the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
this is my first official video for my
own version of game of thrones season 9.
for those of you who don't know i am
writing my own version of what would
happen if hbo decided to make another
season of game of thrones as you all
know the final season of game of thrones
left a lot of fans feeling unsatisfied
some fans thought the final season was
rushed some fans thought everyone was
acting out of character some fans
thought the characters had dumb endings
some fans were mad that a lot of the
mysteries were left unanswered it's no
secret millions of fans were upset with
how game of thrones ended i decided i
would write my own season so i could
make things a little more interesting
than what we were given i want to give
answers to some of game of thrones
greatest mysteries i want to bring back
some of the characters who were
abandoned in earlier seasons i don't
want them sitting on the sidelines like
they were in the final season i will
also be adding certain aspects from the
books that were left out after thinking
about all of this for a few days i
realized this will not be easy i will be
honest i'm not a very good writer that
should be obvious if you have seen a lot
of my videos now i think i have created
some really good ideas for some of the
characters so far but that's about it
writing amazing dialogue and filling in
all the small details is where i
struggle you also have to remember i am
writing each episode over the span of a
few days the writers for game of thrones
had at least six months and they also
had assistance i'm not making these
videos because i think i'm some amazing
author or anything like that i did not
go to school to become a writer i'm sure
i will make a lot of mistakes along the
way i just hope i can give the
characters a more interesting and
hopefully more satisfying ending we
shall see now that i got all of that out
of the way let's jump into the first
episode some of you may have already
seen my recent video where i showed you
my version of the opening scene in that
video i showed scenes from brain stark's
flashbacks and one thing i did not
mention in that video is when bran stark
had the flashbacks if you remember in
brian stark's final scene in game of
thrones he says he will go find drogon
then we see him leave the small council
meeting
well right after that scene bran is left
alone in his bed chamber and when he
goes looking for drogon he also has all
of these flashbacks in that same moment
i will start this video by showing those
again because you will need to remember
those if you're gonna understand how
this season will unfold in the first
flashback scene we are back inside the
three-eyed ravens cave we will see brain
stark the three-eyed raven and leaf
having a conversation
hodor and mira reed are off screen
sitting outside the cave where we have
seen them sit before this is when we
will see the three odd raven and leaf
explain how bran's visions will work
what they say to him is lifted right out
of the books although i did make some of
my own minor changes we hear the
three-eyed raven say a weirwood will
live forever if left undisturbed for
them seasons come and go in the flutter
of a bird's wing and past present and
future are one nor will your sight be
limited to your god's wood the singers
carved eyes into their heart trees to
awaken them and those are the first eyes
a new greenseer learns to use in time
you will be able to see well beyond the
trees themselves now remember what was
said here because this has major
implications for bran stark's abilities
this lets us know bran won't always need
the werewolves for him to be able to see
things it also indicates he might be
able to see future events as well then
we cut to another flashback scene
now we see a massive red building and
standing outside of that building is
hundreds of followers of verlor who are
all dressed in red robes all of them are
looking at the sky but we can't quite
make out what they're looking at after a
few moments we see a giant shadow in the
shape of a dragon fly right over top of
them they look happy for its arrival the
flashback goes to the next scene now we
see arya stark in the woods surrounded
by wolves this was when she reunited
with nymeria and all we get is a glimpse
of this then it flashes to the next
scene brian stark is inside the old
throne room of the red key we're not
able to hear anything at first but we
can see he's having a conversation with
a large man dressed in house stark's
brown leathers with a horrific looking
scar on his face as soon as brain
signals for the man to step in closer
we're suddenly able to hear what he says
next in a low voice bran says when you
return i will make you the master of
whisperers then we go to another
flashback scene now we're back inside
the three-eyed ravens cave we are
looking through the eyes of a raven we
don't see anyone inside other than some
dead bodies and the bones on the ground
it looks like the inside of the cave was
on fire most of the roots of the
werewold are now blackened with ash the
raven takes flight and we begin going
deeper into the cave where no living man
has gone before
some of you might not know this but the
three-eyed ravens cave is actually
massive it's not only one level like we
saw in game of thrones it goes down deep
into the earth
the raven is now flying through complete
darkness after what feels like several
minutes the raven finally lands inside a
chamber we've never seen before
there are lots of candles burning along
the wall the floor is covered in what
looks like hundreds of years worth of
melted wax in the back of the chamber
there are roots of the werewood shaped
into three weirwood thrones the raven
flaps across the room and he begins
walking up and down the roots of the
weirwood
when the bird looks down we can see
there are three very old members of the
children of the forest they have long
white hair with very long white beards
at first they look like they're dead but
right before the flashback scene ends
one of them opens his eyes scaring the
raven away
now these next few scenes happen really
fast now we're in winterfell's godswood
we hear bran say to jaime how do you
know there is an afterwards
what about afterwards
how do you know there is an afterwards
then we see jon stab daenerys in front
of the iron throne
then we see brain and king's landing we
hear him say why do you think i came all
this way
will you lead the seven kingdoms to the
best of your abilities from this day
until your last day
why do you think i came all this way
we see ned stark behead the night's
watch deserter we see the iron throne
before it was melted
then we hear bran say to john you are
exactly where you were supposed to be
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
now some of these scenes indicate bran
stark knew what would happen in the end
now we're back inside the three odd
ravens cave we hear leif explain why
they created the night king
we were at war
we're being slaughtered
our sacred trees cut down
we needed to defend ourselves
from whom
from you
in this final flashback scene we see the
night king when he laid his finger on
the face of one of craster's sons we're
about to finally see what happens after
this
when the baby's eyes became blue the
night king gets back on his horse while
holding the baby
we see him as well as all the other
white walkers ride back to their castle
in the lands of always winter
we follow them as they walk inside the
castle then down a flight of stairs they
enter what looks like a crypt similar to
winterfell's the only difference is
everything in this castle was either
made out of ice or carved into it the
night king bends down to set the baby on
a large block of ice right as the night
king stands back up we get a better view
of just how big this crypt actually is
what it really looks like is an
underground mine shaft that stretches
out like very long fingers into many
different directions it makes one wonder
where they all lead because you can only
see so far into the dark but this isn't
the most shocking reveal right over the
night king's shoulder we can see there
are dozens of babies laying on blocks of
ice the blocks are in single file lines
stretching down each one of the shafts
until they disappear into the darkness
the flashbacks end when we cut to bran
stark sitting in the chair his eyes are
still rolled back in his head but
there's something different about them
they're not as white as they used to be
they have somewhat of a blue haze to
them after a few moments they flip back
to normal then we immediately cut to the
opening theme
like i said before all of these
flashback scenes will happen in the very
first episode before the opening credits
all of them foreshadow some of the major
events that will happen in this season
now i know it took me several minutes to
explain what happened in all of the
scenes but you have to imagine how fast
all of this would happen if you saw it
on the screen yourself each of the
scenes would fly by really fast because
you would be able to see and hear
everything without me having to describe
it all hopefully you will remember all
of this moving forward now let's begin
so after we see brains flashbacks and
then the opening credits the first
official scene will begin out beyond the
wall the sun is just now beginning to
set as we see jon and ghost still
traveling with the small group of
wildlings john and tormund are up front
leading all of them through the dense
forest
you should start back tormund giantsbane
said as the woods began to grow dark
around them
the white walkers are dead the wall is
still broken at east's watch there is no
need for a night's watch anymore there
are no longer any threats living out
beyond the wall john said i don't intend
on staying at castle black ever again
besides i had to swear i would never
ride south
they can have the seven kingdoms i'm
done fighting
with a slight grin on his face tormund
says i knew you had the north in you boy
the real north if you're staying with us
we should stop soon i will make you a
fire i know how you southerners get cold
in the night i can make my own fires
john said half smiling himself then he
says we will set up camp soon we're
almost there
in the following scene we're back in
winterfell where sanja stark is now
queen of the north the scene begins as
we see her and the maester walking
around the grounds of the castle
winterfell is still in shambles there
are dozens or even hundreds of men and
women running around and working in
several different areas we can see there
are men working on the exterior walls of
the castle there are women butchering
meat there are men and women carrying in
large stone blocks it will be years
before the castle looks like it once did
we follow sansa stark as she walks out
to the godswood alone she sits down
under the werewood where we have seen
her and so many other starks sit before
sansa sits there in silence as she looks
around at all the red fallen leaves on
the ground soaking up the white snow
underneath it looks as if she is in deep
thought as she most likely thinks about
everything that has happened to her and
her family after a few more moments of
silence she looks back at the face
that's on the werewood we can hear her
take a deeper breath when she looks at
it the face now looks slightly different
than it did before it still sort of
looks like bran but somewhat darker
there's something about it that makes
sansa feel very uncomfortable because
she immediately looks away from it then
abruptly stands up to leave the godswood
as she begins walking forward she steps
on something making her look down to see
what's under her foot she bends down to
brush away some of the snow whatever it
is she sees is stuck because she has to
yank at it to rip it free from the
frozen ground
she stands back up while holding the
object in her hands sanza isn't sure
what she's looking at but she can feel
it's made out of some sort of metal
suddenly she drops it back in the snow
then she begins rubbing her hands
together hoping to warm them back up
whatever sansa was holding was so cold
she could even feel it through her thick
gloves
sansa doesn't realize it but she had
found the symbol the night king wore on
his armor it must have broken off when
arya stabbed him we now see the maester
walking to the godswood when sansa sees
him approaching she says what is it the
maester says your grace there is
something you should see
as sansa walks away the scene ends as it
focuses on the metallic symbol laying in
the snow
in the following scene we go down to
king's landing where sam gilly and
little sam are finally getting settled
into their new living quarters inside
the red key we see sam as he sets down a
large stack of books on the table we can
see some of the books are about
different subjects like language history
medicine and even magic
gilly asks what are all those for
they just arrived from the citadel says
sam bran has made arrangements for me to
continue my studies while we stay here
with a big grin on his face he says they
will send me new books whenever i need
them i may have been chosen as the new
maester but i still have so much to
learn speaking of books i should send
them back the ones i stole sam walks
across the room and grabs another stack
of books he opens one of them up and we
can see it shows arya's dagger inside
this is one of the books sam stole the
same one he was looking through when he
discovered the dragonglass in season 7.
he looks at the dagger for a few moments
then says i guess we really didn't need
all these books in the end the
dragonglass helped but it was valerian
steel that killed the night king he
slams the book shut then grabs another
one this one says legends of the long
night we saw this book in season seven
as well when gilly was reading it sam
focuses on the front of the book which
looks like it has a skeleton on the
front this skeletal looking creature is
standing on the moon while the sun is
hiding behind him but that's not what
sam is focusing on he looks at its hands
in one hand it has what looks like one
of the white walkers ice swords but in
the other hand it's holding what looks
like a dagger sam looks very confused
right before this scene ends we see him
suddenly grab the other book he opens it
back up then finds the image of the
dagger again he looks at ghillie then
says i will need to write a letter
in the next scene we're on the beach
just below the red key we can see braun
davis and tyrion walking along the shore
we also get a great view of king's
landing from here we get a good look at
just how much was destroyed by daenerys
and drogon we begin following them as
they are walking on the beach why are we
here there are some young ladies waiting
for me in the city you can have them
afterwards when i'm done with them braun
said to tyrion with a sly look on his
face you can have your fun later says
tyrion we still have work to do
this entire city needs rebuilt from the
ground up now he looks at davos and says
you and i both know this city has its
weaknesses even without dragons cities
have rose and fell for thousands of
years it nearly fell the night you and
stannis came across the black water
westeros is on its knees right now
recovering from years of bloodshed with
a large enough force this city could be
easily overran again
overran by who says braun the only
reason this city needs rebuilt is
because of your lovely dragon lady she's
dead we have no enemies right now the
unsolid and dothraki are gone you saw
them set sail the same as i did the
seven kingdoms are actually working
together are they not it's not the seven
kingdoms i worry about says tyrion have
you spent much time across the narrow
sea he says to bronn only a little the
wine is good but i prefer our brothels
said brawn daenerys had her foes
everywhere she went but there are those
across the narrow sea who still love her
i have seen it with my own eyes says
tyrion the seven kingdoms are wide open
right now the unsullied and dothraki
aren't the only armies who have been
decimated look around here do you see
armies in the thousands guarding this
city
no says braun who now looks annoyed we
see tyrion look out across the water
i'm afraid of what might be coming i
don't think i need to remind either of
you drogon is still out there somewhere
he now looks at davos again and says one
day we might look out across this water
and see a new army on the horizon who's
on its way to take this city i just hope
we're ready when that happens in the
next scene we go across the narrow sea
to essos in the city of atlantis this
scene opens up as we see a large banner
flapping in the wind on this banner is a
burning heart the symbol of relore it
sits atop one of the largest buildings
we have ever seen we are now at the red
temple of the lord of light it is
sitting high up on the hill the temple
is a hundred different hues of red
yellow gold and orange it looks as if
the stone was made out of fire itself at
its base just outside of its walls is an
army of what looks like a thousand men
this is the fiery hand an army of slave
soldiers who guard this sacred structure
they're all holding back a crowd of
thousands of followers over lore at the
very top of the steps there are several
high-ranking members of relore each of
them are dressed in red silk robes with
hoods covering their faces each of their
red silk robes are covered in the same
symbols we have seen on melisandre's
necklace one of the men even has the
symbol branded on the center of his
forehead they're all standing in front
of the entrance which has very large
doors that have the burning heart
engraved into them
in front of them is the largest and
deepest brazier we've ever seen with a
fire burning inside that reaches 100
feet into the sky
these high ranking members are standing
in a circle around the fire chanting
something in high valyria
as the chants get louder and louder men
and women in the crowd below begin
weeping the fire starts reaching higher
and higher into the sky
it begins burning so bright everyone in
the crowd has to shield their eyes
swirling around inside this massive fire
is what looks like the head of a dragon
the chanting in high valyria continues
to get louder and louder as the fire
keeps reaching higher and higher into
the sky
the fire is beginning to burn so hot the
army of slave soldiers has to take a
step forward to move away from its heat
one of the men in the red robes feints
falling to the ground as soon as his
body hits the ground his hood falls back
revealing his face we can see his eyes
are rolled back in his head with
blackened blood running out of his nose
suddenly all of the high ranking members
of relore fall silent
right as everyone in the crowd begins
looking at each other wondering what
just happened they hear a sound unlike
anything they have ever heard before it
is the sound of a dragon its screech is
so loud everyone gathered outside now
has to shield their ears those who were
once frightened now have a look of
happiness as a shadow of very large
wings flies over their face
the dragon slams down right on top of
the red temple of her lore as it lets
out another thunderous scream
the dragon flaps its wings again then
lifts off the top of the building now
landing below in front of the main
entrance where the members in the red
robes are gathered in a circle by the
large fire we see it as drogon who
gently lays dany's body down on the
ground someone in a red robe begins
walking forward over to her body when
they're standing over danny's lifeless
body they remove their hood revealing
who they are the scene ends as we see a
smiling kinvara look down at daenerys
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell only now we're down below in
its crips
we can see there are men and women
working down here as well they are doing
everything they can to restore it to
what it once was we can also see several
men wheeling down a new statue of ned
stark as you all know most of the
statues were shattered on the main level
during the battle in winterfell
not all of them were broke due to the
dead breaking out of them however some
of them were simply knocked over and
smashed from everyone running around
down here trying to flee from the attack
it does look like most of the crypt has
been fixed now we begin to follow sansa
stark and their maester as they walk
further into the crypt sansa says it
feels strange being down here again i
usually don't go any further than my
father and aunt statues it has been many
years since i have went this far my
sister and all my brothers loved hiding
down here when they were little i hated
whenever they would ask me to join them
in a game of monsters and maidens or
coming to my castle i was always so
afraid of wandering around these lower
levels don't you worry your grace there
are guards all over this castle ready
and willing to die for you
we're almost there now it's just up
ahead says the maester it's beginning to
get colder and colder as they walk
further and further into the crypt there
aren't as many candles down here either
on the main level there are several
candles at each statue but down here
there is maybe one for every other
statue the faces on the statues are also
beginning to look more and more stern as
they go deeper into the cavernous vault
finally sansa is able to see a few of
their men standing just up ahead when
she reaches them she says what's wrong
why did you have me come all the way
down here we are sorry your grace but we
needed to ask you a question
when does it end said one of the men
when does what end ask sansa the crypt
your grace we have been down here
working for nearly a fortnight we wasn't
sure how far we should go because it
doesn't seem to end
well the statues end but the crypt does
not do you know how far it goes or where
it leads said one of the men my father
always said there are many many levels
down here but i've only been on a few
when i was younger
he would never allow any of us to go to
its deepest level
as soon as you reach that you won't be
able to go any further anyway because he
always said the ceiling was collapsed
down there
we found the collapsed ceiling six days
ago your grace we had several men remove
some of the large stones then we dug out
the rest that is where the statues end
the last few days we have sent men
further than that they say the entire
ground is frozen once you go deeper into
the darkness it doesn't seem to end your
grace sansa says i don't know no one has
ever gone that far before not even my
father the maester says i will look at
all the records maybe there is some
mention of it there is one other thing
your grace said one of the stark men
there are drawings down here on the wall
they look old mayhap's thousands of
years old
drawings of what says sansa this scene
ends as the man says it would be best if
you had a look for yourself your grace
in the next scene we are back out beyond
the wall we're not exactly sure where
this is because everything out beyond
the wall almost looks the same the one
thing we will recognize is the werewood
it might even be the same location where
bran hodor mira and jojen stopped once
before we spend a few moments as we
watch some of the wildlings set up their
camp for the night some of the wildlings
are also skinning animals for later
jon snow makes a large fire for everyone
to gather around then he takes his seat
right in front of the weirwood leaning
his head back against it everyone looks
like they're in good spirits the
children fall asleep almost immediately
while the adults break out the good ale
for a night cap john says you know this
might be the first time i will be able
to sleep out beyond the wall without
having to worry about being killed in my
sleep tormund giant's bane laughs then
says if you don't hand over that drink
you won't have to worry about anything
ever again
now they're both laughing you know i'm
glad you're here with us snow but we
have some long days ahead of us we
should all get some rest while we still
can
everyone begins muttering as they walk
away from the fire
john says you're right as soon as i
finish this drink john takes another big
gulp of his ale then leans his head back
against the weirwood as he closes his
eyes
we see everyone else getting under their
furs around the fire we see ghost
snuggled up right next to jon's feet the
reflection of the fire is glowing inside
his red eyes now we see john again who
looks like he's already fallen asleep as
we look around the fire everything
slowly fades to black but only for a few
moments
we suddenly hear the sound of a soft old
voice that says look for me as we see an
image of the massive weirwood above the
three-eyed raven's cave
look for me
only it's not his voice it's the voice
of someone else now we see the night
king on his horse holding the baby while
they're heading to the ice castle in the
lands of always winter
we see john reuniting with brian stark
we hear john say look at you you're a
man then we hear brain say almost
look at you
you're a man
almost
we see john again but now he's bending
his knee in front of bran
he says i'm sorry i wasn't there when
you needed me
brain says you are exactly where you
were supposed to be
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
we see the massive werewolf above the
cave again we see the night king's
creation
we see arya stab the night king with her
dagger we see bran in the old throne
room of the red key speaking to a man we
have never seen before the man has a
hideous looking scar on his face
now we see daenerys burning everything
in king's landing then the scene fades
to black again
the very last thing we see is a massive
fire burning with smoke all around it
after only a few seconds the fire goes
out we see a silhouette standing within
the smoke as the silhouette steps out
from the smoke we can see they're nude
with a large stab wound in their chest
when they lift up their head we can see
it's dany stepping out from the smoke
johnsono's eyes fly back open as he
begins gasping for breath everyone who
was sleeping around their campfire is
now awake holding a weapon in their hand
wondering what's happening this scene
ends as john looks over at tormund
horrified
okay now before i go to my final scene
in the episode let me just explain one
thing some of you might be wondering how
this happened to john he was able to see
all of these different things because he
fell asleep while his head was laying
against the werewood now what i did was
very different but something like this
does happen in the book jaime lannister
has a very strange dream while he's
laying his head on a weirwood stump
john's was different he's in the north
out beyond the wall this werewood hasn't
been cut down like the one jaime fell
asleep on not only that but jon also has
the blood of the first men as well as a
direct connection to bran stark who is
one with the werewolf net now i don't
want to explain any more than that
otherwise i might reveal too much
information right now
just make sure you remember all the
things he saw from my final scene in the
episode we are out at sea on one of the
stark ships we can see men working
around the ship grabbing ropes moving
the sails carrying things and much more
we will see arya stark emerge from below
the ship with a man who looks like he
might be the captain we hear them
discussing the route she wants to take
as they move west the man says it has
been days since we left sunspear my lady
we will have nothing but the summer sea
ahead of us before we see the arbor good
says arya i can't wait to leave westeros
behind me
the man tips his hat then walks away we
follow arya back below the deck as she
heads for the main cabin as soon as she
enters she shuts the door behind her at
first she doesn't notice there is a man
standing behind her door in the shadow
we're not able to see his face but we
see the light glimmer off his small
dagger when the door shuts he slides the
bolt over locking them inside the room
arya hears the bolt locked shut as soon
as she spins around to see what it was
she sees the man is already lunging at
her they both fall down to the floor as
they struggle for control of the man's
dagger arya finally gets a glimpse of
the man's face but it doesn't look like
she recognizes who it is it's obvious
this isn't the man's first fight
arya isn't able to gain control of the
situation as fast as she'd like what she
does notice is he has a nasty looking
scar that stretches across both sides of
his face after rolling around on the
ground for a while arya finally subdues
the man's arm that's holding the dagger
while she uses her other hand to free
her own dagger from its sheath arya now
has the man in full mount holding his
arms down under her knees she brings her
own dagger up to the man's throat
demanding to know who he is the man
doesn't answer arya shoves her dagger
into his neck just far enough to get him
bleeding arya then says i will let you
live if you tell me who sent you the man
still doesn't answer
she shoves her dagger into his neck a
little further while also using her
other hand to apply pressure to his
throat who sent you the man is now
gurgling there is some blood coming out
of his mouth who sent you she says again
while struggling to breathe the man says
it was the king
arya is stunned she lets go of the man's
throat he immediately grabs at it while
gasping for air arya can't believe what
she just heard it feels like her head is
spinning why would my brother want me
dead arya says
she looks down at the man shocked almost
as if she forgot what just happened he
says let me up you said you would let me
live arya slowly gets up feeling
somewhat dizzy
she says it again
why would my brother want me dead
i don't understand
the man stands back up then heads for
the door
before he can grab the handle arya spins
him back around then slashes his throat
arya just stands there for a few moments
still stunned by what the man said
she drops her blood soaked dagger to the
floor the episode ends as it focuses on
the valyrian steel dagger
the first scene of the second episode
begins in the middle of the night we can
see there is what looks like seven men
walking along the beach away from their
ship six of these men are holding
something very large as they slowly
shift their feet across the sand we
follow them for a few moments before
they finally walk under the full
moonlight allowing us to see who they
are and what they're holding these men
are all dressed in their unsolid
uniforms the six men are holding a
casket as they are following greyworm
who approaches another man waiting for
them at the end of the beach this
unknown man also has several men of his
own standing behind him as greyworm
moves forward the unknown man raises one
of his hands signaling for them to stop
greyworm and his men ignore the request
the man then shouts out what business do
you gentlemen have on the island of noth
greyworm waits until he is standing
right before him then says fulfilling a
promise the other unsullied men set the
casket down in the sand grey worm looks
at it and says this is missandei this is
her home this is where she would want to
be this is where she belongs the unknown
man says missandei is not a name we are
familiar with who was she grey worm
looks back down at the casket and says
my one true love
the unknown man says i see
well in that case allow me and my men to
help you we shall lay missandei of noth
at rest during the following dusk follow
me there is somewhere you must stay
while you're here greyworm's men grab
the casket then lift it back up from the
sand they begin following the men over
to a small building made out of stone
when they reach the building the unknown
man swings the door open and says this
is where you and your men must stay for
the evening grey worm examines the small
stone structure he notices there aren't
any windows he also notices there is
only one door and this door opens only
from the outside greyworm says what is
it why do we stay in this the man says
this is our shelter for our special
visitors greyworm has a confused look on
his face he says shelter a shelter from
what the man smiles and says you're not
very familiar with the island of noth
are you there are over a hundred
different kinds of butterflies on this
island and they're the only thing that
stops soldiers like you from
slaughtering or enslaving everyone that
inhabits it we are not known for our
skill on the battlefield but the
butterflies are the messengers of our
lord you're lucky you and your men
arrived here at nightfall you must stay
in the shelter until you hear a knock on
the door if this door opens while the
sun is in the sky we will be needing
more caskets on the morrow you
understand greyworm nods his head then
him and his men step inside
in the following scene we are back out
beyond the wall where the wildlings had
settled for the night everyone is now
awake gathered around the fire looking
at jon snow who is still sitting beneath
the weirwood
john looks visibly shaken as he takes
another long sip of his ale ghost is now
sitting next to john the albino direwolf
is glaring into the eyes of the werewood
we can still see the reflection of the
fire in his own glowing red eyes ghost
and the werewood have a striking
resemblance they're both white as bone
with eyes as red as blood some of the
wildlings look frightened when they
notice the harris standing up on the
dire wolf's back as he begins sniffing
the ground around the werewolf jon snow
finally looks back at the werewolf
himself wondering if what he saw when he
closed his eyes was real or only a dream
as jon focuses on the weirwood he
notices something red is running out of
its eyes it almost looks as if it's
blood he looks away when he sees tormund
as walking over with more ale he sits
down next to john then fills his cup
back up what's wrong snow did that
dragon lady of yours come back to kill
you in your sleep said tormund who now
has a smirk on his face john doesn't
find that amusing he says maybe she is
before he takes another long drink of
his ale tormund throws his arm around
jon's shoulder then says you have
nothing to fear snow my dreams have been
haunting me for years none of my enemies
have ever killed me when i'm awake
john doesn't respond right away he looks
into the fire for a few moments then
says this wasn't a normal dream
something felt different about it i
heard a voice
now tormund takes a big gulp of his own
ale and says half of the wildlings here
have voices in their heads no what of it
i'm serious says john it wasn't my voice
that i heard a wildling woman suddenly
stands up then walks over to sit down
next to them she looks at john and says
i would like to know what the voice said
well says john
it said
look for me did you hear anything else
what did you see said the wildling woman
john looks over at the werewolf again
then says i saw that only this one was
bigger much bigger it looked like it was
out here somewhere beyond the wall the
weirwood set on a hill overlooking the
snow-covered ground the wildling woman
smiles as she says i know where that is
i have seen it before good says john
make sure everyone is ready at dawn you
will lead the way the woman stands up
then gives a nod in agreement before she
walks away jon now looks over at ghost
who is still sniffing around at the
ground under the weirwood he kneels down
beside him as he runs his fingers
through his white fur
john examines the ground looking for
whatever it is that ghost can smell he
doesn't see anything but dirt and leaves
but he suddenly notices the same thing
ghost does jon's eyes go wider as he
looks over at tormund do you smell that
says john the only thing i can smell is
this burning fire says tormund who now
walks over by jon and ghost he also
watches ghosts as he sniffs around at
the ground what does he smell snow i
don't see anything jon looks back at the
weirwood and stares into its blood-red
eyes this scene ends when jon says it
smells like death
in this next scene we are back in
winterfell below the castle in its crypt
we are following sansa the maester and a
few of the stark men as they head
further and further down into the
darkness the look of fear can be seen on
sansa's face she has never gone this far
before the faces on the statues are of
men she does not recognize
the dead starks look meaner and meaner
the deeper they go
we're almost there your grace the
statues end just right up ahead said one
of the stark guardsmen we can start to
see where this level of the [ __ ] was
once blocked off by the fallen rubble
there are large stones and mounds of
dirt stacked up along the side of the
wall where the stark guardsmen had moved
it when they reached the last statue
sansa stops right in front of it she
says this is the farthest any stark i
know has ever gone my father said it had
been blocked off for many years even
before he was born sansa holds up her
light as she looks around the cavernous
vault this isn't only where the statues
end your grace this is where the candles
and the stone ends as well said the star
guardsmen what do you mean this is where
the stones end said sansa thousands and
thousands of stones were set down here
all throughout the ceiling and the walls
to stop everything from collapsing in on
itself whoever made this [ __ ] stopped
here this is as low as it goes this is
where the stones end said the star
guardsmen
sansa looks at the last statue then says
maybe it was him
she holds her light over the statue as
she looks at its face sansa is suddenly
startled by what she sees the statue's
face seems oddly familiar but there is
something unsettling about it as well
sansa feels as if its eyes are looking
through her into her soul the front of
this statue looks like it's in fairly
good shape considering how old it must
be however some of it is missing the
entire back half of the statue is now
gone sanzo forces herself to look away
we can now see there is a name engraved
into the bottom of the statue it says
brandon stark and right below the name
it also says the king of winter
sansa grabs something that was laying
across his lap she holds it up into the
light for them to see it's the handle
from a very very old sword sansa says my
father always used to say swords were
laid across the laps of each statue to
help keep the vengeful spirits locked
within the crypt the iron from this one
must have rusted away many years ago i'm
not sure it would be of any use now
she drops the broken handle onto the
ground then walks forward the stark
guardsman holds up his light
illuminating what lies ahead he says the
drawings we found are right this way
your grace sansa looks down into the
dark abyss whoever made the underground
passage must have spent years digging it
out you really can't see much ahead but
it looks like it goes on for as far as
the eyes can see sansa says is it safe
you said there are no stones in here
supporting it from falling in
what if it collapses while we're in
there
i wouldn't worry about that your grace
the walls and ceiling feel rock solid
everything moving forward is frozen
sansa the maester and the stark
guardsmen move ahead the scene ends as
they begin fading away into the darkness
in the following scene we are back in
king's landing the sound of steel
hitting steel can be heard from inside
the red key we see swords clash then
spring apart then clash again as brienne
and podrick dance across the map of
westeros on the floor brienne moves to
the right but podrick blocks her with a
quick sidestep and drives her back the
other way brienne now grabs the sword
with both hands then rushes forward
aggressively she brings the sword up
over her head then brought it back down
hard and fast as podrick began to
backpedal he brings up his own sword but
her blow easily knocks it away he sucks
in a deep breath then charges ahead they
sent brienne staggering as she went
reeling on her heels she raises her
sword but podrick knocked it away then
slashed at her again
as brienne regains her footing podrick
lifted his sword high above his head but
he suddenly brings it back down again
when he notices samwell is in the room
watching them
sam is looking at them with a big grin
across his face holding a book in his
hands sam says you know from over here
it looked like he was winning that makes
podrick smile from ear to ear brienne
looks annoyed and out of breath she says
he wasn't winning i was only giving him
a chance to know what that feels like
he's good but he's not that good
sam then says well when he does finally
beat you you will only have yourself to
blame i agree says berean he got all
those moves for me sam then says i am
looking for king bran there is something
he should see he's in his chambers right
now says brienne follow me i will take
you to him sam smiles then gives a head
nod we follow sam and brienne as they
walk across the painted map on the floor
the attack from daenerys and drogon has
still left a large crack on the floor
splitting westeros in half when they
reach what was once the stairs that lead
to the king's chambers we can see they
are now smooth in the fashion of a ramp
this makes it easier for them to
maneuver bran around the castle when sam
and brienne reach the door she knocks
loudly before she says your grace bran
doesn't answer
brienne knocks again then again louder
than before there's still no answer
your grace is everything all right says
sam there is no sound coming from inside
the chambers brienne now looks worried
so she opens the door herself they see
bran is sitting there in silence facing
the fire in the hearth his head is
leaning back slightly with his eyes
rolled back when he hears them in the
room his head snaps forward and his eyes
roll back down
i'm sorry for barging in here like this
your grace but i thought something was
wrong
bran looks over at them acknowledging
that they're there but he looks back at
the fire without saying anything sam
walks across the room while still
holding the book in his hands he sits
down next to bran and says
there is something i wanted to show you
your grace he holds out the book so
brian can see it sam says i found this
book on the legends of the long night
while i was at the citadel at first i
didn't think it had any useful
information but i noticed something
interesting on the front of it i was
hoping i could find out its origin i've
already wrote a letter to the citadel
asking them if they know how old it is
and where it's from or who wrote it
would you be able to help me your grace
sam holds the book out even further
here look for yourself what do you think
your grace bran finally looks down at
the book he grabs it from sam's hands
then studies the image on its cover
he looks at it for a few moments but
then he starts running his finger along
the book outlining the skeleton looking
figure on the front does that look
familiar your grace do you see the
dagger in its hand bran still doesn't
say anything sam looks back at breanne
somewhat confused
bran looks like he's in deep thought as
he runs his finger along the dagger on
the book sam says what do you think your
grace is there anything you can tell me
after a few more moments of silence bran
now looks up at sam with his glaring
eyes bran says no then he throws the
book in the fire
sam and brienne are shocked
they knew bran was a little strange but
they've never seen him show any signs of
aggression before sam looks into the
fire horrified as he watches the book
burn the skeleton looking figure on the
front of the book gets consumed by the
flames why would you do that your grace
that book wasn't mine it belongs to the
citadel it might have been their only
records of the long night bran doesn't
say anything right away he just sits
there watching as what's left of the
book disappears into the flames and
smoke brienne steps forward and says are
you okay your grace bran looks at both
of them then says you said it yourself
sam that book had no useful information
but your grace that was until i saw
bran doesn't let him finish his sentence
because he suddenly says that will be
all for now i would like to be left
alone you are dismissed brienne and sam
look at each other they are stunned by
what just happened the scene ends as
they're walking out of the room in the
following scene we are back out at sea
on one of the house stark ships the
scene opens up below the deck in its
main cabin
the dead man who was sent to kill arya
is still laying on the floor surrounded
by dried blood arya stark is standing
over his body she's discussing what
happened with roughly a dozen stark men
as well as the captain and others who
work on the ship do any of you recognize
this man do any of you know his name do
any of you know how long he has been
with us
get a good look at him he has a very
distinctive scar across his face surely
someone must know who he is all eyes are
now on the dead man laying on the floor
now that arya is getting a good look at
the man she notices he's much older than
he first appeared to be
most of the hair on his head and face is
grey although he is larger than arya he
looks frail he looks like he might be 60
years old the captain says i do not
recognize him my lady i am responsible
for every man and woman who board this
ship yet i don't remember ever seeing
this man
a few of the stark men speak up as well
each of them say they don't know who the
man is either arya shakes her head still
somewhat in denial of the circumstances
what did he want my lady says the
captain did he say anything arya says he
wanted me dead he was hiding behind my
door waiting for me to be alone
he said
arya takes a deep breath then exhales
before she finishes her sentence he said
my brother bran sent him here to kill me
one of the stark men spits on the dead
man's body then says i'm sorry my lady
the man is a liar
why would your own brother our king want
you dead it doesn't make any sense
i know cezaria i don't want to believe
it myself the captain then says maybe
someone else sent him who else would
want you dead do you have any other
enemies my lady
with a slight smirk on her face arya
says
they're all dead my sister sansa said
bran sees things now he has visions he
knows things
he's not the same brother i grew up with
he's different now but i still don't
think he would want me dead the captain
says what should we do now my lady arya
says i need to speak with my brother
right away i have to find out what's
happening
should we stop somewhere soon and send a
raven my lady said the captain arya
shakes her head and says no i don't want
anyone in king's landing knowing what
happened on this ship not yet if my
brother bran really does want me dead i
don't want him to know i'm on my way
back the captain nods his head in
agreement then says very well my lady no
ravens he looks down at the dead body on
the floor and says what do you want us
to do with him arya says throw his body
into the sea the fish can feed on him
four of the stark men lift the lifeless
body from the floor each of them are
holding either an arm or a leg
we follow them out of the cabin and down
the hallway until they reach the main
deck the men swing his body up onto the
railing then they roll him off the ship
into the sea below they stand there
watching and waiting for a moment until
they see the man's body fully submerge
under the water the men walk away back
below the deck we now see one of house
stark's banners flapping in the wind
high up on the ship
right before the scene ends a raven
lands on the stark banner
its eyes are as black as obsidian but
then we see them flash white then black
again
in the next scene we are back out beyond
the wall we are following jon ghost and
the group of wildlings as they are now
heading out further north through the
haunted forest the wildling woman is now
riding on the back of jon's horse as she
guides them to the massive werewood he
saw while he was sleeping as they're
moving through the forest john looks
over at tormund who is only a few feet
away on his horse and says you were
right about what you said back there
right about what says tormund about
daenerys coming back to kill me john
said the weirwood wasn't the only thing
i saw while i was sleeping i did see
daenerys in my dream
she was inside a massive fire just
standing there with a hole in her chest
it felt as if she was looking right at
me
dreams are a funny thing snow some folks
say they've had dreams of all of us
living inside the blue eye of a giant
named macumber says tormund they don't
mean anything the wildling woman says i
have had dreams of me flying on the back
of an eagle maybe you're right says john
maybe it doesn't mean anything this
didn't feel like only a dream though it
felt like something else
you said you stabbed her in the heart
you said you saw her die then her dragon
left with her body i bet she was dropped
out at sea says tormund
john looks over at him again and says
that doesn't mean anything either
you and i both know that dead don't
always stay dead
the night king raised the dead by the
thousands john then sets his hand over
his own chest and says i was also
stabbed in the heart yet here i am
we watch as jon ghost and the wildlings
continue to move forward deeper into the
haunted forest we then see a raven
circling around in the sky just up ahead
right before the scene ends
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell below the castle and it's
crypt sansa the maester and the star
guardsmen are still walking further into
the crypt into the dark abyss their
flickering light is illuminating the
walkway
we can see the ground is frozen there
are icicles and ice crystals hanging
down from the ceiling we can also see
what looks like white and red veins
running along the ceiling when sansa
notices them she says what are those the
maester says those are the roots of the
werewood your grace the drawings are
right up ahead said the star guardsmen
about 100 feet in front of them there
are three more stark guardsmen holding
candles in their hands as they examine
all the drawings on the wall when they
finally reach the three stark men one of
them says we are sorry you had to come
all the way down here your grace but we
knew you would want to see this for
yourself sansa raises her arm to hold
her light up near the wall
we watch as her eyes scan back and forth
studying each of the images we see sansa
taking a deep breath when she notices
something that does look familiar the
first drawing shows a castle that looks
sort of like winterfell only smaller
than what it is now there is also a man
in front of that castle who looks very
similar to the statue in the crypt sonza
says that looks like brandon stark the
old king of winter the maestro says i
think you're right your grace he does
have a striking resemblance to the
statue right next to this is another
drawing of a large weirwood with a man
in front of it surrounded by what looks
like a dozen members of the children of
the forest there is another drawing next
to that this one shows one child of the
forest shaking hands with what looks
like the night king only this one has a
beard like the one we saw on dragonstone
the next drawing shows a very large
grove of werewoods all in a circle
facing inward in the center of this
large grove of werewoods is another
werewood only this one is much bigger
than the rest
it looks like it might be the biggest
weirwood in westeros now this next
drawing shows a beheading there is one
member of the children of the forest who
looks very old he has long white hair
with a very long white beard in his hand
he is holding the head of what looks
like another member of the children of
the forest sansa holds her light up
higher then moves it along the wall a
little further there is one final
drawing on the wall
this one shows a skeleton looking figure
holding what looks like a nice sword in
one hand with a dagger in its other
sansa lets out another deep breath
it's so cold down here you can see the
mist in the air as she exhales i don't
know what these mean says sansa she
looks at everyone else standing there
and says do any of you know what these
are i'm sorry your grace but we do not
says one of the star guardsmen the
maester says do any of your men know how
to draw i'm sure we can find someone who
can said the stark guardsmen why i want
someone to make a sketch of these images
i will send it to the citadel maybe they
can decipher the drawings there said the
maester sansa looks at the maester and
says do you understand any of these have
you seen any of these drawings before
the maester lifts his arm and holds his
finger out to one of the images he says
that one your grace the large werewood
surrounded by the werewood grove there
is only one location in westeros that i
know of that would have a weirwood of
that size the scene ends right as sansa
says where
now in my final scene of this episode we
are back across the narrow sea in essos
in the city of atlantis the sun is just
now beginning to set as we see an even
larger crowd gather below the red temple
of verlor the streets of the city are
now flooded with thousands of followers
of the lord of light drogon is sitting
atop the building overlooking everyone
below
dragon lets out another thunderous
scream
it's equally exciting and frightening
because everyone knows they are
witnessing a historic event the
high-ranking members of verlor who are
all still dressed in their red robes are
all gathered in a circle around
daenerys's body they have her laid out
across a stone block in front of the
massive brazier
they're all chanting something in high
valyria their chanting grows louder and
louder as dark clouds begin to form in
the sky above
everyone in the crowd ducks down when
they hear an ear splitting crack of
thunder in the distance
violent flashes of lightning begin
emerging in the sky
the crowd below grows frantic as the
chanting gets louder and the storm above
grows stronger the ruby necklace on
kinvara's neck is glowing so red hot it
starts burning the symbol into her skin
a red bolt of lightning strikes down
into the middle of the brazier which
causes a small fire to begin burning
inside of it again
suddenly the chanting stops all of the
high ranking members of ralore remove
their hoods then they take a step
forward all of them reach their hands
under daenerys's body then lift her up
into the sky they walk over to the
burning brazier the crowd below erupts
into chaos when they realize what's
about to happen daenerys's lifeless body
is thrown into the flames
now all of the red robes gather in a
circle around the brazier they remove
their necklaces then throw them inside
we watch as the rubies burst open into a
red liquid that almost looks like blood
fire and blood
the small flames are now several
different shades of red and orange
kinvara looks up at drogon her eyes are
now glowing red as well in a loud voice
kinvara shouts dracarus drogon spreads
his wings and lets out another deafening
scream the fire unleashes from his mouth
into the brazier below
there are men and women in the crowd who
are weeping with joy
the flames reach high into the air as
they are licking at the night sky the
storm begins to settle as the clouds
begin to move they reveal there was a
full moon hiding behind them a blood
moon
everyone is now staring into the fire
the reflection of the flames can be seen
in kinvara's glowing red eyes everything
is silent except for the crackling of
the fire
suddenly we hear the sound of thousands
gasping for air as they see a black
silhouette emerge in the flames
as the fire dies down we can see a nude
body standing in the center of the
brazier there is a large stab wound in
their chest there is some black smoke
rising out of it the episode ends as
daenerys emerges through the flames in
smoke
like the first episode of this season
this one will start off by showing us a
cold opening that means we will be
thrown into a scene before the opening
credits even begin the very first scene
of this episode is another series of
flashbacks the first thing we see is a
glimpse of the night king's creation as
leif inserts the dragonglass dagger into
the man's chest then we're back inside
the thread raven's cave this was when
bran realized the night king was made by
the children of the forest we will once
again hear why they did this leaf says
they were at war they were being
slaughtered and their sacred weirwood
trees were being cut down
now this is usually when the scene ends
but now we get to hear what else was
said during the flashback
after elise said why they created the
night king the three-eyed raven then
says
fearing extinction the children combined
their powers for one last spell
that would save their people and their
land from the invaders
by themselves the children were too few
to resist the onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against them
now we flash to something else we see
the night king standing in what looks
like a crypt while holding a newborn
baby boy
the night king is then seen handing this
baby to a child of the forest
this child of the forest is one we have
never seen before we watch it as it
walks away from the night king now
holding the baby until they fade away
into the darkness
now we flash to something else we hear
the mad king say burn them all as we see
daenerys burning down king's landing
then we see brian stark the moment he
becomes the new king of westeros we hear
him say why do you think i came all this
way
let me wear the crown
why do you think i came all this way
[Music]
now we flash to something else we see a
man who looks sort of like the same man
who became the night king only this man
is standing in front of a castle as it's
being built gathered around this man is
a few members of the children of the
forest ones we have never seen before it
looks like they are helping this man
build the castle
now we flash back to the three-eyed
raven's cave we see bran sitting there
as the three-odd raven goes into more
details about the first men of westeros
the children of the forest and why they
made the night king
after hundreds of years and untold
deaths and destruction the wisest heads
of the children and the first men
finally prevailed
the children couldn't win this war and
the first men didn't want to win fearing
the costs of victory
heroes and rulers on both sides met upon
an aisle in the court's eye to form the
pact
now we flash to something else we see a
massive werewolf surrounded by what
looks like a grove of more werewolves
all facing inward the massive werewolf
in the center has an enormous face
carved into it the face on this werewood
is so enormous we actually see its mouth
open and when that happens a child of
the forest walks out of it this unknown
child of the forest is holding a newborn
baby that has bright blue eyes now we
flash to something else we see arya
stark as she is standing in front of
jack and nagar we hear arya say valar
margolis
now we flash to something else we see a
few men with very long beards standing
in the forest they are chopping down a
giant werewolf then throwing its
branches into a fire as the werewood
burns in the fire the crackling in the
flames sounds like the screams of a
thousand children dying
when the smoke rises up from the fire we
see it form the shape of what looks like
the face on a weirwood but none of the
men standing there seemed to notice it
now we flash to something else we see
the massive werewood again surrounded by
what looks like a grove of more
werewoods all facing inward there are
seven members of the children of the
forest all standing in a circle around
the giant werewolf they're all watching
as one of their elders who has long
white hair with a very long white beard
walk forward he stops when he is
standing in front of another child of
the forest who is kneeling in front of
the weirwood we see this elder behead
the kneeling child of the forest the
lifeless body falls to the ground but
the elder is still holding the head by
its hair we see the enormous mouth on
the werewood open up
the elder member of the children throws
the head inside the mouth right before
it shuts now we flash back to the
three-eyed raven's cave we see bran
sitting there as the three-eyed raven
goes into more details about the first
men of westeros the children of the
forest and why they made the night king
the children gave up all the lands of
westeros save for the deep forests
and the first men
swore that they would no longer cut down
the werewoods
thus ended the dawn age and began
the age of heroes
yet after the dawn must come the night
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war returned centuries
later now we flash to something else we
see the massive wherewit again
surrounded by what looks like a grove of
more werewolves all facing inward only
now we see what looks like the shadow of
a dragon flying over the werewoods now
we flash back through the three at
ravens cave we see brain stark sitting
there as the three-eyed raven goes into
more details about the first men of
westeros the children of the forest and
why they made the night king
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only an alliance between the
children and men defeated it
now it comes again
when the children are a shadow of what
they were
and men have long forgotten
but the trees remember
and brandon stark must learn
or
as we watched the first men
so we will watch the last
[Music]
everything now fades to black bran stark
snaps out of his visions gasping for
breath
he looks over his shoulder at the door
worried someone might have walked in
while he was gone
there's no one there as he slows down
his heavy breathing he looks down and
notices both of his hands have a firm
grip on his chair these are the most
intense visions he's ever had
bran finally begins to gain his
composure as he gazes into the fire in
front of him we can see there is a note
laying across bran's lap most likely
something he was reading before he went
into the visions as bran lifts it back
up we get a glimpse of it we can see it
has the broken seal of house stark we're
not able to make out what it says but we
do see there are some rough sketches of
a few different images one of the
drawings shows what looks like a
beheading as well as a very large
werewolf surrounded by other werewolves
before we can see anything else bran
crumbles up the note in his fist then
throws it in the fire
now we see the opening credits and the
theme song
like with all of my flashback scenes
they foreshadow some of the major events
that will happen in future episodes the
flashbacks have answers to some of game
of thrones greatest mysteries which will
be revealed by the end of my season so i
hope all of you are digesting all of
this information
after the opening credits are over we go
to our next scene in the episode we're
back across the narrow sea in volantis
there are still thousands and thousands
of people gathered below in the city
streets the red temple of verlor sits
high on its hill looming above all those
who worship its lord of light kinvara as
well as the other high-ranking members
of relore are dressed in their red robes
standing in front of the massive doors
to the main entrance all of their eyes
are locked on daenerys targaryen as she
steps out of the enormous brazier the
bottom of her feet are now blackened
with ash
grey and black smoke can be seen rolling
out of the large stab wound on her chest
daenerys looks up at drogon who is still
sitting atop the red temple of her lore
when drogon looks into her now opened
eyes he lets out a scream that can only
be described as a cry of ecstasy in
anguish the sound of her dragon makes
daenerys fall to her knees kinvara
rushes over and throws her red robe
around daenerys's naked body
kinvara slowly helps her back on her
feet she says walk with me daenerys
stormborn we should speak inside
four men who are also wearing the red
robes open the massive doors that have
the burning hearts engraved on the front
of them the red temple of verlor opens
up to a great hall of its own
there are over 100 different braziers
burning inside lining all four of the
walls
there is also a very large burning heart
hanging down from the ceiling in the
center of the great hall kinvara helps
daenerys sit down on a stone bench
inside
what do you remember daenerys stormborn
do you know where you are do you
remember what happened daenerys glances
around the great hall but nothing stands
out to her none of this looks familiar
she then looks down at the large stab
wound in her chest her eyes begin
filling up with water as she remembers
daenerys says
i was murdered by jon snow the man i
loved and who i thought loved me
that's right says kinvara you and jon
snow were brought together for a reason
you were brought together to fight
against the great other but you allowed
yourself to be consumed by not only the
force you have while you're on the back
of your dragon but the fear you have in
your heart
the fear of losing what power you still
have
i don't know what happened says daenerys
i mean
i remember what happened but i don't
know why
it felt like something evil was inside
me i never wanted things to end like
this but it was as if i could not stop
it from happening as if something was
moving me in that direction
it felt like something had its grip on
me and would not let go
the lord of light has brought you back
just as the lord of light brought back
jon snow says kinvara you have been
reborn in the great flames overlore his
fire has cleansed your soul daenerys
stormborn now you must never lose sight
again
you once said you wanted to leave the
world better than you found it now you
have another opportunity to do that
neither of you know it yet but you and
jon snow still need each other
no he doesn't says daenerys if he needed
me he wouldn't have murdered me
the night king and his army of the dead
have been defeated cersei lannister is
dead the iron throne is for the taking
i'm sure sansa stark got exactly what
she wanted by naming jon snow the king
kinvara says well you are right about
one thing daenerys cersei lannister and
the night king are dead but you haven't
defeated all of our enemies the great
other still looms over westeros
threatening our very existence what do
you mean the great other says daenerys
with a slight grin on her face kinvara
says there is still so much you don't
know daenerys stormborn
did bran stark ever say who made the
night king
i don't believe he did says daenerys
kinvara helps daenerys back on her feet
she walks her over to one of the burning
braziers canvara glares into the fire
and she says
like i was saying
you may have defeated the night king in
his army of the dead but they weren't
working alone
they have never worked alone daenerys
has a confused look on her face when she
says melisandre never said this
why wouldn't she warn us about other
threats kinvara says
melisandre was but one small instrument
of the lord of light there was only so
much she could do
when melisandre lost her faith she lost
her ability to see everything that lies
ahead the flames only gave her glimpses
but we can see far more daenerys
stormborn our faith has never wavered
and the lord of light has rewarded us
for that kinvara looks deeper into the
flames burning in the brazier
she brings daenerys in closer then says
have a look for yourself
daenerys looks into the fire the
reflection of the flames is glowing red
in orange in their eyes
kenvara says do you see what i mean
daenerys do you see what lies ahead
this is why you and jon snow still need
each other
daenerys has a horrified look on her
face as she realizes what she is being
shown
daenerys says
what do they want
the same thing they have wanted for
thousands of years says kinvara
all men must die
the scene ends right after kinvara says
this is why the new king of westeros has
all of us worried
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell sansa stark the maester and
several lords and ladies of the north
are all gathered below the castle and
it's crypt the lowest level has been
brought back to life now that there are
hundreds of more candles lined up down
here along the walls sansa stark and the
maester are showing the lords and ladies
their recent discovery we hear sansa
stark say we weren't exactly sure what
all of these drawings were maester
walcan had sketches of these images
drawn and sent to the citadel we're
hoping they can help us figure out what
they are we are expecting a response
from them soon we have also sent word to
my brother bran down in king's landing
he does have the ability to see things
others can't if anyone will be able to
shed some light on their significance it
will be him one of the northern lord
says
just how big is this crypt your grace
it seems like it goes on forever and
ever well that's just a thing says sansa
we don't know
one of our guardsmen said he doesn't
know if there is an end
we sent a few more men ahead so we can
see where the underground passage leads
the northern lord says you sent a few
men down there as he looks blindly into
the darkness that's only a hundred feet
in front of them they must be braver men
than i am your grace i wouldn't want to
find out what's on the other end i would
have sealed this back up immediately we
may do that says sansa but not until we
find out how this got here
she holds her light up higher
illuminating the drawings on the wall
maester walken says this drawing of the
large werewood surrounded by the grove
of werewoods is in the south near
harrenhal do any of you recognize what
these other images are the northern
lords and ladies study the drawings for
several minutes examining them one by
one
this one your grace i think i know what
this one is says the northern lord
that looks like the children of the
forest your grace the drawing of the
beheading are you sure says sansa why
would the children of the forest behead
each other sansa looks at maester wolkan
and then says are you familiar with this
story the maester shakes his head back
and forth know your grace i am not there
are legends of the children of the
forest fighting with the giants and
going to war against the first men but i
don't recall ever hearing anything about
them killing one another all records
state that after they fought the first
men their numbers were extremely low
many would say that's why they're no
longer around now and others would even
say they never existed at all
i don't know why they would be fighting
each other but if they did
i suppose that wouldn't make them that
much different from us your grace men
have been fighting and slaughtering each
other for thousands of years sansa says
i must speak with my brother bran he
will know what to make of all this
the scene ends after the maester says if
these drawings are accurate your grace i
fear of learning what drove these small
creatures to such violence
in the next scene we are back on the
island of noth there are roughly 100 men
and women gathered on the beach under
the light of the full moon during the
end of masande's burial ceremony most of
the men standing on the beach are grey
worms men who are all still dressed in
their unsolid uniforms as is grey worm
there are some island natives that are
attending the ceremony as well as the
men who greeted greyworm on the beach
the night he arrived everyone is
standing in a circle gathered around
missandei's casket while holding a white
rose in their hands the smell of salt
water is thick in the air there is a man
that has brown skin and black hair
sitting next to the casket singing what
sounds like a very beautiful song in a
language we have never heard before
after the man finishes his song the
unknown man who has been helping grey
worm walks over to him and says
i am sorry for your loss i did not know
missandei of noth but i am glad you
brought her back home
she must have been someone very special
for you to bring her all the way here
from westeros she was and still is says
grey worm
i don't know what i will do now that she
is no longer here with me i thought i
would stay here with her for the rest of
our lives but it will not be the same
without her i don't think the rest of
your men want to stay here says the
unknown man it wouldn't be very safe for
all of them either unless they all want
to squeeze into that shelter with you
that won't be necessary says grey worm
right over his shoulder we can see he
brought about one dozen ships with him
from dany's fleet the three-headed
dragon can still be seen on their
banners and sails the rest of greyworm's
men are still on the ships waiting and
watching as the ceremony nears its end
well where will you and your men go next
says the unknown man grey worm looks out
across the summer sea and says i don't
know
but we will be gone before the sun rises
have you ever been to volantis says the
unknown man it's not far from here it's
right on the other side of this sea a
few of our silk traitors just arrived
this morning i overheard them discussing
something they said they saw while
leaving volantis now the man was drunk
so i doubt he can be believed but i
heard him say he saw the shadow of what
he thought was a dragon flying over the
city as they were boarding their own
ship grey worm's eyes lock on his as he
grabs him by the arm a dragon says grey
worm are you sure that's what he saw the
unknown man says no i can't be sure
because i wasn't there with them but
that's what i heard one of them say
the man was drunk his words were slurred
you know how men are they swear their
journeys are far more dangerous than
they actually are i heard all of the
dragons are dead i doubt the man saw
what he says he saw
grey worm lets go the man's arm
he walks over to some of the other
unsolid men who are standing on the
beach greyworm says drogon is across the
sea in volantis get our men and our
ships ready we will be leaving soon in
the following scene we are inside the
library of the citadel the archmaester
ibros whoever saw samwell studies while
he was there is sitting alone at a desk
reading a letter we're not able to see
who wrote the letter or what it says but
it was sent from someone within the red
keep of king's landing because it has
the broken seal of the three-eyed raven
after the archmaester finishes reading
the letter he rolls it back up then
slides it inside his sleeve he stands up
then walks across the library to the
other side when he reaches the gate of
the restricted area he sticks his hand
inside of his other sleeve then removes
the key the archmaester unlocks the gate
walks inside then shuts it and locks it
behind him the archmaester walks over to
the bookshelf that sits along the back
wall in the middle of the shelf there is
a book on werewoods when he grabs this
book it causes the whole shelf to slide
over revealing there is a hidden room
behind it even though restricted area
has a restricted area when he steps
inside the hidden room the bookshelf
slides back behind him
there is only one shelf inside the
hidden room as well as what looks like a
metal lock box that has more books
inside the archmaester opens up the book
about werewolves then flips to the back
where another key is hidden
he opens up the lockbox then removes the
deck of books the first book has an
image on the front of it it looks like a
member of the children of the forest
standing next to an unknown man
right under that image it says the
origin of but we can't see what it says
after that because the archmaester sets
another book down on top of it on the
front of the next book it reads a
detailed history of the lord commanders
at castle black the next book the
archmaester sits down has an image of a
weirwood grove on the front of it
this one says the mysteries and legends
of the isle of faces he sits down
another book that just says the birth of
dragons
the next book says the works of brandon
the builder it looks like there may be
an image of winterfell as well as the
citadel on the front of it when
archmaester ibros grabs the next book he
has to wipe the dust off of it before he
can read it himself we don't get to see
what this one says but it must be what
he was looking for because he grabs the
other stack of books then locks them
back inside the small metal box he
stands back up while holding the book he
wants down at his side he walks over to
the wall then knocks on it three times
this makes the bookshelf slide back open
again allowing him to leave the hidden
room as we see him walk away the
bookshelf slams shut again ending the
scene
in the next scene we are following
samwell as he walks through the red key
he walks across the old thorn room
inside the great hall
there is still a massive hole in the
side of the red keep where drogon had
blew out a hole in the side of the
building there is what looks like over
100 ravens walking around on the floor
sitting on different ledges and flying
in and out of the great hall
brain stark has definitely made himself
at home
sam walks out of the old throne room and
we keep following him until he reaches
the new chambers of the hand of the king
he stops in front of the door then
knocks softly the door is opened up by
tyrion lannister who says hello samwell
how may i help you in a low voice sam
says do you mind if we speak inside not
at all says tyrion would you like a
drink no thank you says sam as he walks
in the room then shuts the door behind
him
before sam sits down he notices one of
the windows is open he walks across the
room then shuts it as well tyrion has a
sly smile on his face when he says ah
yes
i see you are now a man of secrecy
samwell now i know i am living in king's
landing again i suspect you must have
something good to say otherwise you
could have said it earlier during the
small council meeting sam sits down next
to him then says i do
kind of but i'm not sure good is the
word i would use for it i'm a little
concerned says sam
have you noticed bran has been acting a
little strange lately
well stranger than usual
no i don't think i have says tyrion
the boy has seemed a little off since i
first met him but that doesn't come as a
big surprise to me
we've all been changed by what we have
been through over the years i'm sure
he's fine all things considered besides
this is his first time living in king's
landing i'm sure he will adjust i still
remember when i first moved here i hated
it but this city does have a certain
charm to it when it's not always
consumed by death destruction deceit and
backstabbing actually now that i think
of it king's landing has no charm
whatsoever i still hate it here but we
will have to make do this is our home
now as it is king brands what makes you
say this samwell did he say something to
you
well not exactly says sam
it's not what he said it's what he did i
was looking through one of the old books
from the citadel and i noticed something
interesting i was hoping bran could help
explain what it means but when i handed
him the book he threw it into the fire
then he just sat there watching it burn
before he made brian and i leave his
room
well
that certainly doesn't sound like
something brain would do says tyrion i
have never seen him act like that before
did he say anything else
he did says samwell
he said the book had no useful
information
we see another smile come across
tyrion's face before he says oh i see
well he might be right about that what
do you mean says sam
you and i both know bran can see things
that have already happened
somewhere deep inside that mind of his
he has access to the entire history of
westeros he must have thought the book
was no longer needed since he may
already know the answers you were
looking for
well that's just a thing says sam he
never gave me any answers it was like he
didn't want me to know
that book wasn't mine it belongs to the
citadel we can't go and destroy all of
its written history otherwise it will be
lost forever if something were to happen
to bran i understand your concern says
tyrion let me go speak with him
thank you says samwell
he stands back up then he heads for the
door
when sam opens the door tyrion says now
before you go i want to ask you
something you said there was something
interesting you discovered in the book
what was it
in the final scene of this episode we go
out beyond the wall
john ghost and the wildlings are still
moving through the forest as they search
for the wherewood he saw while he was
sleeping the moon is a crescent thin and
sharp as the blade of a knife a murder
of ravens are following them in the sky
the sound of leaves are whispering in
the wind we're almost there says the
wilding woman who is still riding on the
back of john's horse ghost is leading
their pack he's been sniffing at the
ground as he moves forward almost as if
he's following someone or something sent
ghosts stopped suddenly
at the bottom of a steep stretch of
unbroken white snow
the direwolf looked back at john sniffed
the air then snarled we're here said the
wildling woman
about 80 yards in front of them was a
massive weirwood sitting on the hill
above the three at raven's old cave
that's it says john that's what i saw in
my dream when they reached the front of
the weirwood john says we will set up
camp here for the night have some of the
men find wood for a fire i want to go
have a look around inside the cave the
rest of the wildlings wait outside while
jon goes tormund and the wildling woman
go inside
they follow the roots of the werewood
which look like dark white snakes
slithering in and out of the earth
around them
ghost is leading them once again as if
he knows where to go
as if he has been here before
jon runs his fingers along the roots of
the weirwood when he looks at them his
fingers are blackened by the ash he says
someone must have lit a fire in here it
looks more like something exploded in
here says the wilding woman
there are thousands of bones all over
the ground
jon notices some of them don't look as
old as the rest when the cave opens up
in the center they all stop when they
see what looks like a throne made of
weirwood
ghost is still sniffing the ground
moving around some of the bones with his
nose
jon sees the skull of a bear and the
skull of a wolf there are dozens of
human skulls and near as many giant
skulls that have been crushed all the
rest were small and oddly shaped they
are the skulls of the children of the
forest the roots had grown in and around
and through them every one
a few ravens are sitting atop them
watching them enter the cave with their
bright black eyes that are full of
secrets do you think the white walker
stayed in here says tormund
i don't know says john i don't think so
ghost begins rubbing himself against
john's leg
when he looks down at his direwolf he
notices he now has something in his
mouth at first john thought that it
might have been a bone but on the second
look he notices it has a metallic shine
to it he yanks it free from ghost
he studies it for a moment but then his
eyes go wide when he realizes what it is
the wildling woman says did he find
something what is it
i think this was my brother bran's says
john
he holds it up by the light so the
others can see
it has the sigil of house stark on it
bran used to wear this around his neck
says john
this must be the same cave he mentioned
before bran was here
now ghost begins snipping at jon's
fingers trying to get his attention what
is it boy says john what's wrong
ghost's eyes are glowing red
john bends down as he is about to say
something else but then ghost starts
forward into the darkness that lies
ahead we should follow him says the
wildling woman the sound of flapping
wings can be heard echoing off the cave
walls they go deeper then deeper not
knowing how far it goes the scent of
blood and smoke is still in the air do
you hear that says john
it sounds like there is rushing water
below us i can hear too says tormund it
sounds like an underground river they
keep following the glowing red eyes
further and further down until some
flickering light can be seen bouncing
off the cave walls ahead someone or
something is down here with them
i'm afraid of what we might find says
the wildling woman
whatever is down there is leading me
here says john
once again the cave opens up into a
larger chamber there are candles burning
down here along the wall
there are also large mounds of melted
wax all over the ground it looks as if
there have been candles burning down
here for hundreds of years
even with their added light it's still
hard to see what's inside the chamber
it's not until they all walk into the
center when they can finally see what's
there waiting for them in the shadows
there are three white werewood thrones
flecked with red
fashioned out of the living roots with
dead branches woven through them they
look exactly the same as the one the
three had raven set in on the main floor
of the cave the only difference is there
is something else sitting on these
werewolf thrones there are three small
creatures all staring at jon snow they
are three little wise men of the
children of the forest who have nut
brown skin dappled like a deers with
spots in large years they could hear
things that no man could hear their eyes
are big as well great golden cat's eyes
that could see in the dark where a man's
eyes only saw blackness
their hands only have three fingers and
a thumb
with sharp black claws instead of nails
there are ravens walking up and down
their little arms
ghost walks over by them then lays down
in front of their thrones
who are you said jon snow
some men call us the singers while
others call us the children of the
forest said the one sitting in the
middle we are as you see us and now you
will understand why we could not come to
you except in a dream we have been
watching you we have seen your birth and
your father's before you
we saw your first step and heard your
first word and now you have arrived at
last jon snow though the hour is late
just as it was late for brandon stark
my brother says john
so he was here
he was said the child of the forest and
that's why you are here now
we're afraid your brother is in grave
danger
he needs you now more than ever jon snow
i i don't understand says john
what do you mean he is in danger how the
night king and the army of the dead are
gone
why would he need me now
did he ever say how the night king was
created said the child of the forest you
should know jon snow we showed you in
your dream
john sits down
then inhales a deep breath as he shakes
his head remembering what he saw when he
leaned his head against the werewolf and
shut his eyes
he finally says
the children of the forest made the
night king
the wildling woman and tormund
unsheathed their weapons and stepped
forward
wait says john
he gets back up then stands in front of
them
before any new bones get added to this
cave i want to hear what else they have
to say
they brought me here for a reason i want
to find out why
give us the full story
why was the night king created
why are there bones all over this cave
why are you hiding out here beyond the
wall
why is my brother bran in danger
i'm sure you are familiar with some of
our story already said one of the
children of the forest
thousands of years ago westeros belonged
to us
those you have named the singers and the
children of the forest
this was our land this was our home
until your ancestors invaded it when the
first men arrived in westeros
thousands of your ancestors began to
settle in our lands it wasn't long
before they started settling in more of
our lands further and further north
until we had to leave our own home
they began destroying everything that we
held sacred
all that was left for us was the deep
forest the first men had brought with
them new gods horses and even weapons of
bronze that we could not match they were
also bigger and stronger than us
threatening our very existence we had
warriors of our own who your ancestors
would name the wood dancers but even
with our secret arts of dark magic we
could only slow down the advance of the
first men
our greenseers and skin changers even
binded direwolves and monstrous
snowbears cave lions and eagles and
serpents and more to their will
but the first men had us outnumbered
they slaughtered almost everyone we knew
we were on the brink of extinction
unfortunately it drove us to act out of
desperation
we felt like we had no choice if we were
to not only save our own kind but our
beautiful lands as well
that's when you made the night king said
jon snow
he sits back down
the wildling woman and tormund sheathed
their weapons and sit down as well
we fought as fiercely as the first men
did to defend our lives yet it wasn't
enough said the child of the forest who
is sitting in the middle throne one day
we discovered there were some first men
living among a few children of the
forest in the north the children who
came before me did not like the idea of
the first men and the children of the
forest laying together especially when
we were at war with one another we
captured and sacrificed one of these
first men who would become the night
king
it was this act that shifted the battle
back into our favor it wasn't long
before the first men gave up and began
fleeing from the north opening our lands
back up this was all we wanted
we wanted the fighting to end and we
wanted the first men to stop chopping
down our sacred werewoods
the first men finally agreed the wisest
of your race in ours met upon the god's
eye and this is where we negotiated your
ancestors would get the open lands while
ours would get the forest the first men
would stop cutting down our werewolves
while we would end the night king's
reign
but that never happened said john
if you entered the night king's reign
thousands of years ago then how did he
come back
we did end his reign said the children
of the forest the night king that you
saw us create in your dream wasn't made
of ice like the one you fought this
night king was only a man by light of
day but the knight was his to rule
when we agreed with the first man to end
the war we brought the night king down
on his knees before a heart tree in the
north where he was from
a bronze sickle was hooked around his
throat right before it was slashed i
watched as his feet drummed against the
earth
afterwards his body was thrown into a
stone cell deep beneath the ground this
is when we entered what you men call the
age of heroes
this was when the children of the forest
and the first men lived amongst each
other for many many years but there was
a new storm on the horizon
not all of our ancestors were happy
about our new living arrangement with
the first men
the gods gave us long lives but not
great numbers even in those days we were
few
yet in this new world the first men had
built there still wasn't room for us
this is what led to the war between the
children of the forest you won't find
this in your books of written history
this is the story that's forgotten in
the north but the werewolves remember
some of us were willing to coexist with
the first men but there were others who
still wanted the first men dead there
were others who still wanted all of our
lands back
in the south there are children of the
forest who are roth in the south there
are children of the forest who hate and
swear a bloody vengeance in the south
there are children of the forest who
fight and kill
they begin slaughtering and sacrificing
any of us who would not stand beside
them
this is what fractured the children of
the forest as well as our secret arts of
dark magic this is when the long night
fell over westeros this is when the
night king returned
for our own survival we had to leave our
homes in the south and flee here to the
far north our race has been split ever
since
that winter lasted for an entire
generation
they nearly succeeded in that war
but with the aid of another man from the
north we were able to push the white
walkers and the night king back into the
lands of always winter i think i know
this part of the story says jon that's
when you built the wall so you could
keep the night king and his army in the
north under your watch
did you see all of the bones when you
entered this cave jon snow the small
ones are from members of our own race
when your brother bran was in this cave
it was attacked by the night king and
the white walkers again the night this
cave was attacked they killed the last
of us living in the north now ask
yourself this jon snow if the night king
is our enemy just as he is yours then
why would we live north of the wall
where the night king and the army of the
dead were hunting
why would we choose to live on this side
of the wall with the night king when he
wants us dead
because you felt safer living beyond the
wall surrounded by the night king in his
army of the dead then you did in the
south among the rest of your own race
says john
very good now you know something jon
snow
says the child of the forest sitting on
the werewolf throne in the center when
brain left the north we began losing
more and more of our influence over his
abilities now you know why bran is no
longer the same brother you once knew he
will only lose more of himself the
longer he is in the south it's not only
bran who is in danger now
all of westeros is threatened
i know you must have so many questions
jon snow but you should leave soon
as we said when you first arrived the
hour is late you must go south while you
still can
john shakes his head in disbelief
he shuts his eyes as he absorbs all this
new information
i can't believe this is happening again
says jon i thought it was over
i feel like i have been living in a
nightmare i can't wake up from
tormund giantsbane throws his arm around
john's shoulder and says
if you must go south again you know i
will ride with you
with his head in his hands john says
what should we do
how do we finally end this
we thought you might ask that says the
children of the forest we won't be
sending you out on your own
we have someone who will help you along
the way
john the wildling woman and tormund all
look at each other confused who's going
to help us says john
me said a voice from the shadows in the
back of the chamber the sound of boots
scraping against the bones on the ground
startles ghost the direwolf jumps up the
glowing red eyes dart back and forth as
he looks into the darkness suddenly a
man steps out from the shadow and says i
will be coming with you jon snow
who are you says john
how long have you been hiding down here
in the dark i was a good friend of your
father's
my father says john the man says you
don't remember me jon snow but i was
there the day you were born
the man reaches out his hand so he can
shake john's the episode ends right
after the man says my name
is helen reed
in the opening scene we are back in the
city streets of king's landing the sun
is just now beginning to set as we see
wagons full of new arrivals entering the
city king's landing is obviously still
in shambles but now that everyone
believes things are stable in westeros
again they're starting to travel to the
different kingdoms
the capital of westeros is starting to
look alive again although it does still
need a lot of work we then begin to
follow one of the wagons down the street
there are men and women all over working
on making king's landing a thriving city
like it once was there are men lifting
heavy stones off the ground there are
women sweeping the street shaking the
dust out of their rugs as well as fixing
up some of the bait shops warehouses and
small markets the scent of raw sewage
and baked bread is in the air the wagon
stops in front of a building where a few
men are standing outside laughing and
drinking their wine a man and woman get
out of their wagon before they walk
inside there are half naked women
dancing and sitting in the laps of a few
men who are seated around the table
where drinks are being served there's
also a few young men lifting a new
barrel of ale there's a woman sitting
alone fixing her hair it looks like
everyone is enjoying themselves we
suddenly hear a voice that sounds
familiar in the back of the room there's
three men sitting at a small table
drinking and sharing their war stories
one of the men is brawn the other men
sitting with him are from the stark's
household guard whose sons are left
behind for her brother bran as brawn
drinks his ale one of the stark men says
so sir brown of the blackwater lord of
high garden or whatever your name is
these days what's it like sitting on the
king's small council
well says brawn i imagine it's about as
boring as it is working for the stark's
household guard most of my days are
spent sitting around wondering how much
longer i can stay in this city i have my
own castle now gentlemen why would i
want to stay in this godforsaken
hellhole the stark man says really
you're not fond of the capital let me
ask you something else how did someone
like you end up in that position anyway
the same way i became bruno the black
water says braun eventually the
lannisters do pay their debts they all
begin laughing
brawn then says why do you keep asking
so many questions anyway the stark man
says i have worked for house stark for
many years yet i can't figure out why
one of ned stark's children would allow
you on their small council this is when
braun stops smiling he sits down his
drink stares hard at the man then says
you should watch your mouth i like
drinking with you fellas but don't let
my new fancy clothes and my new fancy
titles fool you besides i don't think
king bran does much thinking about me
anyway in fact i'm not sure he does much
thinking at all
i like him i really do but there's
something strange about that boy what do
you expect says the star guard most of
his family is dead he has been out
beyond the wall surrounded by white
walkers he has seen things no kid should
ever see is that right says brawn like
what
all of my family is dead i've been out
beyond the wall it wasn't that scary i
saw a man die a slow death when i was
only 5 years old what of it
brawn finishes his drink then slams it
down when he stands up he stumbles a
little bit before walking away he
mutters something under his breath right
as he reaches the door after he walks
out of the inn we watch him as he heads
back down the street in the direction of
the red keep right before the scene ends
we see a raven land on the wagon that's
sitting right out front
in the next scene of this episode we are
back in the north somewhere near
winterfell deep beneath the ground we
are following three men as they walk
further and further into the darkness
searching for an end
we should start back says one of the
younger star guardsmen i don't think
this will ever end we have already been
walking down here for several days if we
don't find something soon we will have
to start rationing out the food the
young star guardsman looks very nervous
as if he can send something is down here
with them
six days they had been walking north and
then northwest and then north again
farther and farther from winterfell's
crypt each day had been worse than the
day before the more they walk the colder
and darker it gets the ground is still
frozen the white and red roots of the
werewolf are still running along the
ceiling although they look more like the
veins inside a man's arm does the
darkness frighten you says the commander
of the stark guardsman there's nothing
down here except for the icicles the
darkness and one scared boy
you can run back to winterfell if you'd
like but your grace has given us orders
we are not to stop until we find the
exit the three men keep moving forward
into the unknown as their light bounces
off the wall we can see the ice crystals
glistening all over the ground as well
as the walls and the ceiling there is a
red sappy-like substance dripping down
from the roots of the weirwood
suddenly all three of the stark
guardsmen stop when they notice
something ahead the underground passage
opens up into what looks like a cave it
almost looks like the three-eyed ravens
cave the only difference is there aren't
any bones in this one there isn't any
weirwood thrones in this one either the
men walk in a little further as they
hold up their lights we can see that the
cave is now connected to seven different
passageways all heading in different
directions the men look at each other in
disbelief
in a low frightened voice the young
stark guardsman says what do we do now
how will we know which way to go we
won't says the commander we will just
keep moving forward and if it's a dead
end we will try another one the men move
on straight ahead as their lights fade
away into the black abyss
in the following scene we go back out
beyond the wall
jon snow the wildling woman and torm and
giant spain are walking back outside of
the three-eyed ravens cave all of the
other wildlings are at their campsite
gathered around the fire right out front
the wildlings begin to stand up as they
see them finally walking back out of the
cave when they reach the fire tormund
addresses all of them by saying this is
where we will have to go our separate
ways now
all of you can stay here if you want or
you can even make shelter inside the
cave but john and i will be leaving to
go south
south i thought you weren't allowed in
the south says one of the other
wildlings well it is complicated says
john i had no intentions of ever riding
south again but my family needs me they
will have to understand i can't say that
i'm sad to see you go says the wildling
man he smiles then gives giants bane a
hug
he then shakes jon's hand before walking
back over by the fire john walks over to
the wildling woman who helped him find
the cave he says i never did thank you
for helping me
it's alright says the wildling woman if
things go your way in the south i guess
i should be thanking you
john smiles and says i never did get
your name the wildling woman walks over
near him when she is standing in front
of john she holds out her hand then says
my name is val
jon shakes her hand and says thank you
val she smiles and says i wish you good
fortune before walking away jon watches
as she sits back down by the fire
deep down he doesn't want to leave but
he knows he has to that's when jon feels
a hard and heavy hand slap him across
the back right as tormund says are you
ready snow she will be here when you get
back let's go
john nods his head in agreement then
follows him back inside the three at
raven's cave they follow the roots of
the weirwood further and further down
until they're deep below the ground
again
there are even more ravens than before
sitting on the skull scattered across
the cave floor the sound of rushing
water can be heard below there is
flickering light bouncing off the cave
walls just ahead when they walk back
inside the cavernous chamber jon sees
helen reed running his fingers through
ghost's thick white fur the direwolf's
eyes are glowing red like fresh blood
helen reed stands up then walks away
after jon takes several more steps he
suddenly stops in his tracks when he
notices something is different right in
front of them is where the children of
the forest are sitting in their weirwood
thrones only now one of them is gone
the child of the forest who was sitting
in the middle is no longer there this
startles jon they look so old and
interwoven with the branches he did not
think they could leave let alone walk
helen reed fades away into the shadows
behind the weirwood thrones john looks
around the cave but he doesn't see
anyone else there where did he go says
jon why would he leave now
the two remaining children of the forest
don't say anything at all they only
stare at john their great golden cat's
eyes look as if they're full of wisdom
deeper than the roots of the weirwood
that surrounds them helen reed
re-emerges from the shadows he walks
over by jon snow looks him right in the
eyes then says you will not see him
again he has gone from here jon snow
helen reed then hands something to john
he had a weirwood bow in his hands
carved with a dozen faces inside the
bowl is a white paste thick and heavy it
has dark red veins running through it
you must eat this said halland he handed
john a wooden spoon john looked at the
bowl uncertainly what is it says john
it's made of weirwood seeds said one of
the children of the forest
something about the look of it made jon
feel sick the red veins were only
werewood sappy thought but under the
light they looked remarkably like blood
he dipped the spoon down into the
substance then hesitated
why are you giving me this as john i'm
not hungry
the child of the force says you have the
blood of the first men as well as the
blood of the dragon jon snow
the werewood seeds will help awaken the
gifts inside you the gifts you did not
know you have we only knew one other man
who had the blood of the first men and
the blood of the dragon that man was
lord brendan rivers who said in the
wherewit throne above us he was once the
lord commander at castle black just like
you but then he came to us and he became
something so much more
you must eat it jon snow you will need
it for your journey that lies ahead john
ate it it was bitter
the first spoonful was the hardest to
get down he almost wretched it right
back up the second spoonful was better
the third was almost sweet the rest he
spooned up eagerly it actually tasted of
honey of new fallen snow of cinnamon and
other flavors he loved the empty bowl
slipped right from his fingers and
clattered on the cavern floor
ghosts ran over then licked what was
left in the bottom of the bowl i don't
feel any difference at john what happens
next now we will leave says helen reed
he walks back behind the wherewit
thrones again when he reemerges he has
something else in his hands wrapped
under a fur blanket john notices that
whatever it is it has a strap around it
allowing helen reed to sling the object
over his shoulder when halen is done he
looks at them and says let's go
john and tormund begin to follow him out
of the cavernous chamber right before
they walk out one of the children of the
forest says one last thing
do not go back above ground jon snow
stay in the cave then follow the roots
of the weirwood until you get further
south we do not need horses down here
our way is faster
john is befuddled he knew the cave went
far into the ground but he did not know
it went south i will show you the way
says helen reed ghost runs off in front
of them he moves through the shadows as
if he knows where to go
he moves through the darkness as if he
has been this way before
the scene ends as we watch the men
follow behind the direwolf before they
begin fading away into the dark abyss
in the following scene we are back out
at sea the sails of house stark are high
in the sky under the light of the sun
the morning air is hazy from the smoke
of the cockfires as a dozen men set down
to break their fast beneath the banners
of the great house of winterfell arya
stark emerges from below she walks back
out onto the main deck then takes in a
long deep breath of that sweet morning
hour she goes over to where the men are
sitting down having their food arya
grabs a fistful of baked bread before
she stood over by the rail and looked
out across the sea at some southern land
she has never been there are several
small islands near the horizon from here
it almost looks beautiful the deep blue
sea was glistening from the sun shining
down it is a gorgeous day but it looks
like there is a storm ahead just above
the small islands that set off in the
distance
she stands there for a few moments
looking at all of her surroundings as
she nibbles on the food
that's when arya is interrupted when she
hears the sound of a seagull as it lands
on the rail of the ship she breaks off
some of her bread then throws it up into
the sky
the seagull leaps off the rail opens its
mouth wide then snatches the bread out
of the sky arya smiles then throws the
rest of her bread onto the deck
as she begins walking away another sound
is heard only this one is from above
when arya looks up a raven lands on the
enormous sail of the ship then it let
out another loud shriek that's when arya
notices there is something different
about this raven she watches as the
raven's eyes go from black to white then
back to black again arya suddenly has a
feeling of dread wash over her it's as
if the raven is looking right through
her arya slowly walks away until she
vanishes below the deck it's only a few
moments later when she re-emerges only
now she has a bow and arrow in her hand
arya watches the raven as she walks back
over by the railing its eyes go from
black to white then back to black again
arya notches one of her arrows then
draws the string back hard she holds the
arrow back as she also holds her breath
the raven's white eyes are looking right
at her almost as if it's challenging her
to let the arrow fly that's when arya
lets it loose the arrow slices right
through the morning air but it misses by
only a few inches the raven did not move
arya grabs another arrow notches it then
draws it back as far as she can
she looks over at the stark banner
flapping in the wind waiting only a few
seconds for it to be in her favor the
moment she releases the string the raven
takes flight from the sail arya watches
as her arrow hits nothing but the sky
before falling into the sea below the
raven lets out another loud shriek as it
circles above
one of the men who is sitting at the
table says i'm sorry my lady you almost
had it arya doesn't respond she walks
back across the ship over to where the
captain is standing at his wheel
when he sees that arya is approaching he
bows his head then says good morning my
lady i see you were sharpening your
skills at archery it's not so easy when
a ship is rocking back and forth beneath
you arya says do you know where we are
the captain smiles and says well of
course my lady i would not be a very
good captain if i did not he holds out
his finger motioning in front of him
those small group of islands you see in
the distance are the step stones my lady
now if you look over here to the west
can you see that speck of land near the
horizon yes i do says arya well you're
now looking at dorn my lady thank you
cesaria
she looks back up into the sky right as
the captain begins saying something else
but arya doesn't hear him she now has
all of her focus on the raven that is
still following them from above arya
watches it for a few more seconds before
cutting off the captain's story arya
says i have changed my mind
i don't think i will go to king's
landing confused the captain says what
do you mean my lady where will you have
me go instead this scene ends right
after arya says i must go to storm's end
first in the next scene we are back in
the north inside the castle of hal stark
sansa is sitting in what was once her
father's high seat in the great hall of
winterfell maester walcan is seated at
her right beside her on sansa's left the
seat is empty a large fire is burning
inside the hearth the gray granite stone
walls inside the great hall were draped
without stark's banners once again the
air is hazy from the smoke and heavy
from the smell of roasted meat and fresh
baked bread
there is a bard running his fingers
along the strings of a high heart while
reciting the words from some ballad
sansa once knew
sansa smiles as she looks around
listening to the sounds of laughter and
a hundred different drunken
conversations it is so noisy that it was
hard to hear anyone who wasn't right
beside you eight long rows of tables
filled winterfell's great hall four on
each side of the center aisle lords and
ladies of the north were crowded
shoulder to shoulder on the benches in
front of her right as sansa is standing
up all of the noise inside winterfell
falls silent as everyone watches and
waits for their queen to speak this is
when we will see a man walk over and
hand a letter to the maester sansa
raises her drink in the air then says
first i just want to thank all of you
for joining me for this feast i welcome
you all to our fires and offer you meat
and mead in honor of our friendship it
honestly warms my heart to see this hall
filled with all of the northern uniforms
yet again my father eddard stark always
said a lord needs to dine with his men
if he ever hopes to keep them
know the men who follow you and make
sure they know you
don't ask your men to die for a stranger
with that being said i must apologize
however because some of you nearly died
for daenerys targaryen i want to make it
known here and now the north is
independent like it should have always
been the only time i will ever ask any
of you to fight for me is so that we can
keep it that way
everyone begin slamming their cups down
against the table as they yell stark
stark stark winterfell winterfell
winterfell sansa smiles and then she
raises her drink again silencing the
great hall my lords and ladies if you
would look beside me you will see i have
left an empty seat it was left this way
for a reason my father always had an
extra seat set at his own table and
every day a different man would join him
so my father could know him and he could
know my father i am asking each of you
to do the same sonza then leans over and
asks the maester what does the letter
say is it from my brother bran as he
shakes his head the maester says know
your grace i still have not received any
word from king's landing this makes
sansa very angry
then something is wrong says sansa our
ravens have went south yet none of them
have come back
she stands up again and says before any
of you join me on this evening first i
would like to speak with our master of
horse we see a stick thin man with brown
hair and a brown beard walking up to the
main table he then sits down next to
sansa your grace how may i be of service
says winterfell's master of horse this
scene ends right after santa says i want
you to have horses ready when the feast
is over i will be sending some of my men
south in the next scene we go back
across the narrow sea in the city of
volantis daenerys kinvara and the other
high-ranking members of our lore are all
inside the great hall of the red temple
we see a man who is dressed in a red
silk robe walk across the great hall
until he is standing right before dany
holding in his hands is a wooden box
that has the burning heart carved into
its lid
he gives it to daenerys then says this
is a gift from the lord of light it will
help you against the darkness wear this
daenerys stormborn and it shall be your
shield against the great other
when daenerys opens the box she can see
there is a necklace laying on a scarlet
robe of her own the necklace has a great
red ruby just like the one melisandre
and kinvara wore around their throats as
daenerys lays it around her neck the
great red ruby starts to glisten as if
it were a fire then she unfolds her new
robe and throws it over her shoulders in
red and gold stitching it has the
burning heart of her lore on the front
of it across its back it has the
three-headed dragon of house targaryen
thank you says daenerys
canvara now grabs danny's hand then
looks in her eyes and says you are the
one who was promised daenerys stormborn
from the great fires overlor you have
been reborn and you will remake the
world you no longer have a large army
like you once had you no longer have
three dragons like you once had yet
still we must leave volantis soon
every day the great other grows stronger
but so shall we daenerys stormborn
what do you mean we says daenerys you
will not succeed if we sent you back to
westeros alone says kinvara we all must
make our sacrifices we will be coming
with you as well as our fiery hand your
dragon and our ships are waiting for us
outside
where will we go first daenerys wants to
know we will go to harrenhal says
kinvara jon snow is already on his way
there now the sound of jon's name made
daenerys nervous but the thought of
seeing him again also made her very
angry remember what i said daenerys
stormborn you and jon snow will need
each other you will not allow yourself
to be lost again the scene ends as the
red ruby on dany's throat begins to glow
even brighter than before
in the following scene we go back out
beyond the wall we're following jon
tormund ghost and helen reed as they
make their way south through the
underground system below the three at
raven's cave they're now walking through
a much smaller passageway there are no
longer bones all over the ground but you
can still see the roots of the werewood
running along the ceiling like the veins
in a man's body ghost is several feet in
front of them leading the way john looks
over at helen reed who is readjusting
the large item that's on his back then
says we have a very long walk ahead of
us my lord do you mind if i ask you some
questions not at all says helen reed
that's one of the reasons why i'm here
jon snow ask me whatever you'd like
before he says anything john thinks back
on what was said by the children of the
forest he thinks about bran and all the
strange things he said as well finally
john says if my brother bran is not the
same anymore then how can i believe
anything he said
you also said bran is getting influenced
or even manipulated by the children in
the south everything he has said may
have been a lie
john looks back over at helen reed
you said you were there the day i was
born what actually happened
i was there the day you were born says
helen reed but i was also there the day
your father met your mother during the
year of the fall spring there was a
great tournament held at the castle of
harrenhal almost everyone of
significance was there that day yet when
the jousting began the day belonged to
your father rhaegar targaryen he would
end up wearing the same armor he would
die in it was gleaming black with the
three-headed dragon of his house wrought
in rubies on the breast
scarlet silk streamed behind him when he
rode and it seemed no lance could touch
him brandon stark fell to him and bron
john royce and even the splendid sir
arthur dane the sword of the morning
rhaegar was unstoppable and that's
because he knew that he must win if he
wanted things to unfold the way they did
as soon as he won rhaegar did not go to
his wife elia martell
instead he laid the queen of beauty's
flowers in lyanna's lap i can still see
it now says helen reed it was a crown of
winter roses as blue as frost but
rhaegar had set all of this in motion
long before this one day rhaegar found
something in his scrolls that changed
him forever
no one knew what it might have been only
that the boy suddenly appeared early one
morning in the yard as the knights were
donning their steel he walked over to
sir willem dary the master at arms and
said i will require sword and armor it
seems i must be a warrior from this day
forward your father knew many sacrifices
would have to be made this is when your
father became obsessed there was a
prophecy he wanted to fulfill he became
convinced that it would be his own son
who would do it rhaegar believed his son
would be the prince who was promised the
song of ice and fire this is what drove
him to seek out your mother lyanna
she fell in love with him the very day
they met it wasn't long after this when
they both vanished we had found your
mother in dorne and what rhaegar would
name the tower of joy your mother laid
there in a bed soaked with blood the
fever had taken her strength and her
voice was faint as a whisper but she
told eddard everything he swore he would
die with her secret and he did i found
eddard still holding her body silent
with grief i had taken her hand from his
otherwise he would have stayed right
there at her bedside forever john holds
his hand over his mouth while shaking
his head in disbelief
everything has happened for a reason
says helen reed there is a reason you're
here with me now jon snow
there is a reason bran gave you the
little bit of information he did when he
did
john says what do you mean by that
helen reed stops walking he then sets
his hand on jon's shoulder and says
bran knew what would happen once that
information got out bran knew how that
would affect daenerys targaryen
he had seen it in his visions since he
was still a boy jon looks stunned as he
realizes what helen reed is about to say
the scene ends right after helen reed
finishes by saying bran knew daenerys
would burn down king's landing yet he
did nothing to stop it bran knew you
would be exiled back out beyond the wall
in the final scene of this episode we
will go down to king's landing we are
back inside the red key at the beginning
of the scene brianna is standing in
front of the hand of the king's new
chambers tyrion lannister opens his door
then says would you mind stepping inside
for a moment i would like to ask you
something before i leave when brienne
enters the chambers she says how may i
be of service my lord he offers her a
seat before taking one himself brienne
sits down as tyrion says samwell and i
recently spoke he said you were with him
when king bran was displaying some
rather odd behavior i was hoping you
could tell me what you thought or how
you felt about it before i go speaking
with our king
well he was acting a bit different than
usual i suppose says brienne at first he
would not answer his door even after i
knocked louder and louder but i thought
maybe he just did not hear me it was
what happened inside of his chambers
that really struck me as odd
sam handed him a book about the legends
of the long night
king baranga sat there staring at it as
he ran his fingers over the drawing of
some horrible looking creature that was
on the front of it he looked almost as
if he was mesmerized by it then out of
nowhere he throws the book into the fire
then says sam and i were dismissed
now i know i haven't known him for that
long but i have never seen him act like
that before our king has seen a lot and
knows a lot there's no doubt about that
says tyrion he has witnessed all of
westeros's violent history i know i
would not want to experience the effects
that would have on someone anyways i
want to thank you sir brianne i am on my
way to speak to king bran now i will
walk with you says brienne as they stand
up and head for the door they suddenly
hear the sound of a very unsettling
frantic scream brienne lays her hand on
the hilt of her sword then says it
sounded like it came from outside my
lord they run across the room then look
out the window
they can see someone standing below the
red keep with their hand over their
mouth in shock
brienne and tyrion leave his chambers
then rush down the stairs sir davos runs
across the hall to join them did you
hear that scream says davos yes it came
from outside says tyrion davos follows
them down more stairs then across the
throne room when they shove open the
doors there is already a crowd gathered
around outside
everyone looks stunned a hundred yards
in front of them there are about 30
people standing around in a circle all
looking down at the ground there are
more standing off to the side looking up
into the sky at the red key
samwell then emerges from the crowd who
has gathered in a circle he looks like
he has been shaken up all of the color
has left his face as he begins walking
over to them he wretches up some of his
dinner onto the ground brienne tyrion
and davos all look at each other
wondering what's happened
they slowly start walking over by the
crowd gathered around
when sam notices them he walks over to
tyrion lays his hand on his shoulder and
says i am so sorry this happened my lord
before walking away with his head down
as they get closer to the crowd brienne
begins shoving some of them aside only
then are they able to see what has
happened sir brawn is laying on the
ground dead surrounded by his own blood
and bone this is when tyrion drops down
to one knee shocked
he looks around at everyone gathered
outside wondering how this could have
happened
davos says i will go find some help
before he runs off
brienne still has her hand on her sword
while she looks for anyone who could
have saw something raidus tyrion stands
back up he notices everyone is now
looking up at the red key as he follows
their eyes up along the castle all he
can see is the balcony to the king's
chambers the episode ends as we hear low
voices say he fell he was shoved he fell
he was shoved i saw it with my own eyes
in the very first scene of this episode
the sky is beginning to get dark as the
sun slowly slips behind the horizon off
into the distance we can see there is a
gigantic castle on the far side of the
lake we're in a location we have never
been before we're on the shore of the
god's eye somewhere we have only seen
glimpses of in brian stark's flashbacks
this evening is eerily silent the only
thing we can hear is the sound of the
red leaves rustling in the wind and the
water gently splashing against the rocks
in the middle of this lake is an island
known as the isle of faces as we look
out across the lake onto the island all
we can see are the faces on the
werewolves a thousand blood-red eyes are
staring back at us eyes that look as if
they're full of ancient wisdom and
secrets older than the land itself the
faces on these werewoods are different
than the ones we have seen in the north
they look frightening almost like
they've witnessed all of the atrocities
throughout the history of westeros there
is something very unsettling about them
it looks as if the werewolves are
guarding the sacred isle of faces
themselves there must be hundreds of
them standing side by side surrounding
the entire island in a circle the
werewoods look alive as the red leaves
dance in the wind
suddenly we start to see some movement
there are shadows shifting back and
forth behind the weirwoods we can hear
the sound of branches breaking
underneath footsteps hundreds of small
green figures begin to emerge from the
woods they're all wearing helmets that
are shaped like antlers their green and
brown skin looks as if it's made from
the leaves these green men do not look
like the innocent children of the forest
who were hiding out in the north
these little green men have a ghastly
look about their faces all of them are
holding dragonglass weapons in their
hands however they're not made from the
black obsidian we have always seen
before their dragonglass weapons are
green and some of them are even red all
of them begin to stand shoulder to
shoulder on the shore of the sacred isle
of faces as the werewoods stand guard
over the island the green men stand
there silently watching over the
werewoods behind them it would be very
difficult for anyone to get onto this
island unless you are welcomed here in
the following scene we go back to king's
landing where a crowd is gathered below
the red keep there are now men and women
everywhere the new city watch is
standing around sar brawn's lifeless
body as they hold everyone back
we see brienne walking around asking
everyone questions in hopes of finding
out what they all saw and heard her hand
is still resting on the hilt of her
sword the city watch make way for
samwell who is holding his hand over his
mouth while he throws a blanket over
brawn a few of the stark guardsmen lift
his body off the ground before they lay
it down on the back of a wagon the
onlookers are still shocked by the
gruesome scene the shape of bronze body
can still be seen on the ground where he
was outlined by bits of his own bone and
large amounts of blood
some of bronze hair can even be seen on
the stone street below the red key lord
tyrion is standing there speechless as
he watches his friend's body get hauled
away he finally snaps out of his days as
he hears a soft whisper behind him say i
saw what happened my lord i saw it with
my own eyes now tyrion looks over his
shoulder wondering where the voice came
from the only one standing there behind
him is a short man dressed in rags he
doesn't say anything at first he looks
over at sam and brienne
sam is kneeling down looking at
something on the ground brianne is still
standing there only now she's speaking
to one of the stark guardsmen not
knowing what this man will say tyrion
doesn't want everyone overhearing him
when he sees that the others are still
busy he looks back over at the man and
says follow me they begin walking away
from the scene they don't walk far
before they find a building they can
slip behind out of sight he grabs the
man by his wrist before asking him what
did you see i want you to tell me every
detail the man looks down at tyrion then
says he was thrown off the balcony my
lord i was standing right below the red
keep when i suddenly heard a few voices
shouting from above when i looked up i
saw three men standing there it looked
like they were arguing about something
it all happened so fast the next thing i
know the men began shoving each other
but only one of them went over the
railing while letting go of the man's
wrist tyrion asks him who are the other
men do you remember what they look like
or what they were wearing i do my lord
says the man dressed in rags let me show
you they step back out from behind the
building the man looks over where the
crowd is still gathered around he holds
out his finger in front of him then says
they look just like him when tyrion
follows the man's eyes and finger he can
see exactly who he was referring to
they're now looking at one of the stark
guardsmen
reluctantly tyrion says i was afraid you
would say that now he steps in closer to
the man in a low whisper he says did you
happen to see anyone else out there on
the balcony
someone that might have been sitting
down
the man suddenly gets nervous as he
realizes the gravity of the situation no
my lord i did not see anyone else tyrion
now looks away while silently letting
out a sigh of relief he looks back at
the man then says do not speak to anyone
else about this without speaking to me
first do you understand the man nods his
head then says of course my lord he then
throws the man a small sack of golden
dragons and says that should be enough
to buy your silence for now what is your
name the man says my name is damian my
lord thank you for the information says
tyrion i may need you again before all
of this is over where can i find you
that won't be very hard my lord says
damian i live and flee bottom in the
only house that's still standing the man
in rags then bows his head before the
men go their separate ways now tyrion
begins walking back over to where
brienne is standing he starts asking her
what she has heard what is everyone
saying about what happened brienne says
i find it a little hard to believe but
they're all saying he fell on his own
there had to be someone standing out
here that saw something else very well
says tyrion if that's what they saw then
that's what they saw
this makes brienne glance over at him
out of the corner of her eye it's
obvious she doesn't feel the same way he
then looks over at samwell who is still
kneeling down looking at the ground he
watches as sam grabs something off the
ground before standing back up
samwell is holding something in his hand
as he walks in their direction when he
stops in front of them he holds it up
into the air for them to see it's a
black feather that has blood dripping
down from it it was laying under braun's
body samwell says nervously when tyrion
realizes what it is his mouth hangs open
as he looks back up at the red key his
eyes find the balcony that braun fell
from it's no longer empty bran is now
sitting out there alone staring back at
them the scene ends when tyrion notices
he is staring right at him
in the following scene we are back in
the darkness deep below the ground
somewhere in the north there are shadows
dancing across the cavern walls as the
flickering flames illuminate what lies
ahead
john ghost tormund and helen reed follow
the red and white roots of the weirwood
as they make their way further and
further south ghost is still only a few
feet in front of them leading the way as
the men continue walking john looks back
over at allen reed then says there are
still a few things i need you to help me
understand
you said bran knew that daenerys would
burn king's landing before we ever went
south you said he knew that i would be
sent back out beyond the wall how did he
know i know bran can see things but how
does he see them before they happen
helen reed begins running his fingers
along the weirwood roots as he walks
alongside john he says your brother was
given this gift from the oldest gods in
westeros jon snow the children have gods
of the forest rivers and stone the old
gods whose names are secret their
knowledge and wisdom runs deeper than
these roots and where they go their eyes
go as well
they are in harmony with everything
around us when the children gave the
weirwoods their faces it gave them the
ability to see what they see but after
thousands of years they're able to see
so much more jon snow your brother brian
is one of their greenseers he began by
looking through the eyes of the werewood
but now he can see so much more as well
jon suddenly stops walking he wipes the
sweat from his brow as he gathers his
thoughts if you're right about all of
this then they know we're on our way
john says dreadfully how can we ever
hope to stop them if they're already
half a dozen steps ahead of us helen
reed sets his hand on jon's shoulder
than says i won't lie to you jon snow it
won't be easy nothing ever is
bran is still in king's landing right
now surrounded by your friends as long
as we can reach him before he leaves we
still stand a fighting chance
bran has seen glimpses of the future in
his vision since he was a boy but he
hasn't seen everything he hasn't seen
you when the night king attacked the
cave he forced your brother to go south
while he was still learning how to use
his new gift the children of the south
are now fighting the children of the
north over your brother's mind they're
like a virus entering his body infecting
everything he sees the further your
brother goes south and the longer he's
there the more and more he loses of
himself it won't be long before he can
no longer control his own thoughts or
actions hold on says john
you said bran hasn't seen me what did
you mean by that helen reed smiles and
says the old gods have your brother now
but they no longer have you not like
they once did you were resurrected by
the lord of light jon snow the same as
daenerys targaryen when bran sees either
of you and his visions now he's looking
at things that have already happened
that's why he's still in king's landing
the scene ends after hallam reed says he
doesn't know you or daenerys are on your
way let's hope that doesn't change
that's our only advantage right now
in the next scene we go back across the
narrow sea
in the city of atlantis the sun is
sweltering on this afternoon as it sits
high in the sky above about a dozen
ships that are anchored along the shore
the black and red sails of house
targaryen are dancing in the sky as the
wind slams against them throwing them in
the other direction it almost looks as
if the three-headed dragons have taken
flight we watch as greyworm and a
handful of other unsolid men walk across
the deck as they make their way into the
city
greyworm has a slight smile on his face
he only focuses on the enormous red
temple of her lore as he walks further
and further down the street it's sitting
high up on its hill looming over
everyone below
sitting above everything else is drogon
he stretches his wings far and wide as
he soaks up the rising sun everyone is
waiting for daenerys targaryen to emerge
from the red temple the one thousand
slave soldiers of the fiery hand are
standing guard outside its massive walls
eagerly awaiting their new orders the
crowd below them has been growing
thicker by the day
greyworm and his men remove their
helmets when they reach the city square
they can see the main entrance and its
great wooden doors that are engraved
with relore's burning heart
one of the slave soldiers of the fiery
hand stops them from getting any closer
they wait and watch with everyone else
suddenly the large wooden doors swing
open a man in a red silk robe emerges
from within
the crowd erupts when they begin
shouting his name bonero bonero
the unsolid men look around unsure of
what's happening
as bonero raises his arms in the sky
everyone grows silent in a thunderous
voice he says
daenerys stormborn is the fulfillment of
an ancient prophecy from smoke and salt
she was born to make the world anew she
is azor ahai returned and her triumph
over the great other will bring a summer
that will never end and death itself
will bend its knee and all those who die
fighting in her cause shall be reborn as
daenerys was reborn before your very own
eyes darkness has fallen heavy over the
realm but that darkness will flee before
her
on this day we will set sail for
westeros and we shall not return until
the great other is consumed by relore's
great flames
there are six more red robes that emerge
from within the red temple
as daenerys removes her hood greyworm's
eyes begin filling with water
he lets out a long sigh of relief
daenerys begins walking down the long
stone steps followed by all of relore's
highest ranking members when they reach
the street the fiery hand falls in
around them as they escort daenerys
kinvara bonero and the others to their
waiting ships drogon lets out another
loud shriek before leaping high into the
sky
greyworm and his unsullied men can only
watch as daenerys is marched right by
them as dany nears the shore of atlantis
she suddenly stops in her tracks when
she sees the black and red sails of
house targaryen among the other ships
there's at least 100 more ships docked
each of them displaying the burning
heart of verlor on their sails and
banners daenerys begins looking through
the crowd wondering who brought them
here when she spins around her and
greyworm lock eyes now hers begin
filling with water they embrace each
other for a few moments before danny
says i wasn't sure if i would ever see
you again how did you know i was here i
found out from a man on the island of
noth says grey worm oh
i see says daenerys with grief in her
voice
she holds his hand then says i wish i
could have been there with you when you
said goodbye i should have been at your
side when jon snow betrayed you says
grey worm if you will allow me i would
like to be at your side again
i will follow you until my last day your
grace i have nowhere else to go
with a smile on her face daenerys says
then we shall sail together i still have
unfinished business in westeros the
scene ends as daenerys and greyworm walk
across the sand over to their ships in
the following scene we are on a
different ship as it reaches the
southern shore in westeros arya stark
walks across the deck as the men get
ready to drop its anchor they have made
it to their destination
arya watches as the waves crash against
the rocks below an enormous castle she
has only heard about in stories the wall
is said to be 40 feet thick at its
narrowest in near 80 on the seaward face
within that mighty ball work the
kitchens and stables and yards sheltered
safe from the wind and wave of towers
there was but one a massive drum tower
windowless where it faced the sea so
large that it was granary and barracks
and feast hall and lord's dwelling all
in one it is crowned by massive
battlements that made it look from afar
like a spiked fist atop an up thrust arm
as arya looks at all of her surroundings
the ship's captain walks over and stands
beside her welcome to storm's end my
lady says the captain it is said that
this castle was built by the same man
who constructed your family's ancestral
home did you know that my lady yes says
arya it was brandon the builder with the
help of the children of the forest raid
azaria says this they hear a loud shriek
from above arya has to shield her eyes
from the bright morning sun as she looks
up into the sky
circling right above them is the same
raven that has been following them for
several weeks when arya looks back down
she says don't wait for me i thank you
for bringing me this far but i will not
be boarding the ship again
i will go to king's landing by horse
from here i am sorry i can't be a
further service my lady but as you wish
says the captain he then bows his head
before he walks away this is when arya
notices several men on horseback riding
her way one of these men is holding a
banner that shows the stag of house
baratheon arya smiles then makes her way
off the ship as she walks across the
sand only one of the riders approaches
her while the others wait on the other
side of the beach i saw your sails early
this morning i was wondering why there
was a stark ship this far south i was
not expecting it to be you my lady i
thought you were heading west says
gendry with a big smile on his face i
was says arya i changed my mind well i
hope you changed your mind about
accepting my offer says gendry arya
cracks a thin smile but she says no it's
not that something else came up and i
may need your help gendry stops smiling
when he says this sounds serious what
the hell happened it's my brother bran i
think something is wrong with him says
arya gendry hops down off the horse
before asking her did something happen
to bran is he okay
well i'm not exactly sure caesarea it
doesn't make any sense but i think bran
wants me dead there is several more
moments of silence before gendry says
this is very serious what makes you
think he wants you dead the man who
tried to kill me said he did says arya
maybe the man was lying says gendry
maybe he did lie says arya but what if
he wasn't not to mention that's not the
only thing that happened
a raven has been following me after
several more seconds of silence gendry
says a raven
what does that mean
well
if you ride with me to king's landing
you will see cesario
okay says gendry i will go but what do
you want me to do once we get there i
don't know cesaria i don't know what to
do about this that seems obvious says
gendry the fact that you're even here
asking me for help says that you don't
know what to do about this situation i
know one thing says arya i need to speak
with bran myself i need to look him in
his eyes and ask him why
if there is something wrong with your
brother and he does want you dead then
he might not let you enter king's
landing so easily says gendry the city
will be guarded the scene ends as gendry
says should i bring some of my men with
us my lady in the next scene we go back
below the ground somewhere in the north
we're following john ghost tormund in
helen reed as they make their way
through the darkness further and further
south the red eyes of ghost are glowing
in their flickering flames the albino
direwolf leads them through the dark
abyss with the men following closely
behind as they're walking tormund
giantsbane looks to hell and read and
says when will this end it feels like we
have been walking down here for days
well that depends on where you want to
go says helen reed you can access almost
any location in westeros using this cave
system
the children of the forest dug these out
thousands of years ago even before the
first men arrived in their lands all we
need to do is keep following the
werewolf south we will get there much
faster than any man would by horse when
we do get there says john what will we
do we don't have an army it doesn't
sound like the children of the forest
want to negotiate they already made the
night king
it frightens me to think of what else
they might be able to do how will we
stop them how will we save my brother
bran helen reed doesn't say anything at
first he just keeps walking with his
head down as he slings the item he has
been carrying on his back over his other
shoulder finally after what felt like
several minutes helen reed looks over at
john then says
we will have to make our sacrifices jon
snow as i have said before it won't be
easy
stopping these children of the forest
will come with a heavy cost we won't be
able to end this without daenerys
targaryen and her dragon
this makes jon think about when he last
saw daenerys when he stabbed her while
they were standing in front of the iron
throne he thinks about what that choice
cost him
he looks over at tormund giantsbane he
thinks about what it cost him when he
let the wildlings through the wall at
castle black he then looks over at helen
reed who is adjusting the large item on
his shoulder again and says what
sacrifices have you made my lord
again there is several moments of
silence before helen reed says anything
helen reed looks into john's eyes then
says
there were many jon snow
unfortunately i made a great sacrifice
that has cost me dearly
with grief and his voice helen reed says
i had to sacrifice my very own but
before he can finish his sentence some
noises are heard in the distance the
hair on the back of ghost starts to
stand up as his glowing red eyes cut
through the darkness ahead jon grabs
longclaw unsure of what they're about to
face
they can see there is some light
bouncing off the walls about a hundred
feet in front of them there are a few
shadowy figures moving behind their
light jon looks at them with a hint of
fear in his eyes they're not able to
make out anyone's faces that's when he
shouts make yourself known before you
take another step who are you
why are you down here suddenly they hear
a voice shout back at them we are here
on behalf of our queen santa stark who
goes there this scene ends as jon says i
am her brother jon snow
in the following scene we go back down
to king's landing a full moon sits high
above the red keep we watch as the hand
of the king tyrion lannister reluctantly
walks across the great hall there are
hundreds of ravens all over the old
throne room
since there is still a very large hole
in the side of the red keep the ravens
are able to fly in and out of the great
hall with ease they all begin shrieking
at tyrion who feels an enormous sense of
dread as he makes his way to king bran's
chambers he knows this will not be an
easy conversation but he has to ask bran
himself what happened why did braun die
so suddenly there are three star
guardsmen standing outside of bran's
door
a few of them are the same stark men who
were drinking with brawn at the end one
of them says we have been expecting you
lord tyrion why would you be expecting
me as tyrion as the stark guardsman
opens the door
he says you will see
go ahead and step inside as he walks
into bran's chambers the stark guardsman
follows behind him when they're all
inside they shut the door lord tyrion
watches nervously as one of them locks
it when he looks across the room he sees
bran sitting there in his chair silently
gazing into the fire he sees there is
even more stark guardsmen inside the
room with them one of the stark
guardsmen throws something from across
the room it lands in front of tyrion's
feet spilling out onto the floor when he
looks down he sees there is a small sack
with golden dragons all around it when
he looks back up bran is staring into
his eyes with a very unsettling look
about his face it makes tyrion feel
uneasy as he tries to figure out what's
happening
that's when the stark guardsmen near
bran step aside revealing there has been
someone standing behind them laura
tyrion immediately recognizes the man
who is dressed in rags it's damien the
man who said he witnessed braun's death
his hands are bound at the wrist his
face has been bloodied and bruised even
the front of his pants are soaking wet
finally tyrion asks bran what is the
meaning of this with a smile on his face
bran says where were you lord tyrion
where was you at when braun fell i was
in my chambers
sir brianne was there with me says
tyrion why are you asking me this
damian flinches as one of the stark
guardsmen throws his arm around his
shoulder this dark guardsman says that's
not what our new friend has been telling
us really cysterian as he looks at all
of damien's injuries he says he doesn't
look like a new friend he looks like a
dog that has had all the fight whipped
right out of him he then looks back at
bran and says what did you force him to
say about me
the man said you gave him those golden
dragons to have sir braun murdered says
brian
this is nonsense yes tyrion why would i
want my own friend dead i gave him that
so i could buy his silencer grace we
know you did says one of the star
guardsmen
you needed his silence so he would keep
your secrets safe we know that now
no yells tyrion that's not how it
happened while looking at bran he says i
wanted him to keep your secret safe your
grace i did not want all of king's
landing thinking the new king was
involved in murdering one of his own
council members before i could find out
what really happened this entire country
has been through enough the mad king the
drunken king robert the sadistic joffrey
my sister cersei and that was before
daenerys burnt king's landing down to
the ground i thought we were finally
done with all of this i did not want
everyone thinking we were back to our
old ways of backstabbing and murdering
each other i guess i was wrong
again
what has happened to you bran i thought
you would be great for the realm
king brain has a haunting look in his
eyes it's as if all of his life has left
them
the scene ends after brain says
what happened to bran
he died in a cave years ago
he looks at one of the stark guardsmen
then says
have lord tyrion thrown into the black
cells he will be executed for the murder
of sir brawn of high garden
in the final scene of this episode we go
back to the isle of faces all of the red
leaves on the werewoods are illuminated
from the full moon that hangs high in
the sky above the god's eye the green
men are still silently standing their
watch over the sacred island we won't be
focusing on them in this final scene
however
now we move inward into the center of
the island where the woods are much
denser than they are on the shore of the
lake
the shrieking sound of ravens can be
heard from the branches above
in the very center of the isle of faces
there is a massive werewood standing
over 300 feet tall and nearly 30 foot
wide at its base
the face on the front of it has a mouth
that's so big a grown man could easily
stand inside of it its eyes are
frightening as it gazes into the fire
before it
surrounding the massive weirwood is a
grove of seven more werewolves all
facing inward at the fire
this is where the children of the forest
would hold their sacred ceremonies and
even their sacrifices to their gods
which they believe are the werewoods
themselves as the flames in the fire
crack in his very large shadows begin to
move all around us suddenly there are
glowing blue eyes emerging from the
shadows around the weirwood grove the
little green men are not the only ones
here this is when we see there are
dozens and dozens of white walkers
riding on the backs of giant elks whose
eyes also have a blue glow to them
there is something slightly different
about these white walkers they don't
look exactly like all of the other ones
we have seen before they're gaunt and
heart as old bones even their armor
seems to change color as they move
around on their massive elks one second
they look white as new fallen snow the
next second they were black as a shadow
white shadows in the darkness
they have a sort of elegance to them
only in a very frightening kind of way
these white walkers are the children's
chosen ones who were selected to guard
their sacred isle of faces
no one knows what they're capable of but
they will find out soon enough
in the very first scene of this episode
we are back below the ground somewhere
in the north of westeros there are
several lights flickering in the
distance as seven shadows move ahead the
roots of the werewood that are running
along the ceiling are thicker here the
red sap-like substance that was dripping
down from them is now frozen in the
shape of icicles it looks like there are
1 000 bloody knives hanging upside down
like bats the scene begins as we see jon
ghost tormund helen reed and the stark
guardsman sansa had sent through the
secret passageway in winterfell's crypt
john's albino direwolf is still leading
the way when he looks back at jon his
blood red eyes glisten in the light
helen reed checks to make sure the long
item he has been carrying on his back is
still wrapped up in the furs after he
secures it again he slings it back over
his other shoulder how did you get down
here asked john where did my sister want
you to go the commander of the stark
guardsman says we got here through
winterfell script queen sansa wanted us
to find out where this ended we had been
searching down here for what felt like a
fortnight we ran out of food yesterday
we're lucky we ran into you when we did
i don't understand says john how did you
get here through winterfell's crypt we
found a secret passageway says the
commander of the star guardsmen the
lowest level of your family's crypt had
been collapsed after we moved all the
dirt and rubble we found a hidden tunnel
that led out into here
john looks at helen reed and asks him
the children of the forest helen reed
begins nodding his head in agreement
that's not all we found says the
commander the stark guardsman there are
some bizarre drawings on the wall as
well drawings asked john what were they
we will show you in a minute says the
stark guardsmen we're just about there
before they take another step forward
helen sets his hand on jon's shoulder
then says i know you want to see your
sister but we can't stay here long we
must go south right away i understand
says john that's when ghosts vanishes
into the darkness that lies ahead after
they walk another hundred feet the stark
guardsman says it's this way he holds up
his light higher revealing the hidden
passageway that's on the left when the
six men enter they see the small bright
red eyes of ghost up ahead the icy floor
beneath her feet begins cracking softly
as they move forward the direwolf is now
sitting down as its eyes study the wall
beside him as jon gets closer he says
what is it boy what do you see when jon
holds up his own light he sees the
drawings that were left on the wall
thousands of years ago he sees a man
standing in front of a castle that looks
a lot like winterfell only much smaller
he sees a giant werewood surrounded by a
grove of more werewoods that are all
facing inward he then sees a child of
the forest holding the head of what
looks like another child of the forest
the commander the stark guardsman says
queen sansa was wondering what these
drawings meant the maester sent sketches
of them down to the citadel but as far
as i know there has been no response he
then looks at jon and says do any of you
know what they mean
why would the children of the forest
behead one of their own john looks at
helen reed who doesn't say anything
right away he grabs the long item from
his back then slings it over his other
shoulder
after sucking in a deep breath helen
looks in the commander's eyes then says
we all have to make our sacrifices he
then looks away while wiping the tears
away from his own eyes
john doesn't want to ask him any further
questions he can see that the lord is
visibly shaken he shifts his focus back
at the star guardsman let's go find my
sister says john as the men enter the
lowest level of the crypt jon notices
ghost is now sitting in front of a
statue when jon walks over near him he
says i always wondered what was down
here i have never been on this level
before but i've seen it in my dreams he
holds up the light again now shining it
on the face made of stone he examines
the man's features for a few moments a
sense of dread washes over jon before he
looks away from the statue's stern face
he looks very familiar john says
nervously well he should says tormund
giantsbane he's a stark just like you
john starts looking behind the statue
after he notices it's been broken this
is when helen reed says he's not in
there jon snow this wasn't just any
stark this is brandon stark the first
stark of winterfell who was the old king
of winter you're right says john there
isn't anyone inside the statue but i
think there is something laying at the
bottom of it here hold this light john
says to one of the stark guardsmen he
reaches down inside of the broken statue
then grabs what was left behind the
frost has it frozen and stiff but the
icy black leather still shines under the
flame
john unfolds it then he holds it up for
all to see it's a cloak made of black
leather and black fur john's eyes open
wide when he suddenly realizes what it
is i've been looking at those all of my
life says storm in giant spain
that's from the night's watch it is says
jon who is now looking over at helen
reed again when i was leaving for the
wall my father
john stops then corrects himself when i
was leaving for the wall lord eddard
said the starks have been manning the
wall for thousands of years
there's great honor serving in the
night's watch
the starks have manned the wall for
thousands of years
i wonder when this brandon stark was
there a very long time ago says helen
read roughly 8 000 years ago brandon
stark was the lord commander just like
you
he then looks into the eyes of the
statue's stern face the scene ends after
helen reed says he was the 13th lord
commander of the nightfort jon snow
in the next scene we are back in the
south right outside of the castle walls
of storm's end the sun is shining the
sky is blue and black wings and white
eyes are seen circling above
suddenly the raven lets out a loud
shriek as it falls from the sky when the
bird slams into the earth its black
feathers go flying back up into the air
we see a foot step onto the raven before
we see a hand yank and arrow free from
the fallen bird it's arya stark who
smiles at gendry as she sees him walking
over with a few horses i don't want any
ravens following us as arya i will shoot
down as many as i can but will you relay
the same message to your men
have them shoot down any ravens they see
i think it would be best if bran doesn't
know when we will arrive i will my lady
says gendry and stop calling me my lady
arya says stubbornly gendry laughs and
says i'm sorry old habits are hard to
break my men are mounted and ready shall
we leave arya gives a head nod then says
we shall gendry hands over the reins to
a brown stallion before climbing on the
back of his own right over their
shoulders is a very large formation of
men following behind them there's maybe
500 or fewer this is where the king's
road begins the banners of house
baratheon are flapping hard in the wind
this certainly isn't the first time a
member from al stark and a member from
house baratheon went down this road as
they made their way to king's landing in
hopes of bringing back some sort of
balance to the realm gendry looks over
at arya as they ride side by side on
their horses he says before we left
king's landing you said you were leaving
westeros and sailing west i wasn't sure
if i would ever see you again i know
these aren't the best circumstances but
i'm glad you're here so am i cesaria
while smiling what should i do when we
arrive in the capital ask andrew what's
your strategy will we storm the gates
will we take over the city like our
father is before us
no says arya well then good says gendry
because we don't have the numbers for
all that i will simply demand to speak
to the king says arya i still don't
actually know if it was bran who sent
the assassin to kill me i have to keep
reminding myself that the man who
attacked me might have been lying
if only the raven wasn't following me
i know that's bran watching over me
spying on my every move but i just don't
understand why
it sounds like your brother may look at
you as a threat says gendry arya flashes
a look of doubt gendry's way she says
why would you say something like that
well says gendry you did kill the night
king and bryan had a front row seat he
knows exactly what you're capable of
that still doesn't explain why my
brother would feel threatened by me says
arya we weren't enemies i had no reason
to fight him gendry looks in arya's eyes
an ominous feeling washed over him as he
says you're right arya you had no reason
to fight him but now you do the scene
ends after he says i just hope you don't
get me killed
in the following scene we go back to
king's landing to see how things are
unraveling there the sun is sitting high
in the sky overlooking the red keep and
the city below there is still a large
crowd gathered right outside of the
castle's walls the atmosphere in king's
landing is charged with electricity
again everyone is abuzz now that they're
wondering how and why the new master of
coin went flying from the balcony of the
king's chambers as you can imagine
rumors are already beginning to spread
across the capital brienne and podrick
are outside together still gathering as
much information as they can
we hear one man say he heard that the
little imp had brawn killed after
fighting over an old debt that he owed
we hear a different man say he heard
braun jump because he was heartbroken
brienne immediately rolls her eyes she
did not know braun well but she does
know that would be the last thing that
would ever happen we then hear an old
woman say she heard a thousand ravens
lifted him up into the sky then dropped
him on his head
i think we've heard enough for one day
brienne says sarcastically thank you for
the information we will inform the king
brienne then glances over at sir podrick
and says let's go back inside as they
head for the castle's gate they are
suddenly approached by another man who
has a hood down low over his face when
he gets within a few feet of them he
holds out his fist brienne grabs the
held of her sword ready for action but
the unknown man opens his hand dropping
a crumbled note at their feet before
walking off brienne grabs the letter
from the ground then opens it when she
looks over for the hooded man she
notices he has already vanished behind
the crowd she looks at podrick who is
just as confused as she is brienne looks
back down at the letter then reads it
aloud it states the answers you are
looking for lie in the hands of your
hand this doesn't make any sense as
brienne the only thing in my hand is
this letter she crumbles the note in her
fist then drops it onto the ground and
walks away wait says sir podrick who is
already grabbing the letter and opening
it again
he starts mumbling the words to himself
the answers you are looking for lie in
the hands of your hand it's just a
stupid riddle let's go brienne says
angrily this is when podrick says we can
go but we must find lortyrion right away
they walk inside the red keep as they
make their way across the throne room
dozens of ravens begin shrieking over
and over again
right where the iron throne used to sit
there must be a hundred ravens gathered
around in a circle looking at something
on the ground when they get closer to
the steps they notice there is some
blood on the floor there is even some
blood dripping down the steps some of
the ravens begin flying away when they
hear brienne walking up the stairs
that's when she realizes they are
feasting on something the sound of
brienne unsheathing her sword makes all
of the ravens fly away at once there is
a lifeless body lying on the ground she
looks over at podrick in disgust
unfortunately the ravens have left this
man's face unrecognizable even his eyes
are missing the one thing she does
notice is the man is dressed in rags
that are soaked in blood his ragged
clothes are the only thing he has left
but it doesn't help them identify who
the man was follow me says brienne as
she walks away with urgency they move
down the hallway before they ascend the
flight of stairs that lead to the hand
of the king's chambers when they reach
lortirian's door brienne knocks on it
loudly the door must not have been
locked or fully shut because it slowly
starts to open as they step inside they
immediately realize lorterion isn't here
however someone has recently been in
this room
everything is a mess the bed has been
knocked over and flipped upside down the
feathers that were inside his bedding
are scattered all across the room and
everything that was inside the dressers
have been spilled out onto the floor
someone has been in here looking for
something says brienne his chambers did
not look like this the night we heard
braun scream through the open window
what scream a deep voice says from
behind when brienne and patrick look
back at the door they see there are now
three men standing there watching them
brienne recognizes the men
they're leftovers from the stark's
household guard they're the same three
men who arrested lore tyrion lannister
inside branch chambers brienne says
where did you get that armor the men
smile at each other before one of them
says we are now sworn brothers of the
kingsguard thanks to your grace he gave
us our white cloaks then commanded us to
find you we will need you to come with
us he's waiting for both of you in his
chambers everything inside berean is
screaming at her to grab her sword she
doesn't trust these men and she knows
it's written all over her face she looks
over at podrick who is hesitating as
well after you my lady says one of the
stark men while stepping aside the scene
ends as they reluctantly follow the men
out of lord tyrion lannister's chamber
in the next scene we are somewhere out
at sea it begins with us seeing an
enormous shadow flying over a fleet of
ships drogon's black scales are shining
like obsidian under the morning sun the
dragon swoops down low over the sails as
he begins gliding over the water below
daenerys steps out onto the deck of one
of verlor's ships she leans against the
railing before she looks out over the
deep blue sea all around them dany
smiles when she looks at drogon who
seems to be bigger and stronger than
ever right over her shoulder are dozens
of more ships some of them are flying
the banners of the three-headed dragon
while the bulk of them are displaying
the banners of the fiery heart all one
thousand slave soldiers from the fiery
hand are sailing with them as well as
many other followers and high-ranking
members of relore grey worm suddenly
appears from below the deck when he
spots daenerys leaning against the
railing he walks over to her he has
vowed to never leave her side again the
rest of the unsullied men are on dany's
old ships following right behind them as
they make their way back to westeros
thank you for joining me says daenerys
when grey worm stands next to her he
bows his head before saying your grace
daenerys and grey worm both look across
the ship on the other side of the deck
as they see kanvara walking their way
kinvara is joined by a very large man we
have never seen before he stands well
over six feet tall with skin as black as
drogon and hair as white as snow on his
face and forehead are tattoos of red and
orange flames the black man's red
scarlet robe has satin orange flames on
it as well in his right hand is a six
foot iron staff with a dragon's head on
the end of it he looks spectacular in a
frightening kind of way as they approach
danny and greyworm kenvara says your
grace i would like you to meet makaro as
he looks at danny with his shining dark
eyes he says in his deep voice the lord
of light has shown me your worth every
night in my fires i glimpse the glory
that awaits you ken vara then reaches
out and grabs grey worm by his arm as
she squeezes his muscles she says i hope
you and your men are ready because
darkness awaits us we are says grey worm
he looks in danny's eyes and says you
still haven't said who we will be
fighting kinvara smiles then she says
why don't i show you instead she reaches
down and grabs his hand grey worm
follows her over to a burning brazier in
the center of the ship look into ralor's
great fire and behold everything that is
ready to strike us down
the red and orange flames reflecting
greyworm's eyes his mouth hangs open as
he stares into the fire in disbelief
after a few more moments of watching a
sudden anger flashes across his face
greyworm slams the brazier down spilling
hot embers all over the deck of the ship
we see three slave soldiers of the fiery
hand rush over and begin stomping on the
embers before the wooden ship catches
fire with the look of shock on her face
danny says what happened what did you
see whatever it was best believe you
will see it again says macaro
grey worm looks at danny his eyes are
now filled with hatred the scene ends
after he says i saw jon snow he was
riding on the back of drogon in the
following scene we are back in
winterfell ghost john tormund helen reed
and the stark guardsmen emerge from
below the castle there is so much
activity in the courtyard no one even
notices them at first
jon can't help but crack a smile when he
sees how alive the castle is again
there are men drilling with wood and
steel swords in the yard there are cooks
tending their vegetables in the glass
garden there's restless dogs running
back and forth in the kennels and
there's even some women gossiping beside
the washing well it almost made him feel
at home again but he remembers what
helen reed said they cannot stay here
for long
suddenly he hears a surprise voice from
up above
jon is that you
sansa who is followed by maester walcan
rushes down the stairs to greet him the
yard grows silent and everyone watches
as jon and sansa embrace each other what
happened asked sansa why did you leave
castle black john looks at her with a
bit of sadness in his eyes he says we
have a lot to discuss he then looks
around the yard at all the watchful eyes
staring back at him sansa finally
notices everyone is looking at them the
silence ends and everyone immediately
goes back to work now that they have
queen sansa's attention maybe we should
go speak in the godswood says john as
they begin walking ghost starts out in
front of them when they reach the
godswood ghost is already there sniffing
the ground around the weirwood john
notices that right away but he focuses
on the task at hand your grace i would
like you to meet lord helen reed john
steps aside while howland reed bows his
head you were friends with my father
says sansa i remember hearing stories
about you when i was younger
helen reed smiles then says i was your
grace your father was a great man it
would be an honor for me to serve his
children what brings you all this way
ass sansa why are you with john did you
join the night's watch know your grace
says lord howland we're here because of
your brother bran
he's in grave danger john has agreed to
help me save him or so we hope sansa's
eyes fill with fear as she looks over at
jon what does he mean ass sansa why
would bran be in grave danger our
enemies have been defeated he is
surrounded by soldiers and guards day
and night i made sure of that myself i
left behind some of our own household
guard brienne joined his kingsguard not
mine who would harm him there are things
in this world that are difficult to
explain says alan reid bryan isn't the
same brother you grew up with anymore i
know says sanza bran said the exact same
thing to me when he said he was the
three-eyed raven i need you to explain
it to me help me understand so i can
help you the children of the forest did
not disappear says helen reed your
brother met some of them in a cave
beyond the wall they did everything they
could to help him defeat the night king
but it wasn't enough to end the great
war there are more children of the
forest hiding out in the south on the
isle of faces they were helping the
night king and his army of the dead all
along they are still working against us
as we speak and they have now entered
your brother's mind he will continue to
lose more and more of himself the longer
he stays in the south not only is your
brother in danger but so is everyone
else around him sansa is befuddled she
says what do they want there is a long
moment of silence before helen reed says
velar more ghoulish your grace all men
must die we're living on their lands and
they will do everything in their power
to get them back we have to get bran out
of king's landing before it's too late
how do we know bran hasn't left king's
landing already how do we know bran
isn't with the children of the force
right now ask sansa
there's only one way to find out says
lord helen reed he looks in john's eyes
then looks at the werewold and nods his
head in its direction you were given the
bowl of weirwood seeds for a reason jon
snow
go set your hand on its face look
through its eyes and tell us what you
see
john slowly looks over at the white and
red weirwood he remembers what happened
when he leaned his head against one and
fell asleep
he can see ghost is still underneath it
sniffing around at the ground he walks
over next to him then kneels down
this is very reminiscent of when john
knelt in front of the weirwood beyond
the wall when he set his night's watch
vows he takes in a deep breath then lays
his hand over the face his head snaps
back and his eyes roll in his head he's
immediately thrown into a vision the
first thing john sees is a massive
weirwood standing taller than any of the
other ones he's ever seen before it's on
an island surrounded by a blue lake a
very large shadow soars over the water
and right behind that seems to be
another very large shadow he sees seven
children of the forest standing in a
circle on a beach right behind them
above the rocks is a castle it looks a
lot like dragonstone he can see bran
sitting in a weirwood throne like the
one in the three at ravens cave bran's
eyes are rolled back in his head he can
see brawn arguing with three star
guardsmen on a balcony overlooking a
city he then sees braun falling from
that balcony he sees greyworm standing
in front of him he looks enraged now he
sees the streets of king's landing right
where the old septa baylor used to sit
bran is sitting there in his wheelchair
brienne podrick and lord tyrion
lannister are there as well but before
he can make out everything that's
happening he snaps out of the visions
john's hand drops from the werewolf's
face he's now gasping for breath
everyone rushes over to him helen reed
bends down and throws an arm over his
shoulder are you okay asks lord howland
john looks around at his surroundings
remembering where he is he slowly
controls his breathing then says i'm
fine help me stand up helen reed and
tormund giants bane help john back on
his feet
sansa looks a bit stunned she's never
seen anything like this before are you
able to tell us what you saw says helen
reed
yes says john i did see bran he's still
in king's landing good says helen reed
we still have time i don't think we have
much time john says doubtfully bran had
his master of coin thrown from his
balcony why says sansa that doesn't make
any sense i don't know says john but i
think he's trying to wipe out his entire
small council
sansa is even more shocked than before
she says what makes you say that john
what else did you see
the sound of grief comes from john's
voice when he says lord tyrion lannister
has been arrested
i saw him kneeling over the
executioner's block helen reed
immediately stands back up when he hears
this he says we must leave now everyone
begins leaving the godswood but jon
stops them before they make another step
that's not all john says loudly i also
saw brienne and podrick they were
standing right behind lord tyrion there
is dread written all over santa's face
after a moment of silence sansa
nervously says what happened jon
the scene ends after he says they had
nooses around their necks
in the final scene of this episode we go
back inside the red keep of king's
landing we're in king branstark's
chambers on one side of the room bran is
sitting there surrounded by his new
sworn brothers of the kingsguard on the
other side of the room brianne and
podrick are standing there searching for
answers is everything all right your
grace asked brienne in a flat voice bran
says what would make you think something
was wrong well something is wrong says
berean you throw samwell's book into the
fire i know i don't know you that well
but that's not like you sir boronify
garden fell from your balcony there is a
bloody dead man lying in the old throne
room lord tyrion seems to be missing and
his chambers looked as if they have been
ramsacked i'm just trying to understand
what is happening around here brain
stares at her and looks right through
her with his unsympathetic eyes he says
it sounds like there is a ghost inside
the red key brienne stands her ground
not allowing bran or his men to frighten
her maybe it was a ghost or maybe it was
a wolf in sheep's clothing where is lore
tyrion bran cracks a thin smile before
saying he's sitting in the black cells
he has been charged for the murder of
sir beron this is nonsense shout berean
i was with lortirian in his chambers
when we heard the scream we ran outside
together we discovered braun's lifeless
body laying on the street below your
balcony together i know for a fact
tyrion lannister did not do this brain
stopped smiling one of his new
kingsguard members says lady berean
cannot be trusted your grace she has
always favored the lannisters rumor has
it she has even laid with the lannister
brienne looks at the man with eyes as
cold as ice she says i have no love for
the lannisters deny it all you want says
bran i've seen it myself
that sword says you're a liar did you
know that sword was made for my family's
ancestral sword after the lannister's
bastard seed butchered my father bran
now shifts his focus over to sir podrick
he says you're a lion as well you was
once the squire for lord tyrion
lannister and now you stand here beside
another what should i call you anyways
lady berean a lion in sheep's clothing
brienne looks into bran's soulless eyes
then says whatever treachery you think i
may have done sir podrick had nothing to
do with it that's enough says the man of
the kingsguard i think they both should
hang your grace
in a low voice bran says
who are you loyal to lady brienne
who are you sworn to guard with your
life lord tyrion of house lannister or
your king you must choose here and now
which house does that valerian steel
really fight for what are you asking of
mr grace asked brienne after a few
moments of silence bran says
lord tyrion is to be executed for the
charge of murder i want the lion's head
mounted on my wall
will you take it for your king or die
next to him you must choose take that
sword and slay the imp or be hanged for
a betrayer the sword or the noose
brienne's eyes fill up with water if she
wasn't frightened before she is now
finally brienne sucks in a ragged breath
and says i will not make that choice
there was another long silence after
this brand's new kingsguard members look
at each other in disbelief this episode
ends after brain says
hang them
in the very first scene of this episode
we will go down south on the sacred isle
of faces there is a full moon in the
night sky sitting directly above the
massive werewolf at the center of the
gods eye its reflection can be seen on
the lake giving us just enough light to
see what's standing on the shore no
different than any other night the green
men are standing their silent watch over
the ancient werewoods while they stand
their silent watch over the sacred
island the black green and red
dragonglass in their spears is glowing
under the moonlit sky
everything and everyone on the island is
silent except for the thousands of red
leaves dancing in the wind
the faces on the werewoods are as
frightening as ever their blood-filled
eyes are staring back at us as a
red-like substance drips down from them
onto the ground we then begin to make
our way into the middle of the god's eye
all of the white walkers who were once
here riding on the backs of their giant
elks are now gone there is still a very
large fire burning at the center of the
island where westeros's largest werewolf
sits surrounded by seven more werewolves
that are all facing inward at the orange
and red flames the face on this massive
werewood looks horrific its mouth is so
large a grown man could easily walk
right through it without ducking as we
stare into its blood-red eyes that are
full of secrets and ancient wisdom
hundreds of ravens suddenly explode from
the werewolf's gaping mouth their black
wings fill the sky and their loud
shrieking brings an end to this silent
night this is when the children of the
forest begin to emerge from the woods
their great big golden cat's eyes are
now glowing in the shadows the sound of
branches breaking and leaves crunching
can be heard as they make their way to
the center of the aisle there are seven
of them each holding dragonglass weapons
of their own
one by one they begin jumping into the
mouth of the massive werewood sitting in
the middle of the grove as we follow
them inside we immediately notice the
werewolf's mouth is filled with hundreds
of skulls of those who were once
sacrificed to the old gods over the
centuries the inside of this giant
werewood drops down into a cave system
like the one we have seen out beyond the
wall only this one has more light
allowing us to see much further into the
dark abyss
the seven children of the forest begin
ascending down deep into the earth the
scene ends as we watch them vanish into
the unknown only they know what lies
ahead but you will find out soon enough
in the following scene we are back in
the capital of westeros the sun is
slowly starting to rise over king's
landing as the city begins to wake up
there are men and women opening up their
small shops and markets for business
there are wagons full of new arrivals
entering the city every day they're
small children running through the
streets as some older kids are chasing
behind them once again the scent of raw
sewage and freshly baked bread hangs
heavy in the morning air there's about a
dozen black ravens circling in the sky
above the red keep as samwell and davos
emerge from within the castle
they begin walking over to the main gate
where there are some men of the city
watch standing guard davos begins saying
something to sam but he doesn't hear
what he says because he's busy looking
over at the ground where he remembers
seeing sir brawn's lifeless body the
dried blood that was once on the stone
street has been washed away but sam will
never forget what he saw that day he
suddenly stops walking then looks over
at the city watch to make sure they are
out of earshot before he interrupts
davos by asking him have he heard any
new developments regarding what happened
to sir brawn has anyone found out what
actually happened i wish i could give
you that information says sir davos but
i'm afraid i do not know i was about to
ask you the same thing what about
lorterion says samwell have you spoke to
him about it wood that i could say sir
davos but i haven't spoke to him about
it either as a matter of fact i haven't
seen lord tyrion since the day we
discovered brawn had fallen from your
grace's balcony sam nervously looks into
davos's eyes then whispers i'm not so
sure he fell sir brawn would have no
reason to be in king branch chambers or
on his balcony unless he was sent for
davos slowly looks up at the red key as
he thinks about what sam just said
you're right davos says reluctantly the
balcony has a railing that stops anyone
from falling over so easily he fell
because someone shoved him sam says
dreadfully they are suddenly interrupted
by the sound of riders arriving at the
main gate as sam begins walking over he
shouts open the gates these men are with
me
when the three riders dismount from
their horses the guards from the city
watch open the gates allowing them
inside one of these writers removes a
letter from inside his sleeve before
handing it over to sam without saying a
word sam smiles and nods his head at the
men who immediately begin mounting their
horses again davos looks confused by
this brief interaction sam starts
walking away as he breaks the wax seal
on the letter wondering what just
happened davos stops him demanding to
know who those men were and why they
hand delivered him this letter sam grabs
him by the arm then walks him away from
the main gate where the men of the city
watch are still standing guard sam looks
around making sure no one else can hear
them in a low voice he says it's from
the citadel
davos is visibly unsatisfied with that
answer so he says well what's it about
what's with all of this secrecy
sam takes a moment before he says when i
left the citadel let's just say i
borrowed some of their books what do you
mean borrowed davos says doubtfully fine
says sam i stole some books from the
citadel but i had every intention of
giving them back once i was done with
them however something happened to one
of the books before i could do that one
of them was about the legends of the
long night i noticed something very
interesting on the front of that book so
i brought it to king bran hoping he
could help me figure out what it meant
but for some reason he threw the book
into the fire this is when i first
started thinking something might be
wrong with bran so i wrote a letter to
the citadel asking them if they could
give me any more information on the
subject the only thing is i never heard
back from them that's when i started
thinking bran might be intercepting all
of the ravens coming in and out of
king's landing since the ravens were
compromised i sent writers of my own
they hand delivered my messages then
brought me back the archmaester's
findings i don't know why but i believe
bran doesn't want me to know the answers
i am looking for well i may finally hold
them in my hand davos is taken aback by
all of this he shakes his head in
disbelief before wiping the sweat from
his forehead after a long deep breath
davos says what does the letter say sam
stands beside him then holds it up for
both of them to read we're not able to
make out everything the letter says but
we do see a few lines that are written
down we can see it says in regards to
the book about the legends of the long
night then further down the letter we're
also able to see it says the green men
on the isle of faces now we focus on
davos sam sam's face as they finish
reading the letter
sam's eyes widen and his mouth hangs
open as he sucks in a deep breath we
follow his eyes as they leave the letter
they slowly look up at the red keep
above them this scene ends when sam
notices bran is now sitting out on his
balcony staring down at them
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell we are following helen reed
as he makes his way across the courtyard
the grounds are now flooded with house
stark soldiers and bannermen of the
north it looks as if they're getting
ready for war
dozens of men are getting fitted for
armor dozens of other men are handing
out dragonglass weapons that were left
over from the long night battle while
others are mounting their horses helen
reed heads for the godswood where john
and sansa are standing before the
werewood when he notices they are still
in conversation he stops for a moment so
they can finish he grabs the large item
from his back before dropping it down
onto the ground he checks to make sure
it's still fully wrapped up in the fur
after securing it again he slings it
back over his shoulder another minute
goes by then helen reed finally says i'm
sorry to disturb you your grace but the
men are just about saddled and ready we
must leave soon john looks at sanzo with
a bit of sadness in his eyes before
opening up his arms and giving her a big
hug
the air is thick with us all in silence
lord halen reed watches as jon whispers
something in her ear when they let go of
each other john looks at helen reed and
says i'm ready john and sansa begin
walking over to wirelord helen reed as
standing on the other side of the
godswood the leaves and snow crunches
underneath their feet with each and
every step john suddenly stops when he
feels something hard under his foot he
lifts his boot then reaches down and
grabs something that was half buried in
the ground as he begins to brush away
the snow he immediately recognizes what
it is sansa says you're not the first
one to step on that i also found it
before but i wasn't sure what it was
from john looks over at helen reed who
is looking at the object in his hands
john says this was the night kings i saw
him wearing this beyond the wall and
then again here in winterfell it must
have fallen from his uniform after he
was stabbed by arya this reminds jon of
what else he found not long ago he grabs
something he has had stashed inside of
his fur overcoat slanza can't believe
what jon is holding in his hands she
says is that brand's where did you find
that it was inside a cave out beyond the
wall it was where bran met the
three-eyed raven the same cave where i
met the children of the forest and lord
howland reed in one hand john is holding
the night king's metallic symbol that he
wore around his neck in the other hand
he is holding bran's metallic stark
choker that he wore on his neck he
studies both of them for a few moments
before sansa finally grabs his arm and
says john i sent ravens down to king's
landing hoping i could speak with bran
when they were left unanswered i sent
men down there as well
they still aren't back from the capitol
they won't be coming back helen reed
says ominously
sansa's eyes fill with anger as she says
what how do you know that i'm sorry your
grace but i did say your brother bran is
in grave danger if your men aren't back
yet then they're dead already
lord howland then looks back in john's
eyes and says we must leave now the
three of them silently exit the godswood
john and halen's horses are already
waiting for them in the courtyard as
well as all the men who are now leaving
with them right before they mount their
horses sansa stops helen reed she says
do you think this will be enough men
i've sent out more ravens but i'm not
sure if they will make it to their
destinations lord howland looks around
at all of the men gathered inside the
courtyard and the men who are mounted
just outside of the gate there's maybe
700 soldiers or fewer i won't lie to you
your grace i honestly don't know if this
will be enough but it's certainly better
than what we had before we stopped here
this amount of men does help but it will
also slow us down
the underground system isn't big enough
for this many men we will have to find a
way to make do with the circumstances we
are in your grace thank you says sansa
lord hallon bows his head before
knocking his heels against his horse as
jon and sansa watch the men begin to
leave the courtyard she says one last
thing to jon before he goes south this
scene ends right after santa says john i
want you to get our brother out of
king's landing bring him home
as jon and his horse are leaving through
winterfell's main gate he looks back
over his shoulder then says i will
in the next scene we go back out at sea
where there are roughly 100 ships
sailing under the bright sunlight the
sun's reflection is bouncing off the
deep blue sea but it's suddenly
swallowed up by a massive shadow flying
above drogon soars across the sky as he
overlooks all of the ships down below
he's drinking up the morning sun as he
stretches his wings and glides through
the hazy air the sails of the fiery
heart and the three-headed dragon are
flapping hard in the wind the scene
begins as we see kanvara standing on the
deck of the ship in our long scarlet
silk robe we can see the sun in her eyes
as she glares into the sky at drogon
she stares at the dragon for several
moments but she finally looks away when
she hears daenerys walking her way
kinvara notices dany has a look of
discomfort written all over her face as
she approaches her kinvara says is
everything all right your grace no says
daenerys i am still worried about grey
worm i haven't seen him since last night
he is still locked inside one of the
cabins with the man you brought with us
mokaro kenvara smiles then reaches out
and grabs daenerys by her hand
you will see him soon enough your grace
says kinvara
greyworm's flesh was kissed by fire he
is not as resistant to the flames like
you have been before he let his emotions
get the best of him he was foolish for
grabbing the burning brazier before
slamming it down onto the deck of the
ship there are no maesters on board with
us but lucky for him we have macaro if
anyone here will be able to fix grey
worm it will be him as she lets go of
her hand daenerys says some of your
soldiers said they heard wild laughter
coming from inside makaro's cabin
laughter that was deep and dark and mad
later they said they heard him singing
some song in high valerian kenvara
smiles again she says see for yourself
daenerys stormborn here they come now
when daenerys looks over her shoulder
she can see greyworm and mccarro are
walking their way
danny notices greyworm is naked from the
waist up his right hand is wrapped in
bandages but his left hand looks very
disturbing the other men standing around
the ship begin whispering and trading
glances as they get a look at greyworm's
arm is everything okay says daenerys
after grey worm and macaro stop in front
of her let me have a look at your hand
says kinvara greyworm raised a charred
and blackened tan it was bloody all the
way up to his elbow even black smoke
rose from his fingers a horrified
daenerys says i will find you a maester
as soon as we reach westeros that is not
necessary says macaro i have fixed his
hand your grace danny then looks back at
grey worm waiting for him to say
something i am fine your grace says
greyworm my hand feels even stronger
than it did before
it feels like there is a fire running
through the veins in my hand makaro
smiles then walks away back below the
deck
greyworm then looks at kinvara and says
may i speak with your grace alone of
course says kinvara who smiles bowser
head then leaves as well when they're
finally alone daenerys asks him again
are you sure everything is okay yes your
grace i swear my hand feels fine but
there is something else i think we
should discuss
okay says daenerys with a bit of
hesitation in her voice what would you
like to discuss it's jon snow says grey
worm i am worried about what might
happen once we land in westeros again
this kanvara says we will need him but i
don't know how much i believe her
he has already shown us that he cannot
be trusted your grace you have said that
we need to stop brandon stark but that's
jon snow's brother what happens if jon
has to choose between saving you or
saving his own brother what happens if
brain attempts to harm you
would jon kill his own brother to save
you because i don't think he will i
think the opposite is more likely to
happen your grace danny looks out at the
deep blue sea that surrounds them
she watches as drogon flies down low
before he skims right above the water
after another moment of silence daenerys
finally says i do understand your
concerns i have some of my own some days
i walk out onto this deck look out at
the sea and wonder if i should go back
to westeros at all sometimes i wonder if
i should risk my own life to save those
who may never love me on other days i
walk out onto this deck look out at the
sea and think about killing jon snow as
soon as we land in westeros those dark
thoughts eventually fade away when i
remember why i wanted to take back the
iron throne that i thought was
rightfully mine i don't want to be
remembered the same way as everyone
remembers my father some of the anger
starts to leave greyworm's eyes i want
to save those who can't save themselves
says daenerys that's one of the reasons
why so many were willing to follow me if
i can't fight for that then it was all
for nothing westeros and even the entire
realm is right back where we started
i have decided that if i am going to
live i can't live with that daenerys
begins slowly walking away but then she
stops and looks back at greyworm
she says but then again
words are just wind if i am being honest
i don't know how i will react when i see
jon snow again grey worm lifts his head
back up he looks over at danny and there
is a fire in his eyes again
as daenerys goes to walk away greyworm
stops her he says your grace i saw jon
snow on the back of drogon when can vara
had me look in her flames if jon rides
drogon what does that mean happen to you
there is a bit of sadness in danny's
eyes when she softly says
i don't know
the scene ends right after grey worm
says i won't let you out of my sight
again your grace when we arrive in
westeros i will kill jon snow myself in
the next scene we are back in king's
landing we follow samwell and sir davos
as they are walking inside of the red
key the sound of their footsteps scare
off some of the ravens that are in the
great hall where the iron throne once
sat as they are making their way across
the throne room davos and sam hold their
hands over their nose when they start
smelling a horrible stench the ravens
have nearly finished eating the unknown
dead man who has been laying in the
great hall all week when sam and davos
look over at what's left of him all we
see is basically a skeleton dressed in
bloody rags there is a raven standing on
the rotting man's skull watching davos
and sam with hatred in its black eyes
the raven watches them until they're out
of sight when sam and davos finally
arrive in the small council's chambers
they sit in their seats and wait
there is an ominous silence in the small
council room
davos looks around at all of the empty
seats beside them
we watch them sit here in silence for
what feels like several minutes at last
davos throws a glance sam's way and says
how early are we they should be here
already says sam we have our meetings at
this hour every week maybe lorterian is
running late says their davos it
certainly wouldn't be the first time sam
smiles nervously before he says no it
would not but that doesn't answer for
sir padraig and brianne does brienne
strike you as someone who runs late no
she doesn't says sir davos now sam
begins looking around the room at all of
the empty seats braun is dead but lord
tyrion sir podrick and berean and even
king bran are not at their scheduled
meeting that's when they begin hearing
the sound of boots walking their way
they eagerly stand up hoping to see
their other advisors walk in and join
them instead a man dressed in the golden
kingsguard armor stands before them
hello says sam as he smiles the
kingsguard man doesn't smile nor does he
greet sam back this is one of the same
men who arrested lord tyrion as well as
brienne and sir podrick follow me says
the member of the kingsguard but we have
a meeting says sam we are waiting for
the others there will be no meeting
today says the king's guardman i'm only
here because your grace said i would
find both of you here he gave me orders
to locate both of you then bring you
with me to join him follow me he's right
this way as the member of the kingsguard
begins walking away sam and davos look
at each other with confusion they don't
fully understand what's happening wait a
minute says davos you will have to
forgive me sir but we have never seen
you before who are you and where did you
get that armor the king's guardman
smiles as he slowly starts walking
davos's way until he's standing right in
front of him
he stares long and hard into his eyes
but then he abruptly jams the handle of
his sword into davos's stomach forcing
him to fall down to one knee as davos
tries finding his breath the king's
guard member says your grace is the only
man i answer to now as i said before
follow me your king commands it
sam rushes over helping davos get back
on his feet
after he finally catches his breath
davos and sam reluctantly follow the
kingsguard man out of the room then down
the stairs they both feel an
overwhelming sense of dread
sam's feet feel heavier after each and
every step as they make their ascension
down the stairs they begin hearing what
sounds like a large crowd gathered
outside it grows louder and louder as
they get closer to the doors sam and
davos look at each other with
uncertainty when they reach the main
entrance of the red keep the king's
guard man swings open the doors they are
momentarily blinded by the sunlight and
the sound of a thousand voices shouting
makes them feel a little disoriented sam
rubs his eyes as he looks around at the
crowd gathering outside
davos holds his stomach as he follows
them around the side of the red key
samwell and sir davos are shocked by
what they see up ahead
they see bran sitting on a very large
platform about a hundred feet away a few
men are seen behind him setting up the
gallows for an execution right in front
of bran is lortyrian brienne and podrick
all of them are down on their knees with
their hands behind their backs each of
them have a gag in their mouth as well
standing right next to bran are the
other new members of the kingsguard sam
and davos rush through the crowd as they
make their way up to the stage davos
yells out your grace what is the meaning
of this why are they bound and gagged
however bran doesn't answer him
instead sam and davis are immediately
arrested by the new sworn brothers of
the kingsguard one of bran's guards
leans in close to davos and sam he says
don't say another word
let this serve as a lesson now enjoy the
show
sam and davos are stunned by this
shocking turn of events suddenly bran
lifts his arms in the air silencing the
large crowd gathered in front of them
when the screaming and shouting begins
to soften brain says it's very
unfortunate that we have to meet under
these circumstances but it seems there
are some rebels among us lord tyrion
lannister your very own hand of the king
is guilty of murdering his friend our
master of coin sir braunify garden lady
berean and sir podrick have always been
on the side of the lannisters this is
when one of brandt's king's guard shouts
lady buran even laid with a lannister
she slept with sir jaime lannister the
kingslayer she has also written lies
about him in our white book making him
out to be some sort of hero the crowd
erupts when they hear this we hear some
of them shouting the lannisters have
always been murderers kill them all some
of them begin spitting at breanne while
others are throwing rocks at lord tyrion
after a few moments of this bran lefts
his arms again silencing everyone there
he says i gave brienne a chance to show
her loyalty all she had to do was kill
lord tyrion
show us that once and for all you no
longer favor the lannisters but she
would not do this it seems that lady
berean would rather die than to honor
her king well lady brienne i will give
you one more chance bran gives a signal
to one of the king's guard who then
walks over and removes the gag from
brienne's mouth i will ask you again in
front of everyone says bran
who do you fight for lady berean
will you defend your king by slaying
this murderous lion of lannister or will
you die beside him you must decide here
and now the sword or the noose as the
tears are falling from brian's face she
helplessly looks over at sir podrick who
has sadness in his eyes as well he
shakes his head no
he doesn't want brienne to break her on
her by giving him what he wants she now
looks over at lord tyrion who is covered
in his own sweat in urine brienne looks
into bran's eyes it seems like all of
his life has left them as he stares back
at her emotionless finally she says i
will not make that choice the crowd
explodes into shouting again then so be
it says brin your fate has been sealed
he looks at his new sworn brothers of
the kingsguard then says hang them first
brienne and sir podrick are yanked up
onto their feet sam and davis are even
more horrified than before
they know there is nothing they can do
to stop this the nooses were slipped
around their necks then jerked tight one
of the brothers of the kingsguard looks
at brienne then says if you have any
other crimes you want to confess to your
gods now would be the time to say them
when she doesn't answer him he smiles
then says you're the strong silent type
i see
have it your way lady brienne
now let's see if you can dance he yanked
on a rope hard before the floor fell out
from under brienne and sir podrick's
feet brienne immediately felt the hemp
constricting around her neck digging
into her skin forcing her chin upward it
sounds like lorterion is cursing at them
through his gag but not the boy sir
podrick never lifted his eyes not even
when his feet jerked up off the ground
brienne thought if this is some bad
dream it is time for me to awaken if
this is real it is time for me to die
all she could see was sir podrick the
noose around his thin neck and his legs
as they started to spasm he was kicking
choking and dying
her mouth opened she sucked the air in
desperately even as the rope was
strangling her
nothing had ever hurt so much
this scene ends right after brienne
screams a word
in the final scene of this episode we go
back below the ground somewhere under
westeros we are following seven small
shadows as they move through the
darkness that lies ahead one of them is
holding a light but we're still not able
to see enough to make out who they are
we keep following the seven shadows as
they move further and further into the
black abyss it's not long before they
spill out into a large open cave when
this happens their light reflects off
the cave walls revealing who they are
it's the seven children of the forest
who jumped into the mouth of the massive
werewood on the isle of faces
they are now standing inside of a cave
that has familiar drawings all over its
walls as we see more and more drawings
on the walls we realize it's the same
cave john and daenerys were in on
dragonstone these seven small creatures
walk through the cave until they emerge
out onto the beach there is a full blood
moon in the sky the empty large castle
looms over them as they form a circle
near the edge of the water
all seven of them are now facing inward
at each other that's when each of them
simultaneously grab their dragonglass
daggers before they make a small
incision on their hand as the blood
drips down from their hands it falls
onto the sand and a small wave of water
comes up to their feet the salt water
washes away their blood before sucking
it back out to the sea now they shut
their eyes as they start saying
something in a language unknown by man
it sounds more like they're singing a
song a song of the earth this is when
something very strange starts to happen
dark clouds begin forming right above
them
lightning starts to strike thunder
begins to crack the sound of the wind
gets very loud as it throws sand all
over the beach suddenly a lightning bolt
strikes down onto dragonstone leaving a
very large crack across the face of the
stone castle the seven children of the
forest begin chanting louder and louder
as the dark clouds above them get even
more violent the waves in the sea are
getting larger but they're not smashing
into the shore it's almost as if the
ocean water is lifting directly up into
the sky the children finally opened
their eyes all we see is white
again their chanting grows even louder
as the thunder snaps and cracks like a
whip as the sea water begins moving
faster in a circular direction another
bolt of lightning strikes down right
into the center of the swirling water as
soon as the dark clouds begin to open up
the children's chanting stops but in
that exact moment it looks as if an
explosion goes off in the water millions
of gallons of sea water flies up into
the sky as a black shadow emerges above
we suddenly hear the ear splitting
scream of a dragon
with their dark magic the children have
summoned rhaegal from below the sea
it's the most frightening thing we have
ever seen the dragon's eyes are now red
because it was decomposing in the salt
water for so long some of its scales are
slipping right off of its bones the
large holes in his neck and chest allow
us to see its fire burning inside of him
at all times the episode ends as the
dragon disappears into the night sky
in the very first scene of this episode
we are back in king's landing there is
still a massive crowd gathered around
outside of the red key all of their eyes
are focused on what is happening up on
the center stage in front of them
samwell davos as well as everyone else
who is standing around them are watching
in silence as brianne and sir padraig
are cut down from their nooses as soon
as their bodies hit the ground they
immediately start gasping for breath
lord tyrion lannister's head rises from
the executioner's block he looks behind
him shocked by what he heard brienne is
slowly getting back on her feet but it's
not easy while her hands are still bound
behind her back when she looks over at
tyrion all he can do is shake his head
no
there is sadness in her eyes again but
only for a moment now she looks away as
one of the members of the king's guard
begins walking over her way he's holding
a small blade in his right hand he grabs
brianne by the shoulder then moves her
so he can free the rope that's wrapped
around her hands he does the same thing
for sarpadric who is now standing up on
his feet as well sam looks over at davos
unsure of what will happen next lady
berean says a voice from the other end
of the stage everyone looks over at bran
stark who has a member of his new
kingsguard standing on his right and
left side laying across his lap is
oathkeeper brianne's valerian steel
sword lady berean says brain again as he
lifts up her sword in the air he says i
believe you are asking for this the
sword is yours and you and sir podrick
will be free to go but first you must
lay lord tyrion's head at my feet
remember the sword or the noose i will
not ask you again says bran the member
of the kingsguard walks back across the
stage he has then handed brianne's
valerian steel sword sam and davis watch
as the man walks back across the stage
again now holding the sword out in front
of him every one of the onlookers and
the crowd are silent as a crypt the
king's guardman stops when he is
standing before brienne he hands her the
sword then steps off to the side brienne
grabs a firm grip around oathkeeper's
handle with both hands she looks over at
bran as well as the other king's guard
men who are standing at his right and
left side then she looks over at
sarpodric who is ever so slightly
shaking his head now brienne extends her
arms out in front of her the reflection
of the sun bounces off her sword she
begins resting the blade on the back of
lorterian's neck as she takes in another
deep breath the edge of oath keeper is
so sharp you can already see a drop of
blood on the back of the neck where the
blade is resting brienne slowly raises
the sword high above her head
lord tyrion shuts his eyes as his body
begins to involuntarily shake
as soon as the blade begins to fall from
the sky brienne does a sidestep then
swings the sword around with her arms
now fully extended in one swift motion
oathkeeper slices all the way through
the neck of the kingsguard men standing
at her side his head goes bouncing off
the stage into the crowd a thick rope of
blood shoots out of his neck six feet
into the sky
the crowd of onlookers below erupt into
absolute chaos the king's guardman who
is standing at bran's left side begins
rushing forward as soon as brianne sees
him their blades come crashing into each
other the sound of steel slamming
against steel can be heard echoing
throughout the city square
sir podrick runs over and grabs the
sword from the headless body laying in
front of him he immediately starts
cutting the restraints around davos and
sam's hands when davos is set free he
grabs the small blade from the headless
king's guardman then he helps lorterion
with the rope around his hands and feet
brienne's sword smashes against the
other member of the kingsguard sword
again only now it knocks it free from
his hand before his sword even hits the
ground brienne drives her own right
through his stomach and out of his back
as soon as she yanks it back out his
lifeless body collapses brienne then
drops down on one knee hoping to find
her breath everything happens so fast
it's almost as if everyone on stage is
in a daze davos sam and the others all
look at each other stunned by what just
happened half of the crowds standing
down below begins to leave now that the
show is over the other half finally goes
silent as they wonder what will happen
now
suddenly brienne stands back up on her
feet she then begins walking back and
forth across the stage looking at
everything and everyone around her after
several moments of this brienne finally
says where is bran
there was an anger in her voice that
none of them heard from her before they
all began desperately looking around the
stage somehow bran must have escaped
after the fighting broke out brienne
looks at them in disbelief this scene
ends after she says he couldn't have
gone far in the following scene we go
right outside of the city we can see
king's landing in the distance maybe
only a few miles away it looks as if
there are hundreds of ravens circling
above the castle arya stark suddenly
stops her horse gendry does the same
before he says why are we stopping here
we're almost there arya looks up into
the sky above them searching to see if
any ravens are following when she
doesn't see any arya says i don't want
us marching 500 men right up to the
gates we don't want everyone in that
city thinking we're here for a fight we
gotta find my brother bran before any of
his guards find us first we also need to
find a boat i know of a way we can get
into the castle undetected gendry smiles
then says i'm sure you do go find me the
commander says arya i will need to speak
to him before we leave gendry whistles
then motions for one of the men who is
standing at the front of the line arya
and gendry hop down from their horses as
the commander steps forward arya says we
will need you and all of your men to
wait here gendry and i will head into
the city first if we need your
assistance we will give a signal we will
be ready when you are says the commander
we follow arya and gendry as they walk
down the hill behind them before they
begin walking along the bank of the
blackwater rush the sun in the sky is
slowly starting to hide behind the
horizon
there are several men fishing on the
other side of the shore but neither of
them notice arya or gendry they end up
walking one and a half miles before they
find a dock that has a boat without
hesitation arya grabs her dagger slices
the rope securing it to the dock then
jumps in gendry shoves the boat away
from the dock before he jumps in himself
the fast flowing water dumps them right
out onto the blackwater bay within
minutes they stay right along the
shoreline until they're directly under
the red key
once they're under the castle gendry
hops out and brings the small boat up
onto the beach after arya gets out her
eyes shoot back out across the
blackwater bay arya is shocked when she
suddenly notices something unexpected
there is a massive black dragon filling
the sky up above and right below it on
the bay is what looks like 100 ships
heading their way gendry's eyes are now
filled with fear he says we must hurry
my lady those are the banners of the
lord of light they have somehow taken
over daenerys dragon i'm not so sure of
that arya says if that's drogon then i'm
afraid daenerys is with them you were
there when the hound killed beric
dondarrion the lord of light brought him
back right before our very own eyes if
they somehow have daenerys body she's
alive gendry knows he has seen a
resurrection before but he's still
shocked at the thought of daenerys
coming back on her dragon look again
says arya gendry's eyes follow hers back
out onto the blackwater bay they can now
see the banners of house targaryen
flapping above some of those ships when
gendry looks back at her in disbelief
arya shouts let's go the scene ends
after arya and gendry vanish into the
sewage drain in the following scene we
are suddenly on the other side of the
city in front of its main gate well i
should say this is where the main gate
was it's no longer there since drogon
blew it wide open with his dragon flame
there are about a dozen masons finishing
some stone work before it gets dark but
there's still a big hole where the
city's main gate used to be
there is also several men of the city
watch standing there on guard one of the
men from the city watch begins walking
forward after he sees a large force
heading his way right in front of him
are jon snow helen reed and tormund
giantsbane who have arrived at king's
landing as well almost every main
character who is still alive are now
here now unlike arya and gendry jon has
brought all of his men with him to the
city their several hundred soldiers
standing behind jon and the others this
is exactly where jon stood moments
before the battle of king's landing
begun as the man from the city watch
walks forward helen reed stands beside
jon then whispers she's here john looks
over at him before he says who is here
my lord helen reed diverts his eyes to
the sky as he looks off into the
distance see for yourself says alan reed
john's eyes look out across the city at
first all he sees is the red keep on the
other side of king's landing but as he
looks up further above the castle he
suddenly notices black wings in the sky
jon now has a dreadful look on his face
after he recognizes drogon flying in
front of the moon in the distance he
remembers what he did to the men who
murdered him he wonders if dany will
want to do the same thing jon suddenly
finds himself reaching for a sword but
he shifts his focus once the man from
the city watch stops in front of him
what is the meaning of this says the
gold cloak why are there hundreds of
soldiers standing outside of our gates i
need to see the king right away says jon
i don't think so says the man of the
city watch you can't just show up here
like this and expect to see the king
whenever you want i would suggest that
you and your men go back but the man is
interrupted by thorman giantsbane before
he can ever finish his sentence this is
when tormund says we did not march all
of this way to ask you for permission we
are entering this city one way or
another now you can either step aside
and let us in or i will go through you
myself we're not here to fight with you
says helen reed we're here because the
king is in danger we want to help him
then helen reed lifts a finger into the
sky and says besides i would be more
worried about that then i would be with
us when the man of the city watch looks
over his shoulder his mouth hangs open
in shock once he sees a dragon circling
above the red key he says nothing as jon
and all of his men begin walking forward
into the city the scene ends as we watch
them head right for the king's castle in
the following scene we are now in the
dungeons of the red key arya stark and
gendry are making their way into the
castle's dark underbelly when they walk
out of one of the black hallways arya
notices the dragon skulls up ahead we're
almost there says arya follow me they
walk over to where there are a long
flight of stairs leading up to the main
level of the castle they slowly and
silently walk up each step arya grabs
her dagger as they emerge from the
shadows then out onto the main floor
after a few moments she looks back over
her shoulder at gendry in disbelief
there's no guard says arya that doesn't
make any sense it almost feels as if the
castle is empty they stay against the
wall as they walk on the other side of
the hall now they enter the hall that
was once the home of the iron throne
there are still a few ravens walking
along the floor gendry motions in the
direction where the iron throne once set
there are some bones scattered across
the floor as well what in the seven
hells happened here gendry wondered this
castle has become a graveyard they exit
the great hall now they walk across the
small council room then over the map of
westeros that's on the floor there is a
full moon up in the sky above them but
it vanishes after drogon flaps his
massive black wings in front of it let's
go caesarea as they begin ascending the
stairs they suddenly hear the sound of a
voice they can see bran's doris slightly
open before they even reach it arya
immediately swings open his door with
her right hand while she holds her
valerian steel dagger and her left hand
once they are inside the room they are
unexpectedly greeted by sir davos
samwell brianne sarpodrick and lorterion
they're all stunned when they see arya
walking through that door lady arya says
brienne why are you back in king's
landing i thought you were leaving
westeros for good so did i says arya
that was until an assassin was waiting
for me in the cabin on my ship i wasn't
sure if i should believe the man or not
but the unknown man said that bran was
the one who hired him to kill me i'm
here to find out what's wrong with my
brother i guess he wants me dead you're
not the only one says lortyrian he wants
all of us dead he would have been
successful if it wasn't for brienne
saving our lives where is brain at now
ask gendry we don't know says davos one
minute he was here then the next he was
gone we need to find him right away says
arya they are suddenly interrupted by a
thunderous sound that only could have
come from a dragon the sound of dread
can be heard in lortirian's voice when
he says what the hell was that you know
what that sound was says arya you were
around the dragons longer than any of us
it looks like daenerys is back from the
dead
she has a hundred ships right outside of
the city walls everyone looks a bit
shaken up by the revelation no one says
a word for a few moments finally davos
says well the fact that we're not all
burning alive right now might be a good
sign that she's not here for a fight if
that really is drogon above us we would
be dead already if that's what she
wanted davos's words ease some of the
nervousness in the room but arya doesn't
look so sure about that arya grabs the
burning torch out of gendry's hand
before walking out onto the balcony of
the king's chambers she begins waving it
back and forth in the air giving the
signal to the men waiting outside of the
city when arya walks back inside she
says well we're about to find out
exactly what daenerys wants if it is a
fight that she wants we will give her
one gendry let's move arya and gendry
exit the room before heading back down
the stairs unsure of what to do next
brienne sam davos tyrion and sir podrick
follow right behind them all of them
walk across the painted map of westeros
then through the small council room
before heading down the hallway that
leads into the great hall where the iron
throne was once located after they enter
the great hall they suddenly stop when
they hear the sound of loud footsteps
walking their way arya and brienne reach
for their weapon one of the ravens lets
out a loud shriek before it starts
circling above their heads near the
ceiling finally there are shadows that
emerge from the darkness on the other
side of the great hall arya gendry
brienne sarpodrick davos sam and
lortirian watch as they slowly walk
their way daenerys targaryen has
officially arrived walking in front of
her is grey worm as well as several of
his unsolid men they already have their
weapons in hand on dany's right and left
side are kanvara and makaro walking
behind them are about a dozen slave
soldiers of the fiery hand lord tyrion
lannister has a fearful look in his eyes
he almost looks as if he'd just seen a
ghost the silence is interrupted by a
thunderous scream as drogon lands on the
roof of the red key the ceiling begins
shaking as the dragon walks over to
where there is still a large opening in
the castle wall
the moonlight is glimmering off of his
shiny black scales his dark red eyes
never leave daenerys as he watches over
his mother in the great hall when they
reach the center of the room greyworm
and his unsullied men step aside as
kinvara and makaro step forward in a
loud booming voice that echoes
throughout the hall makaro says my
friends we are here on this night on
behalf of our lord of light he then
looks over at arya when he says
unfortunately a darkness rises again it
has fallen over westeros already yet it
threatens our very existence as it
sweeps over the entire realm the great
other has your brother as we speak we
must act fast will you stand beside us
as we bring the light back into all of
our lives again davos brienne sam and
tyrion all look at each other in
disbelief
i don't understand says arya i killed
the night king i watched as his army
fell right before my very own eyes what
are you saying makaro's dark shining
eyes study everyone in the great hall as
he says the night king was simply an
instrument of the great other just as we
are simply an instrument of the lord of
light why do you think your brother
tried to have you killed there was a
weariness in arya's voice as she asked
him how did you know about that makaro
smiles before he says i have seen this
and much more and were lore's sacred
flames he then looks back at daenerys
and says the lord of light has shown me
daenerys stormborn's worth that's why we
stand beside her now every night in my
fires i have glimpsed the glory that
awaits her is that right arya says
angrily did this lord of light show you
what daenerys did to this city i saw
that with my own eyes as well i was down
there in those city streets watching as
her and her dragon burned innocent women
and children is that this glory that you
speak of now if that's not darkness
falling over westeros then i don't know
what is the lady arya is right whispered
a voice from the shadows there was a
darkness within daenerys and even her
dragon as she burned the city to the
ground it was the same darkness that
lives within your brother brandon stark
now
who said that astoria do you know where
my brother is a moment goes by before
the man behind the voice steps out of
the shadows my name is alan reed my lady
i know where your brother is and i know
what is wrong with him i'm afraid the
great other has him now and all of us
must leave soon if we want to live some
of the anger leaves arya's eyes as she
says you're friends with my father i was
my lady says helen reed arya looks at
kinvara and makaro then back at alan
reed before she says both of you speak
of this great other yet i don't know
what that is who are they where are they
and what do they want with bran well
it's just as he said says helen reed
your brother is simply their instrument
no different than the night king was
before they created the night king after
all and they were living inside of his
mind the same way that they are inside
of brain's mind now there is an island
not far from here known as the isle of
faces some of you may know it as the
god's eye on this sacred isle live some
of the wisest and eldest living members
of the children of the forest they have
been living there since before the first
man ever stepped foot on westerosi soil
they are extremely dangerous and their
veins have been filled with hatred for
thousands of years they want the same
thing daenerys wanted they want what
they believe is rightfully theirs they
want back all of the land that man stole
from them and they will stop at nothing
unless every last one of us are dead
lord tyrion who has been standing behind
everyone else finally steps forward a
hint of anger flashes across dany's face
after she sees him so they have been
inside of bran's mind making him kill
all of us says tyrion i'm afraid so says
helen reed after a moment of silence
lord tyrion whispers why do you think i
came all this way this immediately gets
the attention of arya sam davos gendry
and brienne they all remember hearing
bran say that right before he was named
king he knew says tyrion he knew exactly
what would happen after i suggested we
name bran as our new king he said why do
you think i came all this way it's as if
everything happened exactly the way he
wanted he knew we would defeat the army
of the dead after a sadness fills his
eyes lord tyrion looks at danny then
says
he knew daenerys would burn king's
landing he then sits down after suddenly
feeling a bit dizzy finally danny says
did they orchestrate everything while
she is looking at lord helen reed yes
they did said a familiar voice from the
shadows as jon snow emerges from the
darkness he says everyone was exactly
where they were supposed to be
that was the very last thing bran said
to me right before he shipped me off to
spend the rest of my life at castle
black when drogon sees jon again he lets
out a thunderous scream so loud it feels
as if it shook the very foundation of
the castle the ravens that were circling
around the great hall immediately
scatter into the wind it looks like the
wind has been knocked right out of
daenerys after she sees jon for herself
greyworm and the unsullied ready their
weapons immediately arya and brienne do
the same
when genvara and makaro notice this they
step in front of jon hoping to avoid any
bloodshed just yet your grace jon says
nervously
i'm sorry for what happened i did not
know then what i'm beginning to
understand now lord tyrion is right bran
or i should say the children of the
forest knew exactly what would happen
they wanted all of us to destroy each
other i finally understand why bran said
i was exactly where i was supposed to be
he knew you would burn down king's
landing he must have seen it in one of
his visions and he knew that i would
execute you for that now i see why he so
easily sent me to the wall
he needed me out of the way but only
after i did what he knew i would do
john then looks at arya and says that's
why he sent an assassin after you he saw
you kill the night king he knew you
would be one of his biggest threats he
had to get rid of you the same way he
was getting rid of all of us once they
had the iron throne they no longer
needed any of us don't you see that now
brian
i'm not really
you died in that cave
you're a man
almost
i'm sorry i wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
if we choose you
will you wear the crown
[Music]
why do you think i came all this way
to go through all of that and
make your way home again only to find
such
chaos in the world
i can only imagine chaos is a ladder
the great hall is suddenly as silent as
a crypt everyone is looking around at
each other in disbelief but also
realizing what has been happening all
along daenerys begins walking forward
out from behind all of her guards
greyworm goes to stop her but she lays
her hand on his before shaking her head
no
she walks out across the great hall
until she is standing in front of helen
reed and jon snow dany looks in john's
eyes for several moments as she thinks
about everything that has been said she
looks over at helen reed then says i
guess now there is only one thing i want
to know how can we defeat them once and
for all
the scene ends right after helen reed
says well
we will defeat them the same way they
were using you and your dragon to kill
everyone in this city we will burn them
all in the final scene of this episode
we are back on the shore of the isle of
faces this scene begins by us getting a
good look at the full moon that is
sitting above the god's eye there are
hundreds of ravens circling in the sky
above all of the island's sacred
werewolves we watch as shadows shift
around in the woods no different than
any other night the green men are
getting ready to stand their silent
watch as they guard the isle of faces
thousands of little green men begin
emerging from within the woods as always
all of them are holding weapons of their
own their weapons are made up of
different dragonglass some of them are
black green and even red the faces on
the werewoods behind them are somehow
more frightening than they were before
they have hatred in their blood red eyes
they all have been sitting here silently
watching and waiting for thousands of
years it makes you wonder how many
horrific sacrifices they have seen over
those several millennia as soon as all
of the green men are standing in a
circle around the whole island something
else begins shifting in the shadows the
sound of branches breaking and the
leaves crunching under the footsteps is
very reminiscent of the sound of bones
breaking the little green men are not
the only ones watching and waiting on
this evening suddenly what looks like
100 000 glowing blue eyes begin emerging
from the darkness within the forest this
massive army is made up of nothing but
white walkers who are still riding on
the back of their giant elks only these
white walkers look slightly different
than the ones we've seen before
now as frightening as they look they
also have a bit of elegance to them
sort of like a haunting beauty all of
them begin surrounding the sacred island
as well
they're ready for whatever is heading
their way now we begin to move to the
center of the island where the largest
werewolf in westeros is located once
again we see the grove of seven
werewolves that are all facing inward at
each other right in the center of them
is a massive weirwood with a very large
open mouth on its face there are bones
and skulls scattered all around the
werewoods on the floor of the forest
this is where the episode will end the
final thing we see is what's inside this
massive weirwood the episode will fade
to black after we get a glimpse of
brandon stark sitting in this mouth of
madness like the three out raven before
brandon stark is entangled by the roots
of the weirwood it looks like the
children of the forest have made this
his new home
a home that he will never be able to
leave again
in the opening scene of this episode we
will see a massive army marching along
the king's road all of their footsteps
sound like the beating of a drum
there are thousands of soldiers made up
of the different armies throughout
westeros and even essos the soldiers of
the north are marching at the front of
the line as they are being led by jon
snow ghost helen reed giant spain
brianne sir podrick sir davos lorterian
and samwell right behind them are the
bannermen of house baratheon led by
gendry baratheon and arya stark
following right behind them are what
remains of the unsullied army as always
they are led by grey worm and right
behind them are the 1 000 slave soldiers
from the fiery hand who are led by
kinvara and makaro at the back of the
formation we can see there are about a
dozen small boats being held by some of
those slave soldiers each of those small
boats might be able to hold about 30 men
the sun is shining down on all of them
but not for long as the sun is resting
high in the sky it is suddenly smothered
by a massive black shadow when drogon
fully extends his enormous black wings
in front of it his dragon scales are
glistening as he soaks up the sunlight
right on the back of drogon is daenerys
who leans over on our side when the
dragon makes a hard left off the king's
road as they begin heading for a large
castle that is sitting off in the
distance the thousands of men below make
a left as well we go back to the front
of the army where jon snow and howl and
reed are riding on horseback the large
item that was on hallan reed's back is
now slung over the side of his horse
it's actually bouncing off the horse's
leg after every step it makes this is
when jon snow will ask helen reed what
he has been hiding under that blanket
helen reed flashes a faint smile before
he says you will see soon enough jon
snow it is a gift that i have brought
for you jon doesn't know whether to be
happy about this or not i'm not sure if
i like the sound of that says jon who
shows a thin smile as well right over
jon's shoulder we can see samwell on his
horse making his way to the front of the
line he rides up beside john and helen
reed right as jon begins asking him
something else john looks back over at
lord hallon then says how many of us do
you think will actually make it out of
this alive do you really think we will
be able to save bran helen reed doesn't
answer him right away he looks into the
sky and dragon and dany flying off in
the distance when he looks back at jon
he says well it's as i've said before
what will you be willing to sacrifice
jon snow now as for your brother bran i
will not make any assurances that you
will get him out of here alive but that
doesn't mean you can't help save
everyone else i know you want your
brother back believe me i do but you
also must remember his life isn't the
only one at stake jon silently looks
away he looks in front of him at the
castle that grows larger with each step
they make he watches as drogon and
daenerys fly in a circle above the
castle it's five long fingers reaching
into the sky
finally jon looks back at helen reed and
says what was your sacrifice my lord
when i met you out beyond the wall you
once said you made the greatest
sacrifice of all what did you mean by
that there is another long silence
before anything is said helen reed looks
in john's eyes and says my own flesh and
blood
i sacrificed my very own son jon snow
this new revelation stuns jon but before
he can follow up on what he said samwell
rides up alongside them with a letter in
hand i was hoping i could have a moment
with you before the battle begins says
samwell this was sent from the citadel
before you arrived in king's landing i
wasn't sure what to make of it at first
but i have a feeling you will know what
it means soon enough here i want you to
have it sam reaches out and hands john
the letter before falling back into
formation jon's eyes open up a little
wider as he unfolds the letter there is
an image in the center with a few words
written above it the only thing jon
focuses on is the drawing of what looks
like the face of a weirwood he studies
it for a few moments when jon begins
folding the letter we will see that this
werewolf's face is surrounded by fire
lord howland reed says we're here when
jon finally looks back up he sees an
island surrounded by a large blue lake
jon snow helen reed samwell davos
brienne and all the others begin hopping
off of their horses
arya gendry and lore tyrion lannister
walk up behind them everyone stands near
the edge of the water as they look out
across the lake at the sacred isle of
faces it doesn't look like anyone is
here says gendry it will not remain that
way says helen reed not when night falls
jon is resting his hand on the hilt of
his sword when he says then we better
get everyone over there before that
happens have the men start dropping the
boats in the water the sun will be
setting soon drogon and daenerys are
still flying above harrenhal they drop
down over the god's eye but when
daenerys looks down onto the island
she's not able to see anything through
all of the heavy brush having a bird's
eye view isn't really helping them at
least not yet it doesn't look like there
is anyone on the isle of faces from up
above either when daenerys sees them
dropping the boats into the water she
lands her dragon on the shore of the
lake we don't have enough boats for
everyone so make sure they are sent back
across until we get all of our men over
there on the island says jon one of the
northmen nods his head before stepping
into one of the small boats himself
helen reed grabs the large item from his
horse then he slings it back over his
shoulder lord tyrion lannister walks
over by sir podrick who is helping
berean with her armor he greets them
with a thin smile before he looks at
sarpodric and says i have something i
want to give you when he looks at
brienne she nods her head freeing him of
his duty he then follows lorterion who
walks around the other side of his horse
he watches him with uncertainty unsure
of what this is all about after another
moment lord tyrion emerges from behind
the horse and in his hands he is holding
a sword when he stands before him he
says this was my brother jaime's sword
it's no good in my hands i'm not sure if
you will need it but i can't think of a
better man alive that should have it my
lord this is valyrian steel says sir
podrick it is says lorterion it was made
from house stark's ancestral valyrian
steel sword brienne has one half and now
you have the other here he reaches out
and grabs the sword from his hands when
he holds it out in front of him the
fading sun glimmers off the ripples in
the blade thank you my lord says sir
podrick lord tyrion smiles then he walks
away we then see daenerys loading grey
worm and the unsolid men on the back of
her dragon the small boats are making
their way back across now
jon motions for samwell and davos they
follow him as he signals for lorterion
as well jon says i want you three to
stay over here now i don't mean to
offend any of you but if we don't
succeed without you i don't think 3
extra men will make that much of a
difference i'm hoping we are back before
sunrise jon then abruptly walks away
ghost follows right behind him he stops
one of his northmen as he makes his way
back near the shore jon says make sure
you unload the wagon full of dragonglass
now there is more than enough to fill
one of these boats on its own
jon had hundreds if not thousands of
dragonglass weapons brought down from
winterfell they were what was left over
from the long night battle against the
night king the northman bows his head
before walking away jon's eyes suddenly
look for the sky as he hears the sound
of a hundred screaming ravens from above
the isle of faces
it is a dreadful sound that reminds him
of why he is here kinvara and makaro
fallen next to jon as he walks alongside
the lake can vara's glowing red eyes
find john's she says your brother will
be waiting for you jon snow but he is no
longer the man that you think he is the
werewolds have corrupted his mind only
the purest death will cleanse his soul
now anger flashes inside jon's eyes he
grabs kenvara by the throat but he lets
go immediately after her red ruby burns
his hand why would you say that jon says
angrily we are sorry jon snow but this
night will be dark and full of terror
says konvara only the fire will burn
them all away now
jon runs over to the shore then signals
for everyone to get inside the boats he
looks at helen reed then yells we must
leave now lord helen reed jumps in the
boat then gives them a shove off the
shore when jon looks back he sees
kenvara standing there staring at him
her bright red ruby glowing all the
while the rest of the dozen or so boats
are filled with the slave soldiers of
verlor the ends of their weapons are now
lit up with a red and orange flame this
section of the lake almost looks as if
it's on fire the sun is now setting
there is a full moon sitting above the
god's eye on this evening as the
darkness falls the sacred isle of faces
finally starts to come alive the
shrieking sound of ravens are now heard
from the forest in the center of the
island this is followed up by the sound
of ominous screams that echo across the
silent lake
all of the soldiers that are standing in
formation on the shore of the isle of
faces begin looking at each other with a
hint of fear in their eyes the moonlit
sky is suddenly blackened as drogon and
daenerys circle around the island again
daenerys watches from above but she
still doesn't see any movement from
within the center of the forest gendry
walks over by arya then says do you feel
that feel what astoria the werewolf says
gendry do you feel them looking at you
because i do
arya looks at all the different
werewolves that surround the isle of
faces all of them are looking back at
them with hatred in their eyes the faces
look nothing like the face on the
werewood back at arya's home of
winterfell arya knows she is not welcome
here but she moves forward anyway all of
the 1000 slave soldiers of relore have
finally arrived on the island they begin
standing in formation waiting for the
signal grey worm as well as his unsolid
men are lined up beside them all of
gendry's bannermen and the men of the
north are now here also only a few of
them remain on the last of the boats
with jon snow and highland reed who are
landing ashore now when jon ghost and
lord helen reed jump out they grab their
boat and drag it up onto the beach they
walk around all of the soldiers to the
front of the formation as they watch the
final boat land on the shore as soon as
ken vara and makaro step foot on the
isle of faces a massive shadow falls
from the sky before unleashing a blue
fireball onto the lake the black shadow
vanishes back into the night sky as the
entire lake goes up in blue flames
everyone who's standing on the shore of
this sacred island is left feeling
stunned by how fast this happened
daenerys looks up into the sky thinking
whatever it was dropped down from above
her jon looks over at kinvara with a
sudden rage he thinks that she has
somehow done this since it happened
right after she stepped off the boat
makaro notices this so he walks over to
jon and sets his large hand on his
shoulder then says it has begun jon snow
there is no escaping this now they don't
want us leaving here alive the isle of
faces is now surrounded by a massive
blue ring of fire the reflection of the
flames are seen in the blood-red eyes of
ghost the white direwolf begins looking
into all of the eyes of the werewoods in
front of them we suddenly hear what
sounds like the screams of a thousand
dying voices from within the woods jon
snow ghost helen reed arya gendry
greyworm as well as everyone else begins
descending on the center of this island
in search of brandon stark black shadows
begin shifting throughout the woods all
around them while daenerys and drogon
are scanning the area from above dany
suddenly notices a massive fire start
from within the middle of the god's eye
dany does get a glimpse of small black
shadows dancing around the orange and
red flames
everyone on the ground is walking very
slowly dreading what lies ahead when jon
and the others look up they see hundreds
of ravens sitting on the branches
watching them with their white eyes as
they move inward all of them ready their
weapons as they see more and more
shadows shifting around in the woods
dragonglass arrows start raining down on
them from above
dozens of soldiers begin falling down
all around them where are they yells
giant spain they're up in the trees
brian shouts back everyone suddenly
looks above them they're not able to see
who they are or exactly what they are
all they see are yellow and golden cat's
eyes glowing back at them the slave
soldiers of the fiery hand rush in the
end of their weapons are lit up on fire
with orange and red flames they hold
their weapons near the bottom of the
trees catching them all on fire the
island begins burning from within then
in an instant the little green men jump
out of the sky with their dragonglass
weapons in hand landing all around them
everyone starts hacking and slicing at
the small green men in front of them and
now behind them brianne lops off one of
their heads with her valyrian steel
sword their great big golden cat's eyes
are still glowing as their heads go
bouncing off the ground one of the green
men sticks their dragonglass spear into
the back of gendry's leg but he spins
around and slices off its head in one
swift move helen reed falls as an arrow
goes into his shoulder and back he lets
out a scream as his body hits the ground
ghost dives through the air and sinks
his razor-sharp teeth into the face of
one of the small child-like soldiers we
watch as its golden and green eyes fade
to black as its life leaves its body
when one of the little green men jumps
on tormund giants bane's back he reaches
behind him and grabs it by its throat he
smashes its head against a rock while
screaming like a madman arya grabs her
valerian steel dagger then jams it into
the ear of one of the green men dropping
it instantly sir podrick slices another
one of them in half before dropping
another one from running up behind
buryin daggers and swords rise and fall
then rise and fall one after another
until the forest goes silent again the
little green men were in a match for
thousands of soldiers dressed in armor
jon helps helen reed get back on his
feet he still has the arrows in his back
and shoulder giant's bane walks over and
yanks them out he can still move on his
own gendry is now limping from the
injury in his leg but everyone else
seems to be fine for now all of them
began moving forward again even slower
than before after walking only a few
more feet jon and the others begin
hearing something else shifting around
in the dark woods in front of them in
the matter of moments there are suddenly
very large shadows all around them jon
raises a fist signaling for everyone to
stop where they are everyone falls
silent as they listen to the sound of
leaves crunching and branches breaking
in the darkness the slave soldiers of
relore hold out their weapons in front
of them hoping to see what's out there
around them as their flames drive away
the shadows jon's eyes have a sudden
look of disbelief when he starts to see
blue eyes faintly glowing all around him
their eyes look at the sky when they
unexpectedly hear a thunderous scream
from a dragon ring out across the island
the resurrected rhaegal drops from the
sky
daenerys is so horrified by the sight
and sound of regal she nearly falls off
drogon but she holds herself up by one
of his spikes rhaegal immediately lets
out his blue flame but drogon dives
through the sky in order to dodge it
samwell davos and loretarian are still
standing near the water on the other
side of the lake they begin running for
the castle of harrenhal when they see
rhaegal emerge in the night sky
everything lights up with red and blue
flames as the dragons unleash their fire
on each other one after another back on
the ground jon and everyone else form a
line as they see the glowing eyes move
in for the kill some of rhaegal's blue
fireballs begin striking the island
lighting up everything around them they
suddenly see what's heading their way
there are dozens and dozens of white
walkers riding on the backs of giant
elks the slave soldiers of verlor rush
in to deliver the first blow one by one
the white walkers begin snuffing out
their flaming weapons as each of the
soldiers lifeless bodies slam onto the
ground as the forest burns down all
around them daenerys can finally see
what's happening on the ground below her
from her view we can see there are
roughly 100 white walkers closing in on
everyone down below dany watches as
greyworm throws his dragonglass spear
shattering one of the white walkers and
the giant elks it was riding on the
unsolid men move in their weapons give
them a slight advantage here since the
white walkers are now high off the
ground they form a shield around
everyone standing in the center as the
white walkers rush forward they all
thrust their spears out at once
shattering several of them before they
can break their wall now when some of
the other white walkers see this they
start charging on their giant elks this
begins knocking most of the unsolid men
down as they run them over smashing some
of their skulls beneath their feet
dragonglass weapons are flying through
the air everywhere white walkers shatter
again but not all of them some of the
dragonglass misses and it unfortunately
hits a few of their own men dropping
them instantly when one of the white
walker sees jon it jumps down from the
elk with a nice sword in hand
jon greets him with his own sword in
hand the white walker swings its glowing
ice sword right at jon's head but it
misses by only inches after jon bends
down to avoid it raidus john launches
back up he brings his sword with him but
this white walker raises his own ice
sword to block it their swords smash
into each other in the air when the
swords meet a shattering sound rings out
throughout the forest the white walker's
lice sword is fine it was actually
john's valyrian steel sword that
shattered you see these white walkers
are unlike the ones we have seen before
they themselves can still die by
valyrian steel and dragonglass but their
ice weapons are much stronger than their
last ones
the children of the forest at the isle
of faces made sure of that while jon is
standing there in disbelief holding
nothing but his sword's handle the white
walker brings its ice sword high above
his head moments away from delivering
his fatal blow as soon as the white
walker brings his sword down sir podrick
drives his own valyrian steel sword
through the back of this white walker's
head shattering it before it can kill
jon after only a few seconds jon finally
gathers his senses then he grabs a
dragonglass weapon from the ground
before entering the fight again this is
when the resurrected rhaegal will drop
out of the sky unleashing his blue flame
on dozens of unsolid men standing on the
ground another one of the white walkers
riding on one of the giant elks comes
rushing through the field a handful of
gendry's bannermen dive out of the way
before they get ran over kinvara
suddenly finds herself standing there
all alone before she can move the
massive elk lowers its head driving its
rack of antlers right through her body
out her back when makaro sees that
happen he lets out an agonizing scream
he immediately raises his six foot long
iron staff high above his head on the
end of his staff is a dragon's head as
he continues to let out this booming
scream the dragon's eyes begin to glow
green he suddenly swings down the staff
in a slicing motion and when he does
this the dragon's head spits out a green
flame that ignites everything in front
of it dozens of white walkers and their
elks go up in flames instantly we can
hear the sound of crackling ice as white
walkers let out a scream of their own as
they burn alive this allows jon and
everyone else to finally move forward
again most of the isle of faces is now
on fire there are red orange green and
blue flames everywhere
davos lorterion and samwell are
horrified as they watch from below the
castle of harrenhal all they're able to
see is fire from where they're at it
doesn't look like anyone will make it
out of there alive as everyone else is
moving through the woods helen reed
stops jon before they go any further
wait says helen reed there is something
you will need if you're gonna end this
tonight lord helen reed drops the large
item from his back
john has been wondering what this is as
he unfolds it from the blankets and furs
jon suddenly sees the reflection of
fires in the steel i know valerian steel
when i see it says jon where did you get
that its name is dark sister it was once
lord brendan rivers he gave it to me
years ago and he said i would one day
give it to you when the moment was right
you no longer have a sword of your own i
guess now is as good a time as any john
holds the sword firmly in his hands then
he nods his head and rushes forward into
the flames the grove of seven werewoods
is right up ahead but everyone is
suddenly stopped when another wave of
white walkers and giant elks head their
way as jon looks behind them he can see
the biggest wear what he's ever seen in
his life he fixes his eyes on the
enormous mouth at the base of it as he
looks inside he instantly notices bran
is sitting there with his eyes rolled
back in his head bran john whispers he
says the name again only louder bran
everyone looks at john who then sticks
out his sword in brian's direction they
all see him sitting in the weirwood now
as well arya grabs her dagger with her
left hand before throwing it out in
front of her the dagger slices right
into one white walker shattering it
immediately but the dagger continues
flying through the air until it hits a
white walker right behind it shattering
that one also the fires on the floor of
the forest begin spreading all around
them mocaro raises the iron staff in the
air again shooting out another green
flame from the dragon's mouth the grove
of weirwoods in front of them began to
go up in flames jon screams out no
we must get brian out of there however
the werewoods all around him are now
burning locking bran inside a green ring
of fire john and arya run in to get him
but the massive flames stop them from
moving any further they run around the
circle of werewoods looking for another
opening but they don't see one
white walkers are still descending on
their location
gendry grabs arya by her shoulder he
yells if we don't leave now we will die
here
brienne and greyworm are still fighting
off the enemy sir podrick is rolling
around on the ground some of his armor
is melting while his uniform is on fire
it's absolute madness on the isle of
faces helen reed finds jon again he
screams john's name before he says get
back to the shore now daenerys needs you
your brother brian is inside that dragon
you cannot save him but maybe you can
save her right as helen reed says that a
white walker shoves his eye sword
through his back and out the front of
his belly john looks at helen reed's
eyes as he drops on his knees with blood
running out of his mouth this snaps john
out of his haze now before the white
walker removes the ice sword from helen
reed's lifeless body jon angrily shoves
his own sword into the white walker's
neck after it shatters jon runs back to
where they first landed on the island
everything is burning behind him there
are red green orange and blue flames
everywhere the dragons vanish as they
fly through all of the smoke that is
right above the isle of faces only
drogon and daenerys emerge on the other
side they do a couple circles around the
island looking for regal but they don't
see him neither does jon daenerys and
drogon fly back into the black smoke
again only now when they come out the
other side rhaegal is locked onto
drogon's wing the undead dragon is
biting and scratching holes and drogon's
side the dragons are now spinning wildly
out of control until regal releases and
vanishes back into the smoke jon starts
waving his sword hoping dany notices it
she lands the dragon near him anyway
when jon runs over by her dany yells
down drogon is hurt badly jon looks at
the holes in drogon's wing then he
shouts back will he still be able to fly
i think so says danny although i don't
know how much longer john yells out
again let me go up with you let me help
you now before danny answers she looks
into the woods where there are now white
walkers running their way get on shouts
daenerys rhaegal drops back down out of
the sky one of the white walkers grabs
his ice spear as jon is climbing on
drogon's back
raidus john sits down behind dany drogon
lifts from the ground the white walker
throws his magical ice weapon missing
drogon only by a few feet as the dragon
soars into the sky rhaegal dives down
behind him following them into the smoke
john yells out i need you to get above
him why shouts danny what will you do
after a few seconds jon says i don't
know
drogon ascends further into the night
sky rising higher and higher they stay
inside of the thick black smoke for
several moments almost as if they're
hiding from regal as soon as dany sees
the resurrected dragon down below them
she has drogon dive down hundreds of
feet he slices right through the air
like a speeding bullet then as sudden as
a thunderbolt a shrieking drogon dives
onto regal locking his fangs around the
other dragon's neck the dragons were now
locked together as they begin falling
out of the sky the lake was suddenly
rushing up at them with incredible speed
as the dragons fall further and further
jon snow stands up on drogon's back with
the valerian steel sword dark sister in
his hand within the blink of an eye jon
launches himself off drogon's back as he
is flying through the sky he raises dark
sister high above his head daenerys is
horrified as she watches this when jon
falls down onto rhaegal he drives the
valyrian steel sword through the
dragon's eye
he shoves it in with so much force the
end of the blade drives out the back of
rhaegal's throat the resurrected dragon
lets out an agonizing scream that can be
heard throughout the isle of faces
jon hangs on for dear life as the dragon
drops out of the sky half a heartbeat
later rhaegal struck the lake sending
thousands of gallons of water up into
the sky daenerys looks down and watches
as the dragon slips beneath the water
the like boiled with dragon's blood and
then was still
daenerys immediately lands drogon on the
shore of the god's eye arya ghost
brienne and gendry come running out from
the blazing woods behind them every
single one of the werewoods are now on
fire dany screams out at arya there is
dread on her voice jon went into the
water with rhaegal says danny silence
falls over the isle of faces everyone's
fearful eyes look over at the lake
hoping jon emerges from below ghost
begins running up and down the shore
searching for jon's body the episode
will fade to black as we see air bubbles
breaking on the surface of the water
in the early morning hours of the
following day we begin with an overhead
shot of the god's eye everything on this
sacred island had went up in flames the
ancient werewoods that once inhabited
the isle of faces are nearly gone the
ones that are still standing will never
look the same again
all of their red leaves have vanished
their faces are now blackened by the
ashen smoke even their red eyes now look
black there are still some small fires
burning around the island there are
thousands of dead bodies littered all
over the forest floor some of them are
even still holding dragonglass weapons
in their hand right on the shore of the
god's eye arya ghost gendry brienne
daenerys and greyworm are standing there
looking out over the lake none of them
are saying anything they're just
standing there hoping jon snow will
emerge from below the water deep down
arya stark knows he has been under the
water for far too long on the other side
of this lake we can see davos lortirian
lannister and samwell walking away from
harrenhal as they head for the shoreline
as the sun is rising over the horizon
something glimmers in the water arya
begins walking forward when she notices
this the inside of her boots instantly
fill up with water as she walks out into
the lake
after only a few steps she bends down
then grabs something from below the
surface of the water when she lifts it
up into the air the morning sunlight
begins reflecting off the blade after
looking at it for only a few moments
arya says this is valyrian steel whose
sword is this dany sucks in a breath
when she recognizes what it is that's
the sword jon shoved into rhaegal's eye
before they slammed into the lake says
danny its name is dark sister says
gendry i saw lord helen reed give that
sword to jon during the battle arya's
voice cracks when she says i will hold
it for him before she slides dark sister
behind the belt around her hip daenerys
walks away grey worm and brianne follow
behind her they begin walking through
the smoking forest on the isle of faces
as they make their way into the center
of the island we see nothing but death
and destruction all around them drogon
begins flying around above them as they
move further and further into the forest
right up ahead them lies what was once a
grove of seven werewoods surrounded by
one massive werewood in its center
brienne suddenly stops when she hears a
voice whisper her name she runs over
when she notices sir podrick is still
alive laying on the ground most of his
uniform has been burned off of him she
helps him slowly get back on his feet
she then grabs his arm and throws it
around her shoulder so she can help him
walk away arya and gendry are walking
their way now brienne suddenly notices
someone else as she waits for them
giant's bane lies only a few feet away
he is unfortunately dead he must have
been killed by one of the white walkers
since it doesn't look like he died by
the fire brienne kneels down next to his
body she lays her hand on his face
before shutting his eyes she stays there
kneeling for a few moments until arya
and gendry walk right by them without
saying anything arya is walking to the
center of the island she wants to see
what happened to bran for herself
daenerys and greyworm are already
standing there by what was once a
massive weirwood when daenerys looks
over her shoulder and sees that it's
arya walking over she drops her head
down then walks away arya stops when she
is standing in the middle of the grove
of burnt werewoods there is black smoke
rising out of the mouth of the giant
werewolf bran was sitting in when arya
bends down and looks inside its mouth
she sees there are hundreds of bones
inside some of them look very small even
some of the skulls are childlike when
she looks further into the center she
does see a set of bones that are much
larger the roots of the werewood are
wrapped all around them there is water
in her eyes when she walks away without
saying a word gendry follows her in
silence everyone is ready to get the
hell out of here
what should we do now says lord tyrion
when dany sits down on the back of
jurgon she says you will have to figure
that out for yourself i'm leaving
westeros for good everyone seems a
little shocked by this i thought you
might want to come back to king's
landing says lorterian lannister
greyworm looks over at danny waiting to
see what she will say
after only a few moments daenerys says
it was all i ever thought about not long
ago i thought that's what i wanted but
after seeing most of the seven kingdoms
i have realized this isn't what i want
not anymore grey worm smiles right as
danny goes to leave on drogon a voice
shouts wait arya walks over near her
dragon when she looks at dany she says
how do we know you won't come back and
burn everything down again with your
dragon
well
i guess you never will says dany right
before her and drogon launch into the
sky
everyone stands there watching in
silence as the massive black dragon gets
smaller and smaller above them finally
lore tyrion looks at samwell and davos
then says well what about you guys i
don't think so says samwell i want to go
home with my family i don't think i will
be back in king's landing either says
lord davos i have a home of my own lord
tyrion lannister is left standing there
alone as samwell and davos walk away
lady brianne and sir podrick walk over
by where arya and gendry are standing
will you be making your way back to
winterfell says brienne i am heading
that way myself i thought maybe we could
go together no says arya i still have no
desire to go home but i wish you good
fortune on your journey arya shakes her
hand then her and gendry walk away
as we watch most of these characters
head in different directions the screen
will suddenly fade to black but only for
a few moments when the next scene begins
it will be several weeks later the very
first thing we see is the red keep in
king's landing we see the great hall
where the iron throne set for hundreds
of years this enormous castle that once
housed many different kings over the
centuries now sits vacant the following
thing we see is samwell gilly little sam
and their newborn baby boy john they are
now at samwell's family home in horn
hill they're all sitting outside
overlooking the gorgeous landscape
little sam is sitting on gilly's lap
while sam is holding his son john
they're all much happier here the next
thing we see is sir davos standing at
the front of a ship that's out at sea
then we see lorterian lannister riding
on a horse we watch as he arrives at his
family's ancestral home of casterly rock
this is the home that his father said he
would never get for himself in the
following scene we see sansa stark
sitting at the head of the table in
winterfell's great hall standing
directly behind her are lady brienne and
sir podrick they are now members of
sansa stark's very own queens guard now
that sir podrick has widow's whale and
brienne has oath keeper hal stark's
ancestral valyrian steel sword ice is
back inside the walls of winterfell
guarding ned stark's daughter the next
thing we see is arya stark and gendry
standing at the main gates of storm's
end as zarya looks in gendry's eyes she
says i want to thank you for what you
have done
gendry smiles then nods his head
i really mean that says arya thank you
for everything thank you for always
being such a great friend
don't mention it my lady says gendry you
know my offer still stands gendry says
next and what offer is that asked arya
well says gendry the one i offered you
back in winterfell i would love it if
you would however before gendry's able
to finish the sentence arya leans in and
gives him a kiss on the lips this moment
will end without us knowing what will
actually happen next maybe arya stays or
maybe she doesn't after this we will see
daenerys riding on the back of drogon
high in the sky we can see they are
flying over the old smoking ruins of
valyria it looks like daenerys has a
smile on her face as her and drogon fly
off into the distance
now during the final moments of my
version of game of thrones season 9 we
will go back to the god's eye everything
on the sacred island has finally been
overrun by the flames the werewoods are
not even recognizable anymore the only
thing that inhabits the isle of faces
now are the dead bodies that were left
over from the final battle there is
however one thing still alive on this
island sitting there along the shore of
the lake is ghost it looks as if he
hasn't went anywhere else in weeks the
reflection of the water is seen in his
blood red eyes all he does now is sit
here and watch waiting for any sign of
jon snow it's obvious that ghosts will
die here before he ever leaves john's
sight again
this final episode will fade to black as
we see ghosts still sitting there
looking out over the lake of the god's
eye
[Music]
you